thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
chess is great for the brain but it's
also fun to play and chess kid makes it
easy to have fun whether your child is a
total beginner or a prodigy they can hop
on and find a well-matched opponent from
around the world at any time chess kit
is the safe parent-approved way for your
child to play chess online
chess kid is educational
it's it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest puzzles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
foreign
cgc we're here it's about to go down
y'all turn up let's go
I'm excited for this here it is y'all
see it
but it's for real oh my God it's kind of
cool this is excellent
wow that is so gorgeous yeah you're
right that water don't look friendly
yeah let me try to get in there bro wow
look at the view here I am way off the
ground right now look at that it's just
so peaceful right here yeah I mean it's
so cute it's like water all right come
on down
yeah so we're gonna play chestnuts
helicopter all right let's get it let's
go
okay
who won
can we watch the balls yeah sure yes
wow that is so gorgeous oh man wow
really over Niagara Falls we're on a
helicopter what are you doing
huge shout out to chess.com
we're Landing wow that was incredible
that was super cool that was incredible
got the same favorites being Nemo
us well I don't know we're the fan
favorite friends I think you know okay
it's fine yeah fan favorites yeah yeah
let's go with that
check out chess.com's newest mobile
release for Android and iOS now with
game review
game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play use
retry mistakes to get another shot at
finding missed opportunities
game review is available today on both
Android and iOS
download our app and try it yourself
[Music]
foreign
the one Hotel Toronto Prides itself on
its Forest feel and eco-friendliness
this week its doors are open to some of
the best players in Pro chess today
while some players are on the brink of
going home others are poised to move one
step closer to the two hundred thousand
dollar first prize
it's day two of the quarterfinals at the
chess.com Global championship and it
starts right now
in Vancouver but as wonderful as Andrea
and Vancouver are it's pretty tough not
to fall in love with the city of Toronto
natural beauty abounds inside Toronto
and pretty close by
the largest city in Canada the people
here have been playing chess and clubs
in universities and in public parks for
well over a century remember when
amaranth played chess in the hot tub
and now this wonderful place plays host
to the very first chess.com Global
championship finals
facing elimination for weeks eight of
the world's best players have survived
to continue their quest for the
queen-size share of the one million
dollar prize pool go get a garba's face
the car was like really wait what is
going on is he playing a fun club I'm
speechless
my friends you're in the right place
it's time for the cgc finals Toronto
Canada officially has it all
thank you once again to the boat test
sisters Canada indeed does have it all
and once again we will have all the
action from downtown Toronto as we move
into the start of the second day here at
the cgc finals and on that note we
welcome you once again inside the
gameplay Hall at one Hotel Toronto I'm
Danny wrench alongside Grand Master
Daniel noraditsky fide Master James
Canty International Master Levy Rosman
and even a Hikaru Nakamura there in the
background chat we're excited to have
you back with us of course we look
forward to hearing from you throughout
the entire day so stay with us keep it
coming guys before we dig into the day
ahead we know we got a lot to unpack
here let's talk about yesterday here's
how the games played out here's where we
stand what are the matchups giving us of
course right at the top everyone knows
Hikaru Nakamura showed up and he he took
what he wanted in that match with yonsha
stuff Duda Wesley so leads three to one
over on draken Anish Geary has a two and
a half to one and a half lead over tame
over java and Sam sevian has the same
lead over Nihao Soren so much to talk
about in terms of how we got here as we
as we reflect guys on how we got here in
the day yesterday Donya your biggest
takeaway biggest highlight from day one
I said I'm gonna choose the Wesley match
because nothing was normal about them
that match that match went off the rails
so quickly just consider the fact that
both of Wesley's wins were the black
pieces game one was insane Dimitri and
Drake and jumped out to a completely
winning position with black I stopped
watching then apparently Wesley missed
Maiden two and that game somehow ended
in the draw that was in the decisive
game but Dimitri on Drake and just sort
of forfeiting the white pieces and then
taking that draw in game three which I'm
sure he's regretting yeah because he had
a big attack he needs to come through it
with a massive performance today but
most importantly he's got to keep
playing well with black and he's got to
capitalize on those opportunities it was
super wild you know we talked about Duda
being until on Dragon after not winning
that game one maybe never recovered we
didn't talk about that can't he what was
your favorite matchup of yesterday mine
was uh the Sam Sabian and the nihal
sarin with that of course I actually did
a percentage check in fact Sam right now
is playing out of his mind right take
the first game accuracy what you think
it was what'd you think first game
accuracy 97 okay it was 95. 95 right
both of them second game right so this
is where uh Sam won it was a one he won
by uh 95 I think there well but nehal
was 70 so that was huge so if he keeps
having this percentage drop like this
it's gonna be bad and then the next two
games were both 90 above and the last
game was 98.5 by both of them nasty
you got what was your favorite matchup
yesterday I mean you got to give some
love to the giri rajable like we gotta
remind the audience there's a matchup of
friends so it's an interesting situation
they're the two most balanced players in
the event but you have an Unstoppable
force in Anish giri who has had the most
brilliant Moves In the Event versus Timo
rajabo yeah only lost six percent of his
games I wish I could say the same it's
probably more like 66 percent of my
games so giri took the early lead
interesting to see what happens today
yeah you know those two guys are known
for being balanced we talk about on the
insides but all those games were wild
between Geary and rajaba of course the
only matchup we didn't touch on is the
one I hit at the top of the day Hikaru
Nakamura over youngsta stuff Duda you
know he has a four game lead it was it
was shocking I think for all of us to
see it get away from John schistov the
way it did especially the decision of
course to play the bond Cloud to some
criticism right yarn sure stuff had
white there was an opportunity there
maybe to strike back there especially
because remember he was winning game two
with white or at least clearly better
right so I was I was surprised to see
that we'll see where that leads us into
day two and and whether NACA continues
to hold on so all right well for those
not with us yesterday a reminder that
due to some tricky Logistics we have
five players here in Toronto and of
course we have three players playing
online in Serbia let's remind everybody
where they sit who they are Wesley so
and Anish Geary now not here yet they're
at the top of course neither is Sam
sevian the truth is the more I look at
it's a car Nakamura sitting solo here in
the in the studio behind us Jan shift of
Judah also not here yet so all five will
be with us at some point in Toronto
they're not here neither are the
gentleman in Serbia where are they each
one of them may be getting a little bit
extra game time in their in their prep
because they all have to fight back in
their respective matches Dimitri on
Drake and Tamer of a job of and nihal
sarin so all right guys well
except Judah
every other player that's losing is in
Serbia right the Toronto players lead
what do we expect from the players from
Serbia today and if you had to pick a
matchup that might turn around which one
is it yeah that's a great question I
think if I were to reason objectively
the match that is most likely to turn on
percentage-wise is maybe nihal against
M7 because all of those games were very
close but again I'm still very intrigued
by this Wesley so Dimitri on Drake and
match because we've seen so many
incredible performances by Dimitri
throughout the RCC throughout all the
online events so I'm expecting more
aggressive play by Dimitri I'm expecting
interesting openings of the black pieces
and I love Danny watching matches where
one of the players says they're back
against the wall because they often play
stuff that they don't normally play we
see stylistic tendencies that we don't
normally see yeah I'm Gonna Keep a close
eye on the Wesleyan Drake yeah I just
want to give myself a little bit of
credit yesterday when we talked about do
we like to play online or over the board
I said the three guys in Serbia have a
tough task because they're not here
right are they going to get in the right
headspace well they're all trailing we
still got some games today but for now
like to just give myself a pat on the
back about that
um yeah here's what I think has to
happen rajabov and nihal have to up the
ante they got to up the level they gotta
up the intensity Dimitri and draken he's
got to chill out a little bit okay stuff
yesterday with the white pieces he was
getting worse positions in the first 10
moves with black he was all right but
with white he was very shaky if that
continues West is going to be out of
here in one hour maybe two hours max no
you're right those games were absolutely
nutty of course as we were highlighting
missed mates and missed winning
positions maybe on Drake it needs to
relax a little bit Canty uh your
thoughts on what the guys in Serbia are
feeling in a matchup that might turn
around if you had to pick one I love
this Serbia losing they all got to step
it up that's pretty obvious right so of
course uh nihal definitely needs to up
that percentage I think on draken
actually yeah it depends I mean he has
to tone it down but then again maybe he
can turn it up a little bit I mean I
know we know he's very uh wildlike I
think right we have no idea it didn't
make any sense yeah I think some nerves
I think everyone's a little nervous
right I'm the first Global championship
and I want to say I do agree that Soren
the reason I still think nihal has a
chance not just because Sam you know was
the underdog getting here he has that
unique story but Soren was not himself
yesterday the accuracy score speaks to
it right he wasn't playing his best
chess will that turn around on day two
we're gonna find out but all right one
player who doesn't need to turn it
around he's definitely feeling good
about himself is Hikaru Nakamura he's up
4-0 that is not a typo over Yan shustoff
Duda NACA only needs a draw to advance
to the semi-finals he's fresh off his
win at the Fisher random World Chess
Championship ship as well and Nemo sat
down with a car to talk about his
expectations for the cgc
[Music]
obviously after playing in Iceland and
doing well I'm just looking forward to
the CG scene hopefully I can win this
one too
nice to have you here in Toronto
excited for the cgc yeah it's um I was
here a couple weeks ago in Toronto
filming some other stuff so it's good to
be back where would you personally rank
rapid chess a mom's Pro chess formats
for me rapid is I would say right now is
close to my favorite or uh or it's one
of the two rapper Blitz but definitely
not classical I also think that with
less time more blunders occur so that's
why rapid I think is a truer test of of
your overall skill ability Blitz will
always be my favorite if there if
there's nothing on the line how is
preparing for a rapid tournament like
cgc different from preparing for a large
over-the-board tournaments is there a
difference what's your process like um I
don't think it's much different
classical chess has to be quite a bit
deeper you have to do look at many
different lines many different
possibilities and Rapid generally I
think if you have an idea and you look
at a couple of lines before the game
that's for the most part good enough I
found I was going to ask you what are
your own internal expectations for
competing this week as I said I'm just
going to try to play my game and if it's
good enough it's good enough if it's not
it's not but I don't really think about
anything else I love that answer just
playing the chess that's great
foreign
[Music]
thank you again Nemo that was awesome
you know asicara mentioned guys and as
everyone knows he won the Fisher random
World Chess Championship in Iceland
there's his path as he made his way at
34 years of age into our cgc finals here
in Toronto that insights shows he plays
88 of his rapid games on chess.com in
the morning I think that's partly
because we've historically stacked our
biggest rapid events the pro chess
League Global Champs in in the morning
but I I want to kick up with a big topic
that maybe is uh surprising or not but
it's hard it's like our Nakamura playing
the best chess of anyone on the planet
right now human I think that's entirely
fair to say I mean I think the accuracy
could be debated but he's doing a heck
of a lot of winning and what tends to
happen when you know athletes have this
kind of stretch in their careers as you
think well okay Yamcha stuff is going to
be an obstacle you know Magnus Carlson
is going to be an obstacle but right now
he car is making it look easy against
absolutely everybody yeah no he has and
you know Levy you you cover this guy for
your YouTube channel you know his games
and content as well as anybody are you
seeing a Hikaru 960 or not it's still
chess and maybe even more representative
of your form and that you don't have
opening prep right so when you look at
Hikaru what do you see about his chest
right now yeah I was going to say chess
is a right now is a game that you could
be a grand master in when you're 15 or
16 years old and you're the best the
younger you are generally in any sport
the better you can be a teenager you
could be in your 20s people very rarely
absolutely Skyrocket the level of their
play in their 30s and he's just doing it
he's just no questions asked he's gone
on massive winning streaks his winning
percentage in live and online events has
been just unbelievable I don't think
there's a single person it seems who can
slow him down well I have to say that of
course I always say this by iCarly's
half man and then the other half we
don't actually know yet so when you said
human he was like okay yeah I had to
clarify half a human right in fact right
because the other half is like we just
we don't know to play that kind of Chess
right but also of course that just goes
back to his discipline the hard work
that he does he streams eight hours on a
Tuesday every Tuesday 12 hours 12 hours
that's ridiculous wins both events both
events right you know Mr 50 mail I don't
even get the 2 000 from just com okay
let me get that extra money right but of
course at the same time he's paying
excellent chess right and it just goes
back to that work once again dude it's
so crazy because I also try to play
every title Tuesday yeah I think the
last time I won a title Tuesday was
maybe I won the very first one
apparently in 2014 after that I had a
bit of a cold streak lasting eight years
so listen I can attest for a stand to
the fact that none of the tournaments
Hikaru wins are are easy or gimmies I
mean everybody's strong
and like just the consistency that's
been displayed in like the last year
from the candidates to the Fisher random
tournament to to yesterday is is just
honestly honestly breathtaking it's
crazy well regardless of how we got
there he's 34 years old so there's a lot
of time left in his career Vision on
didn't become world champion until 38
right so who knows what I mean maybe
globally will come at 34 but all right
let's let's turn to today everybody uh
here's how each of the four matches sit
at the halfway point we are in the
quarterfinals as we've been talking a
lot about Hikaru Nakamura with a
commanding position over youngsta stuff
Duda Wesley so almost as dominant over
Dimitri on draken but I agree with Levy
I think that the games were so wild who
knows what could happen Anish Geary and
Sam sevian have leads to protect will
they play too cautious uh you know real
quick Donya your thoughts on the matchup
uh the matchup that you're most looking
forward to well I'll go back to Wesley's
match against Dimitri I kind of pointed
out that I'm expecting some Wild play by
Dimitri I mean he has gotten amazing
positions of the black pieces that's the
most ironic thing about the match if you
know that fact alone hey Dimitri was
winning in game one and much better in
game three you'd say I mean Dimitri
never loses with white so the fact that
he's down 3-1 is absolutely crazy but
I'm expecting much more topical openings
with the white pieces from Dimitri and
Drake and I think that's his only chance
and obviously in the other matches where
one side is down by a point I mean Timur
is gonna have to up up the
anti-aggression wise and and so is nihal
nihal Saran I don't know if the London
is going to work again if he wants to
make a push to equalize the score
against Sam Sevin you said Andrea needs
to calm down how do you calm down when
you're down 3-1
that's actually a very good point Danny
that's an excellent point well first I'm
glad I'm not playing right the white
Pieces Just got to get regular positions
he can't be giving points away right and
now having said that the only two losses
that he had were with the white pieces
we talked about Geary versus rajab
Anisha has to keep doing what he's doing
but we do have to keep in mind that
rajava played two Sicilians yesterday
right when you play Sicilian Defense not
E5 on the first move you're kind of
showing an indication and a willingness
to fight maybe he's going to go back to
E5 I'm really Keen to seeing that match
when he tries to strike he's going to
show to show up game one things are a
little bit calm and that's when he's
going to try to you know surprise the
niche and win I don't know that that one
could go seven or eight yeah I wouldn't
be surprised if there's an army getting
there I'm hoping farmer getting as a fan
I will admit okay you're Sam seville's
coach helping him getting that right
mindset the right mindset that he was in
yesterday what are you telling him
hopefully he at the gym this morning we
did have a talk right at first of course
he was like are you a big dude man so we
started talking about his business and
he uh definitely is working right now if
he keeps doing his 90 is how he's doing
keeping up that consistency it's gonna
be hard for nehal to strike back of
course course the knee-haul I definitely
has to up that percentage can't slip
really anywhere because Sam is playing
really strong chess right now
all right well at the start of the cgc a
few months ago everybody we had
thousands of you participate in our cgc
bracket challenge no none of you were
able to win the 100 000 for the perfect
bracket don't don't beat yourself up
about it but here's how you've all
picked today's matches uh no surprise I
guess they're at the top uh very very
heavily weighted toward people
predicting Hikaru Wesley so Dimitri on
draken Wesley also a big favorite by the
community the Anish giri verjava much
closer to a coin flip and the real one
that I guess has everyone kind of you
know second guessing themselves right
now as Sam sebian has a lead despite the
community predicting by about 65 percent
that Soren was the favorite so uh yeah I
mean this is this is an interesting
Community keep with us of course but uh
we are also making our picks all week as
you know you saw us do it yesterday so
let's check in with who we picked
yesterday for one of the tighter matches
that we're going to be talking about
here as the quarterfinals move on Gary
Raja Donya do you remember who you
picked yeah I picked two more that
hasn't aged very well okay and I think
Anish just stepped out for a second so
let me just finish this really really
quickly I'm going to stick listen I
believe I'm sticking with your
predictions I'm going to stick with you
more I also think high probability mode
Armageddon so you know Buckle in we'll
see well I picked Anish giri so I want
him to hear that where you at bro um I I
did pick a niche Gary it's not just
because he's here always watching
judging waiting lurking something he's
going to Tweet about you later you never
know where he's going to strike next but
I did take a niche I think he's an
underrated rapid player I wouldn't be
upset if this one went to over again but
I'm gonna stick with my pick a niche as
well I'm definitely going with these
gear as well Mr super GM drip Master
himself of course with uh with having
the suits and the ties and the socks you
should have seen him in the interview
that's a heavy praise
he's just missing the bling right yeah I
got one for him right all right but
Anish Gary's my pick for sure yeah
listen I'd chosen each Geary yesterday I
gotta stick with him he's I think he's
just a slight tiny tiny bit difference
in that imagine he really showed it
yesterday and I I don't know we'll see
more over extend in trying to fight back
or you're leaving me out to dry too yeah
my partner my co-commentator yep I see I
see see how it is take no comment
hikaru's over the shoulder I don't I
don't think he's too much too worried
about whether anyone's picking Young's
just off at this point we'll see how
that goes and uh all right well there
were our picks everybody uh we will see
of course how giri Raja pans out and
that's going to do it for us here
everyone in chat stay with us we will
see you a bit later as we rejoin the
super exciting announcements ahead today
involving Magnus Carlson and one of our
upcoming tournaments but for now let's
bring in our commentators I'm mon
Hamilton and Robert Hess fellas we're
going to kick it over to you good to see
you this morning as we push toward the
start of game five for all of our
matches appreciate you Danny and
everybody else over there hope you have
fun but Amman yesterday was a lot of fun
for some of the players others reeling
licking their wounds what do you think
day two has in store for us well one
thing I know for sure Robert is that day
two has winners in store for us we are
going to find out who actually wins
these matches and moves on to the next
round that's why day twos are so
exciting I mean you have the the big
comeback potential and you have those
tight matches that could go either way
it's true and remind everybody of the
tournament format it is two games excuse
me two days of eight games four on each
day a month we saw at halftime with some
players happy with how things went in
this 15 minute plus two second increment
time Patrol but today's the day even if
you were down on day one you can strike
back and if we're lucky or and Danny
wrench gets happy we will have
Armageddon as well that's right the you
know chess.com Global Championship
features the ever exciting Armageddon
format and the way they've done it with
the bidding procedure you know I've
called so many of those matches
alongside yourself even as well and it's
just so exciting to watch so obviously
you know all biases aside just as a Pure
Chess fan Robert I do want to see some
Armageddon today oh well one player who
would love to see Armageddon is that man
on screen in front of you Jan shisto
Duda he is down four to nothing he needs
to win all four games just to have a
shot as we take a look at the insights
between these two players among what
stands out to me Hikaru Nakamura the
much more experienced player loving
those Wild Games indeed and you know
chess.com has got to put together those
insights for accuracy after losing with
the bunk clap I think I'd like to see
that stat maybe we can get that pulled
up but in all seriousness you know Duda
is is looking at a tough spot to be in
and he's down four nothing Robert he has
to win all his games just to make it to
Armageddon yeah that is a gargantuan
task for a player he looks defeated and
the game is underway How will John
Chester do to respond oh no please no
bong clouds and Carl he pauses here Iman
he's wondering oh okay the answer is
there we can we can I actually wasn't
sure not only would you know would Duda
play it but I was wondering would Hikaru
play it after what happened yesterday he
didn't seem to be in the best mood after
getting bomb clouded himself but no
Robert it looks like we've got a normal
game of chess well I say normal even
though we've got the French defense on
the board
okay and it almost looks like this black
queen she's about to be trapped Bishop
G5 I had the same thought we had to take
a deep breath here it's early in the day
Bishop G5 does trap the queen right
except for the fact that after Bishop to
G5 black can steal this Knight on F3
removing the guard of the bishop on G5
and attacking the White Queen return you
see the evaluation drop that would be a
Game ending blunder and a car will not
make that move yeah and sometimes you're
in that mindset that your opponent is
just kind of blundering and dropping
things you might play Bishop G5 too
quickly thinking oh I've caught him this
you know it's the match is over but uh
no he's actually laying a clever little
trap there and uh interesting opening
choice you know it's the French defense
they're always going to have that
passive structure but one thing he's
done differently in the French Robert is
he's got that Bishop that French Bishop
he's got it out to C6 it actually exerts
you know a lot of pressure from that
square the White Knight can't jump into
the E5 Square to harass it because it's
covered by the Knight on D7 so you know
all things considered when he you think
of a French defense Robert big
Improvement when you when you look at
that bishop and that's why a car drops
back Bishop to E2 protecting the Knight
so his King Side Pawn structure does not
have to be compromised and Iman one of
the things I complimented car on
yesterday was his professionalism when
someone plays the Bonk clad against you
your first instinct is to say this is a
joke let me respond in a silly fashion
no he played serious chess he won that
game and he is taking nothing for
granted taking no chances and I love
this why not take control of the center
if you're a car Nakamura yep but uh look
you're in a must win situation if you're
down just off Duda it's 4-0
I like the decision I like the opening
he's got those Bishops aimed towards
hikaru's king and you know we could see
all sorts of things from you know Pond
H6 Pawn to G5 even we could get a pawn
storm going we could see uh Queen side
castling here from Duda so you know on
the one hand yes the match is very
lopsided but I think that means that
this game might be particularly
interesting for sure Bishop E4 what a
move I guess the threat was D5 when the
bishop was on C6 to trap the piece so in
comes this bishop and I'm liking your
ideas more and more you have to play on
the queen side the thing is a draw is
equivalent to a loss if you're young
just of dude maybe not in terms of
ratings this is a hybrid event feed a
rapid rating on the line that's a great
point but if you draw it you're still
eliminated so you might as well go big I
think so you know some players have that
feeling like they don't want to go out
let's say five nothing but I don't think
you can have an ego about like look at
how much money is at stake in this
tournament Robert I say you leave it all
on the line go for it and so far I think
that's what dude is doing he didn't like
that D5 move as you mentioned which
would have you know really put some
pressure on his Bishop he likes the
bishop on that diagonal but Robert that
E4 Square it's not feeling very secure
to me like I'm looking at rookie one as
a as a normal move I I like rookie one
just you know that x-ray pressure on the
bishop for sure and at some point the
other Bishop can be hit with a move like
C5 you want to time that right because
pawns don't move backwards so as soon as
the move C5 is played by white that
hands block this D5 Square for the rest
of the game so interesting strategic
decisions for both players I will agree
with you that if you need a win this is
a pretty good position to have right but
a car was spending his time it's not
often we see hikar down the clock he
made the move Knight G5 attacking this
bishop and the bishop is sent to the
other diagonal Iman maybe it's akara's
turn to take over the long diagonal
light squares and I think that's his
plan Knight G5 Bishop G6 let's say you
play your move Bishop to F3 you're
hitting that pawn and maybe you're
intending something like Knight to E4
that the reason that I'd be cautious
about that is Robert there might be some
tactics on that H2 square and it's not
the first game in this tournament where
there's been some tactics like that
first game of the day you know you're
still kind of rubbing your eyes a little
tired don't be falling for for anything
like this because you better believe
that Duda is on the lookout for stuff
like that for sure well this is the
first game of the day in the matches the
second game is about to begin this one
between Wesley so and Dimitri on Drake
and you see Wesley putting in the
headphones Dimitri is ready he gets the
black pieces and as we look at the
matchup between these two superstars
Iman Wesley so higher rated in classical
chess and chest like I'm rapid rating
but on draken has the head to head he
has the head to head and you know it's
it's an interesting statistic that I
don't think these players are really
considering too much you know they they
probably feel this is a not only an even
match-up but a stylistically even
matchup they're very similar in how they
play and you brought this up yesterday
Robert both of these guys things they
love going to the end game the solid
grindy Style file it's usually such
solid openings but everything I just
said think of the exact opposite if that
was the match that we've seen so far
it's so odd because these two players
are so positional in nature and yet it
was wild Cactus Galore and for Dimitri
on Drake and he's been doing well with
the black pieces we heard Levy and Donya
and the rest of who talking about this
and here he plays this tarash and takes
on D4 early we may in fact get an end
game not too far from now exactly this
is a really interesting opening uh I'll
be you know completely honest here I
think this is an underrated opening you
give up a pawn immediately you know
white often goes for this queen to A4
check and it's because you want to take
back on D4 and not be in a pin not have
your queen undefended in the center so
uh really tough to explain but we're
gonna get into a position which I think
is theoretical in nature Robert so we'll
probably have a couple moves here coming
back to back to back but the general
principle Black's give giving up a pawn
but then starting to attack that queen
move after move getting a lot of pieces
out with Tempo and you know we talked
about settling down I think it was Levy
saying he used to settle down a little
bit I don't think he heard him no he's
giving away material for the activity
and look at Wesley so drop his Queen
back to D1 if he had captured that pawn
on B7 we can analyze that very quickly
because you don't want to bite off more
than you can chew if Queen had taken on
B7 then this Knight on B8 immediately
hops up because the Rook is trapped in
the corner Knight C6 you're already
threading things like Knight B4 to C2
Rook to B8 right and white is down
several Tempe in terms of development
the two pawns perhaps not quite worth it
no not at all and you know any time I
always say anytime that the engine eval
is sort of around zero but you're down
two pawns you don't want to go near that
position and neither does Wesley so
who's gone for a slower approach here
with it's just Queen back to the
starting squared D1 he doesn't want to
leave it exposed where more pieces will
start to attack it he's got A3 I suspect
Robert he might be interested in a move
like Pawn to E3 getting the bishop out
nice and easy Bishop E2 and as you
highlighted Pawn to B4 to attack that
bishop and prepare Bishop to B2 that's
right it's a flexible move taking away a
square from an opponent giving control
of it to yourself but you need to
develop I like using E3 first develop
that light Square Bishop get castled and
white is a pawn ahead right but
sometimes you get a bishop pair for a
pawn you get something like that a
Target to exploit I don't think black
really has that here so what the way
Wesley chose to respond allows him to
take that material say
um you're never getting this back I'm
putting that in my pocket and now the
best you're gonna do is try to equalize
and these games often get into really
really wild skirmishes so don't be
surprised Robert if we see from black
moves like Queen to E7 and long Castle I
know it looks crazy you don't have a
seat on you know the the D files wide
open the C files wide open but black and
Castle tucked that King on B8 and then
actually go for things as crazy as Pawn
to G5 and absolute Mayhem could be on
the board in this game so don't be uh
don't be surprised if andrekin continues
more of the same interesting play with
the black pieces and the words of our
good friend James Kenny G5 we live and
we would love to see plays like that and
queen E7 step one leaving the
flexibility of which direction the king
will go to Amman I really like your
strategy because while Dimitri can draw
this game and still continue his fight
he's kind of in a must-win situation
down three to one you can only afford a
few more draws so I feel like Dimitri
he's feeling the pressure and he has
done well with the black pieces in day
one even though the result doesn't show
that yeah he's done well with black
pieces and uh you know to the contrary
he hasn't done well with the white
pieces so he's not feeling the way that
a lot of chess players feel where
they're like oh I'll draw this game with
black keep it nice and even take my
chances with the white pieces he might
feel the exact opposite I gotta take my
chances where I feel my opponent has
given me opportunities and with the
white pieces I gotta Shore things up and
that's why Wesley so he knows how
dangerous undraken is he's thinking do I
develop my Bishop on the dark squares
first or do I listen to Amman and play
E3 so there's pros and cons to each
Bishop G5 delays your king side
development the white king for sure
wants to head over to G1 but the
downside of playing E3 is you make it a
bit passive so without a pawn more space
for the pieces it if there were a Pawn
on E6 I'm just going to take the H Pawn
then the queen doesn't have an open line
so exactly it's going to be interesting
to see how this one develops and another
game is about to begin this one between
Anish giri and tamarajava that was the
picks that our friends in the studio
were talking about all of us including
us except for Dania chose Anish giri in
this matchup and we show The Head to
Head between the two Anish geared the
younger player but rajapov in that rapid
head to head has the lead and it's like
you know keep saying Anish giri the
younger player how long has Anish Gary
been at the top level of Chess Robert
it's crazy he's got so many accolades to
his name and he's only 28 years old
Robert he's younger than me what the
heck am I looking at here here and you
know you see that head to head they've
played so many games which is
interesting considering you know what
good friends these guys are they have
played against each other a ton I think
this match is as close as people
expected I did think this would go eight
games the full eight games Robert I
don't know if we'll see Armageddon but
you know this is probably one of the
closest matches that we have in the
quarterfinals and Anish gear is sticking
to E4 on the first move and rajabov
plays E5 so he was playing Sicilian
yesterday he actually had a bad loss in
the candidates the five on a carwana
playing the Sicilian so he's opting out
of the more aggressive opening instead
playing the solid E5 I'm on what do you
make of that decision I think it's uh I
think it suits the match so you know
these guys have been neck and neck I
don't think that it benefits either
player to take too much risk early on
they've shown you know a lot of draws in
these games but not boring draws either
they still get fighting positions with
chances for both sides I've maybe
disagreed with every draw offer I've
seen so so you know if they're getting
these positions with chances for both
sides I agree with this stick to a solid
opening because it will get spicy later
on for sure and right now Anish has the
choice does he expand on the queen side
with A4 B4 as he played more towards the
center of the king side often a plan is
rookie one Knight B2 the Knight comes to
F1 and ultimately I'm gonna pick up this
Knight and put it on G3 that's where the
Knight Journeys to right it's a long
story it takes several moves to get
there but that's the two different plans
and he does play A4 do like this Choice
from a niche I think it's a good place
to start because you know what A4
doesn't fully commit and I was gonna say
a hybrid of your both of your great
ideas Robert might be preferred A4 you
know to control a little bit of space on
the queen side not necessarily allow B5
or the more dangerous Knight to A5
Knight to A5 looks to pick up that white
Bishop but now with the pawn on A4 you
can Retreat to the A2 Square so I like a
little bit of both and keep in mind
black can actually say hey that's a
great plan you got there I'm gonna do it
too 19 E7 Knight to G6 in order to copy
that Knight F1 and Knight G4 and Knight
G3 idea and you said Knight G4 because
that's the move that was just played
exactly already a threat on F2 so
typically white defends that with Rook
E2 or Rook F1 and kicks the night out
with H3 the big thing is black has not
castled yet so it's an argument who made
that rajaba is going forward with some
kind of King side pressure and rookie 2
Step One H3 step two but 97 so again the
job of not committing his King and that
might mean if H3 is played if some
positions are moving H5 let's use the
fishing hook that famous kind of tactic
where you sacrifice a piece to open the
H fail and The Rook on h8 will try to
lay Devastation and I mean that's
everyone's favorite isn't it when you
get a chance to throw in that H5 move I
have to say I'm not convinced that we'll
see it in this particular moment but the
idea remains there and actually it's
it's an issues kind of ignoring the
opportunity to play H3 Robert usually
when that night is on G4 nestled there
you're thinking okay get that out of my
face as fast as possible how come he's
you know refraining from playing H3 well
H3 is a useful move even if the Knight
were back on F6 but the Knight is
actually better placed on F6 so perhaps
Anish is developing his pieces first and
then we'll kick it out with he could
play D4 he could play around the Knight
on G4 saying right you had a one move
tactic a one move threat I have a
limiting death threat and now I'm
closing off your Bishop so is your
knight actually good on G4 it's what
these top players do right I'm so
tempted to kick that Knight immediately
and he says you sit there keep talking
about the chest I'll show you my moves
are talking so you be quiet now agreed
yeah though that that night on G4 if you
think about the position black has
actually made a threat that's now
completely covered so you might even
play Knight back to F6 voluntarily like
on its own next turn and then white can
at least has them with H3 in reserve you
can play H3 but you're not forced to so
I like the decision you know uh you you
keep the move there Knight change 3
continue with the plans that we've
talked about the Thematic ideas for this
e45 position you know structurally we
will see that pawn eventually probably
go to D4 now that the knights on G3
supporting E4 I think you're
highlighting some of the moves that
we're going to see white also might want
to play Bishop E3 but not while that
Knights on G4 right the Knight takes
away that square so H3 is very likely
and we'll see oh we don't have to wait
long the niche does play H3 the Knight
will venture back but we'll see how this
one continues the fourth game here is
about to get underway this one between
Sam Seville and nihals on game five in
that match seven with a two and a half
one F lead and if you look at the head
to head between these two players
there's nothing to look at Amman they
are very young and they have never
squared off before yesterday yeah I mean
the the head to head is like might have
to update it basically from yesterday's
scores that's the information that we're
working off here we just we know what's
in front of us which is that we have two
young superstars in the Chess World
right now and you know despite Sammy in
being knocked out in this tournament and
you know getting a second chance he
deserves to be here as well he's at the
level and he's ahead in this match
saying you know what I deserve this spot
and he's playing like it Robert when you
beat Maxine Russia lagrav in a second
round matchup and then you do lose to uh
Levon aronian he did get a second chance
and he's making the most of it we see in
the early opening just a Queen's Gambit
Decline and oh okay they're playing very
quickly this topic aligned with B5 white
will snag that pawn C4 becomes a Target
but the Knight comes back to B6 the
bishop to B7 on an open diagonal these
positions kind of hard to explain to
newer players but the essential point is
black it's space and squares for the
pieces for the ugly Pawn structure
that's a great you know quick summary
Robert because I think a lot of players
would look at that c Pawn on C4 and say
what kind of compensation do you have
for that that pawn looks like it's going
down Rook to C1 Knight to D2 you know
that pawn looks like a goner but in
order for white to sort of orchestrate
capturing that pawn it's really
difficult you have to put a lot of
pieces on uncomfortable squares and that
Knight on B5 also in a bit of a
precarious position so you had to waste
the move playing Knight back to C3 and
you mentioned the squares have a look at
the D5 Square you highlighted that
diagonal Bishop to B7 is going to be
commanding on that beautiful diagonal
and there's no way to block it so that
is the compensation but of course it's
balanced by those ugly C pawns yeah
things are getting spicy early here some
position that's not that bounce actually
is the game between Hikaru Nakamura and
yonchist of Duda and when I say that you
may expect a car to keep on winning but
as we bring up that game here we see the
advantages in yanchistoff's favor so
maybe he did bomb Cloud it too early but
perhaps that actually cleared his head
rather than creating some smoke and now
he's up a pawn a clear extra Pawn for
JKD against Hikaru yeah clear extra pun
here Robert Bishop to E3 was the last
move you know you could convince me that
this position is actually white to move
and I would believe you but no it's
actually uh Jan trust off Duda his turn
got that clear extra pawn pawn to B6
looks normal here could even go Pawn to
A6 but uh something about Pawn to B6
feels feels nice blocking that Bishop on
the diagonal and you know I just think
back Robert and I'm like man did he
relinquish that game four too early did
he tilt too early because what we're
seeing here is like a new day and a new
Duda yeah that's a good way of putting
it and yeah stuff him he probably is
kicking himself because look at the
advantages where 25 moves into this game
black is a clear extra Pawn up and we
have Bishops of the same color sometimes
in the Bishops are opposite color you
say let me trade out pieces try to make
a draw no no no these pawns B2 A3 on
dark squares already being targeted and
dude is doing the correct thing he's up
several minutes he's up a pawn and he's
spending time because this is a big
moment if you play B6 you may already
fall to some Rook C1 hitting the C6 Pawn
if you play A6 all your pawns are on
light squares which makes the bishop on
E3 kind of dominate the queen side
vulnerable Square so he does choose A6
and now for Hikaru this is where it gets
difficult to mine you know you're worse
and you have to fight claw to try to
make a draw
what's it do yeah and you know sometimes
Robert you're in a position where you
you know you're worse but it actually
makes your your moves a little easier to
find sometimes because they're limited
you can only do so much at some point
you know being a pawn down you actually
don't have the pressure of having to
come up with a plan you can sit there
and say Hey you beat me you're the one
that's got the extra pun and of course
we know duda's down 4-0 so it's not like
he can try his best to win and
ultimately draw he doesn't have that
cushion he needs to win this game so I
think the pressure is actually on JKD
here and Hikaru knows that and I think
dude is regretting his decision to play
A6 for them B6 in comes the queen of D7
already yes the idea is like Bishop to
A7 kicking this Rook away from this Pawn
on B7 that's now the Target and there's
pressure in the E file Rook staring at
each other through Bishops the H6 Pawn
is loose so I feel like Duda he's in
danger of slipping away like his
Advantage might just go out the window
in the next two moves exactly it could
be that quick I was thinking maybe on
the previous move try to take more
control of the position something like
Queen E6 and don't let that Queen into
the D7 Square Robert but instead we have
full penetration here The Rook gonna be
tied to the B7 Pawn as you mentioned the
Rook on E8 it's sort of tied to that
Bishop on E5 and H6 Pawn hanging I'm
even struggling to come up with a with a
move here because if you think about
this position From duda's perspective
this is not the extra Pawn that you
signed up for not at all Queen E6 would
be such a good move if that pawn on H6
were not hanging so if you just take
back that move right that pawn was there
a turn ago yeah when the queen was on F5
amman's decision like Queen E6 just
offer that trade let's try to get those
off the board the downside of trading
pieces is you feel like maybe that one
extra Pawn isn't quite enough to win the
game so Duda has many difficult
decisions to juggle and while he is
trying to figure out his next turn let's
get a bird's eye if you look at all
games at once because all eight players
are taking part this may may be the last
time we see this view because Duda could
see his tournament Run come to an end so
Iman as we look across my eyes are on
Wesley so against Dimitri on draken
because that King has castled long for
ondrakin and I see White's pieces
staring at that King I feel like on
drakin potentially going for the
aggressive plan he may be the one who
falls victim to attack yeah and you know
what you think that maybe you want to
slow down a little bit if you're on
draken because of how the match has gone
but also because of the score three to
one he does have to take more risks he
needs to flip this match on its head he
needs to score the same day that Wesley
had yesterday today and I think this is
a great opening to it it is scary having
that Bishop on F4 Robert covering the B8
square if you grab that King and put it
on the A8 square that is so safe right
it's in the corner tucked away but on C8
we have the bishop restricting the B8
Square which means hello Rook C1 one if
that Rook appears there Robert that King
is going to be forced maybe towards the
center of the board which that's the
wrong direction no that's not where you
want to be and maybe Knight H5 going
after this bishop should be on Dragon's
plan and then the good news is the queen
on A4 actually covers the bishop because
the bishop is not hanging white can
continue developing and then that means
that extra pawns making its presence
felt and the C file being opened with a
king there and many pieces in the way I
do like Wesley's position I like his
clock management this is dangerous
territory for Dimitri on draken Yep this
is uh gonna be a back and forth battle
for sure but one of the things that
Wesley is doing so well in this game is
you know he's the one that's up upon so
he knows that his opponent is coming
straight for the throat right there's
going to be compensation there's going
to be an attack but he's handling it by
actually putting some pressure back on
his opponent he's not saying I have the
extra Pawn I'm just gonna try to play
defense and you know maybe try to trade
as best I can because sometimes that's
what black wants they want you to play
passively and get their aggressive game
but he's basically fighting fire with
fire and I hope he plays with Bishop A6
exploring the fact that the Knight on C6
could be loose that would be really cool
I'm not sure if it's good but it looks
like a lot of fun and that is how you
fight fire with fire but we've looked at
our first two games of the day so far
let's look at our other two our matchups
between Anish giri and Tim Rojo Sam
Sabian nihal sarin and as I look up at
this screen here Amman that night for uh
Sauron is on B3 so we can see the light
Square control for him but that C4 Pawn
on the right side of the screen still is
quite vulnerable and the left side of
the screen that Knight is on F4 for Timo
rajaba so both games are very fighting
and maybe the biggest thing to note is
the job of up nearly six minutes on the
clock yeah that's a great call Robert
the the clocks right now in both games
are something to start paying attention
to you know we're looking at the
positions but obviously the clock
situation is what's causing a lot of the
discrepancies in the eval you know you
talk about that girian rajabov game
Robert yet the eval bar starting to
climb and when you've when you've got
that you know time pressure ticking as
well it just it just adds it becomes
like a multiplier yeah let's dive into
Geary against rajaba because that
position is looking very good for a
niche his he uses time wisely to get an
advantage in this one and it's weird
because black is missing an a pawn white
is missing a c Pawn so what happened was
eight six to A5 took on B4 and the C3
Pawn took back but the reason why white
is better here is this pressure on the
E5 Pawn already white threatens to win a
pawn directly on F4 and if black has to
be forced back okay he's at Force
backwards no no no let's go forward G5
but the reason I hate that move him on
the F5 square is White's for the taking
yeah that you know you don't need to
highlight uh anything other than that
that's enough for me to say okay I don't
like the move G5 at all after Knight to
F5 if you just throw the move in right
now I'm already looking at that each six
Pawn Robert you're highlighting it if I
play King H7 I'm also walking onto the
diagonal from the bishop on C2 to the
King on H7 I know that there's a few
pieces in the way but you'd be surprised
Robert how quickly things can clear out
and then tactics abound yeah the only
downside of moving the knight from G3 is
E4 becomes loose but you can start
trading pieces that's the big problem
with G5 is that's a permanent weakness
on F5 and if we go through some very
logical moves here D takes E5 let's say
you just take back on E5 then I just
trade Bishops on A7 you take back and
when all is said and done give me that
F5 Square I can just go straight in here
and that's a big problem not to mention
this beautiful tactic of Knight takes E5
Rook takes E5 and queen D4 you don't see
this every day two different Rooks are
spied by that Queen and you know what
that's such a beautiful Fork because
usually two Rooks on a chessboard no
matter where you put them they can
always move to defend each other the
only reason that won't be able to happen
is if pawns or other pieces are in the
way and of course lo and behold every
everything is perfectly in the way here
so that's a great tactic and you know
what else I was thinking Robert earlier
in this line if black wanted to flick in
after Pawn E5 Bishop takes on E3
you can actually take that with the pawn
and it might you know look a little
visually disturbing you've got those
triple pawns there momentarily but two
nights hanging I'll take the piece oh
gladly Anish Gary would grab that
instead we see takes takes and instead
of the attack with Knight takes five
plays Knight F5 it's the most natural
move in the position you see the
evaluation bar Sky High for Niche that
is just a square that you need please
let me play E6 let me play G6 no your
pawns are too far Advanced H6 is a
Target and after King H7 I'm already
liking moves like H4 trying to open okay
I barely gotta say it in each played it
and he is letting his moves to the
talking exactly and this is just pure
Instinct chess now because after Pawn to
G4 Robert I think the move Knight takes
E5 becomes even more apparent now the F4
Knight is hanging as well so G4 not an
option but it also doesn't seem like
it's an option to leave the pawn on G5
White's threatening to take it and win
it with check plus you've got this
strange Rook on A7 which believe me it
might not be the case now Robert but
that is going to be hanging to all sorts
of tactics we already showed one of them
Knight takes E5 would be available so
Timor has 10 plus minutes he is going to
have to use all of that time to have any
sort of chance it's not looking good for
him but let's look at all four games
here because all eight players are
sitting and trying to find the best
moves we see in the top left the
advantage is gone the eval Bar says a
car Nakamura doing okay because the H6
Pawn is gone that's picked off in the
bottom left we just looked at Anish giri
he has a big Advantage there and well
Wesley so's Queen is gone is extra Pawn
is also gone yeah and I'm looking at
that uh Sam Sevin and nihal sarin game
as well that pawn on C4 also got picked
off from the bishop you can see just
retreated so feels like some some key
Pawns in a lot of positions Robert just
disappeared all of a sudden and the
evaluation bar sort of changing to
reflect that yeah let's go to the game
between Wesley so and Dimitri on draken
I think think that one should be quite
level given how few pieces remain and
well the pawn structure is bad for black
so I think that's what Wesley is
counting on the best players in the
world don't mind handing back some of
the material if it leaves them with a
positional Advantage so in the last few
moves we'll just scroll back a few show
how we got here after this night came to
H5 attacking the bishop on F4 white said
I'm going to develop my queen thankfully
protects this piece G5 kicks the bishop
back and after this trade Bishop takes
E3 a month I see your eyes there what a
move the point is that after Pawn takes
Queen takes there's threats against this
King there's no castling for you white
has an advantage it's hard to see
through I mean I'm gonna cheat for a
second turn the evaluation King F1 is
the best move that's a really hard move
to play that's amazing yeah and even if
you play it I think you have to continue
to play good moves after that it's not
like hey King F1 and uh yeah we'll
actually just back up and I will leave
you alone no the attack is still raging
so King F1 is only beginning of many
tough moves right so instead Rook D1
some trades trades Queens get that
attack out of here and Wesley says I'm
better in this ending so Knight D4 give
me that pawn and look at this position
white is upon ahead not the best pawns
we've ever seen but a knight can
outclass a bishop in end games because
the Knight can go from color complex to
color complex that Bishop on G6 only can
stay in the light scores please let my
knight get to E5 then I could try to win
this game and you know what the Knight
can sometimes outclass the bishop if the
puns were even so the fact that there's
an extra Pawn here I know the eval bar
is not in love with this Robert but I
kind of am I think there are real
chances for Wesley here and keep in mind
the time situation as well it's really
relevant as we get to the end game here
you got to think about the fact that
Wesley just took a potential attack
neutralized it took it to an end game
he's got a three to one match score lead
right now this is exactly what he wants
he wants a chance to get a full point
but a guaranteed Half Point right he's
remaining in control he said I'm not
going to lose this game he has zero
losing chances and speaking of control
Jan just just after it looked like he
was losing control against Hikaru
Nakamura but once again he has reclaimed
the advantage so yanchist of Duda he is
trying to remain in this tournament we
see his position on the right side of
the screen there that B2 Pawn is gone so
Hikaru is now down upon once again and
it's not just any pawn amount there's a
Pawn on D3 just two squares away for
promotion for the Post player exactly
yeah this Pawn on D3 sometimes you'll
get positions where you know you are
even down material but you have a pass
Pawn so far up the board that it's full
compensation well guess what now you've
got a position where you're even up
material Robert that pass Pawn is worth
so much it's gonna take whites either
queen or Rook to take control of some
Square on the D file and stop it from
promoting so you're using one of your
pawns and you're making white waste the
you know a queen or Rook to defend it
that's right and speaking of D file look
at The Rook on D1 for Niche gear in the
left side screen he was attacking
teamwork jobs Queen Regal's pieces on A7
B7 not taking part in the game the King
on H7 is about to be blown open and
let's actually go into that game quickly
if we can because Anish giri he looks
like he's on the verge of another win
what is wrong with h takes G5 you can't
even take it back because the Knight
Will land on G5 with a fork of king and
queen that's incredible first of all I
think the move is going to be Knight to
G4 after Pawn takes Pawn on G5 it I mean
I think it just has to be right but
after Knight G4 that's a one move attack
there's still a Pawn on G5 they're still
Knight ready to jump in and I just can't
see him surviving because Robert don't
forget that Rook on A7 you had to spend
time playing G6 or B6 excuse me to
protect it and shield it but it's not
participating in the game white is
essentially up a rook and anees plays
Bishop B3 just hitting the queen of the
pawn behind it that looks like a simple
decision for him this position is
terrible terrible for team he has no
play of his own he goes Queen C A give
me F7 give me G5 this is over so yeah I
think we can safely let Anish take it
away from here and John Duda in that
game is you know we have to bounce
around it looks like the Polish
Superstar is giving Hikaru all he can
handle and more but the King on G8 for
Duda it's a bit exposed that could lead
to some Perpetual check some repetitions
but the pass pawn and under 10 seconds
of the clock for dudas let's Dive Right
In to that one dude it down to five
barely is getting his moves off with
limited time on the clock exactly and
this is where Hikaru is so tricky he
knows how to use your time against you
he knows what moves you're looking at
and he knows how to play against that so
he'll be trying to drum up some tricky
moves where he thinks he knows how
you're gonna reply and have a reply
ready for that to put you on the spot to
move with five seconds and wow he hung a
bishop on E3 that pawn F2 is pinned Rook
Edge when the king slides up to G6 there
is a couple checks but the Rook can
always drop back Yan chistav Duda with
his back against the wall he wins game
five he stays alive in this tournament
at Carl Nakamura well he's not gonna be
happy about that one no he's not that
was a full piece hung as we see Duda on
your screen right there he's breathing
New Life in this competition in this
match Robert everyone counted him out
but it seems like he woke up and just
chose violence today he chose violence
in D and a car Nakamura still with a big
lead 4-1 but the only win of today is by
Yan chistav Duda and he is going to feel
a bunch better about this match some
players although will not feel so good
about their chances while Hikaru
Nakamura will have to bounce back in the
next game but Duda I mean would it
performed to him after the bomb Cloud
yesterday indeed and you know Robert I
honestly look back at that game and
think you know damn if he just was in a
different mindset in that fourth game
and played it out even if he just drew
that game yeah you're down three and a
half to half but you come back on day
two and it's a whole new ball game so
look he didn't do that unfortunately he
dropped all games yesterday but there is
still a chance here as chess players
love to say Robert one game at a time
well I think he's using that mentality
and after a great start it's a momentum
based competition Robert so he's looking
to continue Anish gear wins his game we
just saw that flash on screen so Niche
takes the headset off he extends his
lead doubles it from one to two and he
is also gonna be thrilled with how this
day has begun as he wants to eliminate
Timor of the job of from the competition
so the score now in Geary's favor the
number one player from Holland leads
three and a half to one and a half over
rajabov after decisive game one that's
right and you know that was an
unbelievable uh he made it look easy
Robert and it was such a simple uh
execution so I thought that was a great
game to watch e45 it was just clinical
and now it's getting to the point where
you know if you're a job of you're
starting to feel the pressure of this
lead just mounting and mounting Geary
with a great performance is no surprise
that he won that game based on the
position that we left at last for sure
so anishikiri extends the lead we have
Wesley so taking on Dimitri on Drake and
look at the evaluation bar and look at
the pawns it was one extra Pawn for
white now it's three who cares if the
pawns are doubled Westley so is well on
his way to Victory and we want to get to
the match between seven and Neil sarin
there's still much life left in that one
but let's go to the game between Wesley
and Dimitri because Wesley about to
convert and end game appears with
Dimitri down to just 11 seconds exactly
and this Rook end game looks like it's
about to be very very clinical look
there are two past pawns they're doubled
on the B file but even with one of those
past pawns Robert I would wager that
this might be a winning end game so I
don't think Wesley will have any
difficulty guess what the time played a
factor only 10 seconds for on Drake in
here and that's probably why he ended up
losing more pawns and he's going to lose
this game he is for sure Rook D2 then
King D4 there it goes Wesley's King
should run on over to help those b-pawns
escort them to the other side of King F4
Rook D3 is simple Rook B3 sandwich a
rook sandwich on the beef file and then
the bee Pond runs this is over Dimitri
on Drake and might resign right here
yeah and if he doesn't resign I can't
see him finding a move that you know has
any real impact beep on time B5 B6
Robert you can use the rook and the king
and guess what The Rook from D3 covers
the F3 Pawn so black has no counter play
at all none so whatsoever it looks like
clinical technique from Wesley so King
C5 looks The simpas Rook B3 Rook behind
the pass Punk cannot blame him and
Wesley so wins game five he was up three
to one make it four to one and he is a
half point away from securing his spot
in the semifinals that's right you know
even though the Nakamura match started
with the more one-sided score guess what
the score is the same now in those two
matches four to one for Wesley so he's
got you know all the opportunities now
to just make a draw and secure this
match win Robert and Dimitri on Drake
and give him credit kind of went all in
with the opening it did not pay off it
was a gamble that was not rewarded so
Dimitri on draken the Superstar the guy
who eliminated Fabiano caruana from this
field he is down to that man Wesley so
so Wesley he's in great form right now
and you know good job by him in game one
yeah absolutely no this was a really
really well played game I love the way
he neutralized the attack was willing to
give back material Robert and ultimately
that was the difference yes so a 4-1
lead and we get right in to Savion
against nihal Sara now we have not seen
how this game has reached this point but
as we're here I see opposite colored
Bishops if I do a quick material count
even number of Pawns whose King is safer
it looks like Black's King so I like
nihal's position yeah and I also have to
highlight the that was not what I was
gonna highlight as much as I'd love to
take commentator credit nope that was
not it I was gonna say look at the pawn
structure as well because those double F
pawns weak H Pawn in opposite Bishop end
game where the pawn structure you know
is the determining factor I think
black's way ahead but there was just a
tactic on the board Robert we came at
the best time to see all the action yeah
that Rook on D1 was opened up to the
queen on D5 the queen loses that
Showdown has to retreat the B7 but B2 is
now loose I think your point still holds
F4 F2 H4 E5 all on dark squares so if we
get this Turn end games the bishop for
blackens are picking off the pawns and
if B2 Falls next then A3 is loose and we
could see an extra Pawn but don't forget
about the Rook I actually overlooked
that that Rook slides across the board
and protects A3 it's easy to blunder in
positions like this yeah so so easy
actually to forget that that Rook the
Rover from H3 all the way to A3 is
covering things well guess what I think
after Queen takes B2 although the C7
Pawn is hanging I mean we could see a
really wild position where the Queens
stay on the board and Robert neither
King is true really safe here we got a
king on F1 and f8 it's like they both
Mouse slipped castling and that King was
safe that's what I was saying when we
got here but Bishop takes G6 removed
that safety there is no Pawn but when
there are no pawns there are open files
and Rook G8 already threatens Queen G2
The Rook slides back to H2 I wonder if
we will see a bishop takes H4 type of
move to just distract The Rook or
alternatively maybe it's now time to
take on B2 it is getting very complex
and nihal sarin and sam7 around four
minutes on the clock exactly and The
Rook on H2 compared to H3 so much worse
you know you you wish you could have
played maybe Rook G3 from H3 to
challenge The Rook on the open file but
if you compare the Rook on H2 to The
Rook on G8 I mean it's just a bystander
The Rook on G8 exerts so much more
pressure on the position so Queen takes
C7 Robert this is gonna be a really
interesting finish because now the
Queens are staying on the board but I
think the story is the quality of the
Rooks Rook anjeet that much better
that's a passive Rook on H2 it can't go
anywhere useful now there's a bit of a
pin The Rook on D1 is loose the only way
you can move the bishop is backwards to
defend A3 is loose and it's not just to
even up the pawns right White currently
is up upon A3 seems like it's just gonna
fall but once A3 Falls this Pawn can
start running to the other side of the
board yeah that's that's exactly right
the a pawn might be the determining
Factor however be on the lookout for
maybe something like Bishop E2 and
trying to take on H5 because if you grab
the H Pawn hey The Rook on H2 is not
doing much but it is placed behind a
potential pass Pawn in that H4 pawn and
once you send that pawn up the board
Robert it could be a crazy race where we
might even see Four Queens out here I
would not be surprised by anything in
this competition but right now sam7 that
almost a minute he's kept a lead on the
clock in day one here in day two the
mouse speed is there for Neil sorry we
know how strong of a bullet player he is
but he can't keep getting down out to
under 10 seconds to two minutes for his
opponent no you know you live and die by
the sword he's such a great bullet
player but sometimes it works against
him as it does many strong bullet
players because they're so good with low
time that they don't feel the danger
when it gets down there and when your
opponent's Menace they can really spend
the time to calculate Bishop E2 and
apparently there is a problem with this
and I see what it is this Rook covers
the G file so once you swap on D1 this
is a game-winning tactic let's analyzed
real quick I think Nihao will spot this
it's not that difficult Queen B5 check
we don't even need the analysis board
he's doing it for us Bishop E2 Queen B1
background here Rook G1 The Rook slides
in and where's that King going nowhere
good that's at minimum a piece if not
Checkmate and resignation nihal sarin
has even this match up oh my goodness
that was the biggest blunder of the
chess.com Global Championship I think
Robert Rook to G1 totally missed this
queen B5 shot was beautiful from nihal
sarin and he's bounced back and tied
this match wow we have had decisive game
in every single match nihal sarin he was
down two and a half one half against the
guy who shouldn't even been here and yet
he Strikes Back sam7 was thumbs up
before the game I think right now he's
feeling a bit thumbs down I think you're
right and you know Nihao tsar and he's
just come back with a vengeance today he
played that position so well but it was
the accuracy that blunder happened
Robert and he was on it like a shark he
spotted that immediately played it and
we saw the resignation just like that so
Nihao did not miss a beat no he did not
and nor did three other players there
were four decisive games in round five
we saw yonchist of Dude to stay alive he
beats Hikaru Nakamura we saw Anish Geary
win a nice game against Timor rajabo and
then of course Wesley so an end game
grind against Dimitri on Drake and
before ultimately this huge Gaff by Sam
Simeon exactly no the first of all the
Wesley match you know he's starting to
really pull away from Dimitri on draken
right of course you've got Hikaru
Nakamura drop that game to Duda it's
still a huge huge comeback that's
necessary for both Duda and on Dragon
now who trail with only a point to the
Four Points from their opponents so
tough matches there but Robert you know
it was all about Nihao sarin and that
comeback and you know what a crushing
game we saw by Anish giri as well you
know continues to increase his lead but
Nihao just played I think a great game
to start off this morning it gets the
win he did and you look at this position
we kind of left it but look at the
control for black B3 D5 the C4 Pawn was
the only problem but as this game
continued here Knight came to D5 that's
the square you want to use the bishop
Retreats so even though the evaluation
is white is better White's moving
backwards while Black's hopping forwards
exactly and you know those those light
squares were for the taking
I just love the control that he
exhibited here he was also willing to
give up that C4 pawn and just understand
that that wasn't the end of the line
it's actually the Bishop from B7 that at
the end captures on F3 and well you
could play Rook takes F3 Robert but you
got some hanging pawns to deal with not
to mention H4 potentially D4 later on he
decides to double the pawns but that's a
long-term weakness in H5 cements that
weak Pawn on H4 love that move the pawn
will not be able to be pushed forward
and after F4 G6 this is light Square
control against the light score Bishop
so great play here from nihal sarin as
the game continued King F1 King f8 the
queen backtracked to C1 and this is
where things started to get wild A5 just
locked down the B file and after D5
that's where we tuned in where all of a
sudden you capture twice on D5 Bishop
takes G6 I think seven overestimated his
position winning this Pawn because it
looks so good in fact if I had to take a
pawn out of Black's position I might
grab the G6 pawn it looks like the glue
it's covering the G file you want to
play King to G7 for black tuck your king
away can't do that anymore your H Pawn
is now super weak from Bishop to E2 or
queen D1 later but it's funny he won the
most important Pawn in the position
Robert and somehow I didn't like his
position afterwards no because the next
few moves we did see The Rook Angie just
that much better than its counterpart
and here was the critical moment Bishop
E2 that is actually the losing move in
this position instead the move Queen C2
giving up A3 it doesn't look pretty but
it defends all the pieces but Bishop E2
lost the game on the spot because that
takes check here Bishop can block but
then the queen comes the B1 The Rook
covers the king Escape that means the
back rank Checkmate and in the game the
king went on a bit of a journey but it
didn't get very far because Queen D5
picks up a piece and that was a win for
Neil sarn to even the match exactly it
was too easy for him to pick off that
piece at the end he spotted the tactic
immediately it went from opposite Bishop
slow grind to tactic game over knockout
and an even match Robert what a game
that was we got a fun time here in the
studio but we are going to kick it back
to Danny and the Gang to talk about
duda's win and much more back to you
Danny thank you guys wow boys we have
liftoff this day has indeed started with
a bang uh what to react to First is
going to be hard I think I'm gonna go in
reverse order they just spent a lot of
time on the star and Sevilla match we
have to talk a lot about what's ahead
there
says I'm not done yet rebounding Levy
the bong Cloud wasn't the end what are
you doing if you're on shift off to make
a comeback and and I don't even did he
play the French to scare the audience
into thinking that he was going to play
King E7 I I was walking through the
bathroom and I saw that on the monitor
now
and then he played D5 yeah that was a
shocking game because hikaru's level was
astronomical yesterday and today it felt
a little bit shaky it was a bit odd to
me I'm gonna quickly read off these
scores and then we're going to continue
that was hilarious yeah so as you see it
yon schistuff Duda keeps his cgc hopes
alive Wesley so gets another dub now
matches Hikaru in the win column Anish
Geary also keeping his friend Tamor
rajabov behind but Sam sevian and Nihao
Soren are now Dead locked at two and a
half games a piece we are going to have
a lot of amazing matches ahead today who
knows uh maybe we get Armageddon after
all guys what did we just see in this in
this Canty can'ty I want to go to you've
been talking a lot about savian Sauron
know your savvian's trainer yeah you're
also talking about the water in India
for the youngsters what do you see in
this man look man they going blow for
blow okay they won't blow for blow okay
you hit me I hate you you ever played
that game before right now
that's the game that they playing right
now they stand in there and they're
taking blow for blow whoever gonna hit
hardest is gonna win right now it's a
percentage starting brought it up and he
won he spotted the attacker instantly I
mean it was a basic tactic too but it's
hard in that time pressure facing Saran
Drew as well so I mean two two and a
half two and a half is even though what
are you doing emotionally right now to
recover from that if you're Savion
because we we said yesterday at the end
of the day if he starts badly a lot of
voices are going to start popping your
head do I belong here Soren was the
favorite by the community what are you
thinking if you're seven I think you
don't overstate the case I think it's
important to realize that Seven's doing
everything right he's not doing anything
wrong from an overall strategy
perspective I think his opening choice
is fine he was much better he was around
plus two at one point not to just pair
at the engine but it was significantly
better yeah his opening prep has been
great okay he made one blunder of this
the reason we're so surprised is that
this is the only blunder that has been
made basically in the entire match so
you know for sam7 you don't want to
start constructing the narrative in your
mind oh you know I gave up the lead and
now he's gonna get the lead you just
want to move on and you want to realize
the time match three more games let's go
yeah I was discussing this with you
yesterday his defensive abilities are
unreal savion's done a great job but
it's never over against nihal sarin
until that little thing pops up that
says you want my resume and even then
it's not over yeah even then you're like
are you sure is it a good game four
yesterday he was winning Savion could
have been up two and he was up a piece
and they all just kept playing and today
he kept playing as well yeah he was
better but uh Savion can't just cut it
out and he got to keep the same strategy
but yeah and the hell's not going away I
wanna I wanna talk about that point but
also give you props I was watching you
and Donya as a fan as the day closed
yesterday and you called it you said if
this match turns around it might be this
game that Soren held that Rook at night
versus Rook you said that and it was I
remembered that seed and I want to say
that the one thing about about nihal
watching this kid grow up online on
chefs.com he's often reminded me of that
guy who's over my right shoulder where
you play so many games you're so used to
being in time pressure and having to
find good moves you develop this
resourcefulness that other players don't
have and and you see that with Sauron in
those moments against Savion right
absolutely of course I mean sorry is so
resourceful and then we got the
percentage up this game I'm curious to
see what that would be probably maybe 80
90 once again but of course these guys
are fighting you know tooth and nail I'm
excited to see what happens next
especially with Sam hopefully Sam can
bounce back I'm like you know go to his
room Sam look bro it's what we got to do
okay just take one shot of creatine okay
that's it just wake up wake up I have
been dead on about this gear job of
match yeah job shows up and he plays E5
that's what I thought was gonna happen
but then ojava played a little spice on
there tries to win with black but play
G5 I started attacking Anisha just he
said no were you you nuts you attacking
me right you just won that game like
effortlessly right and I want to say
that I think a niche is not only well
poised obviously thanks Captain Obvious
he's leading on the scoreboard but I
think this is exactly where a niche
release rise when he gets a lead because
his style is so solid all the draw jokes
all those things he's such a tough nut
to crack that rajaba really has an
uphill battle here against a guy like
Anish who maybe gets criticized for not
winning enough but very rarely beats
himself yeah Anish is like the glue guy
on a basketball team he's not
necessarily the LeBron James
LeBron James he's not the Steph Curry
who hits the 40 Footers he's the guy who
kind of keeps the whole team together
right
has he played brilliant games absolutely
but he hasn't played a lot of him he
just sort of wins in the sort of working
man fashion he has all the fundamentals
in place very astute opening choice that
the stuff that don't really go doesn't
really go into the stat line that's what
Anish Gary is so good at and we're
seeing that in this match he's been just
amazing honestly like I don't think he's
played one bad game has he been under
any pressure yeah in the first five
games of this match speaking and draken
did not chill out Drake and played the
Von Henning Gambit okay I was gonna say
you went home Google it all right he
stacked upon and move five with black
yeah and he lost he's all in right now
and I was gonna say you've been such a
good coach for seven and now you've got
to be a coach for Dimitri on Drake and
what would you say across the pond here
to Serbia your voice going over the
Atlanta I really like his game too first
one be like look bro I like your game
you're not your game nice okay it's real
tight I love the tactics you know what I
mean Russia all day okay now at the same
time um we're gonna have to bounce back
bro we have to play some more solid game
but like Banco anything else right
something you have a Hannah whatever
Gambit that is it's not even you know
you can't play that with Wesley you just
can't do that kind of stuff so you have
to do maybe more solid obviously to go
uh from this round but he got to play
better that's it yeah I mean I don't I
think he actually has to play these
types of opening at this point he's down
four one and there's nothing to lose you
know if you play normal opening against
Wesley you know he's going to force a
draw if he wants it even though this
isn't really on draken style I think at
this point he just sort of comes to
terms of the fact that yeah I'm probably
going to lose I don't think he's lying
to himself and saying yeah my chances
are amazing I've got 4-1 against Wesley
yeah uh but but that can also be
liberating it can be liberating and it
can allow you to play some of your best
chess which I would have with you stop
right exactly exactly I'm expecting an
exciting exciting we're getting an E3
King E2 from a dragon real quick
E2 from on Drake and the bond Cloud okay
but back to yancha stuff who we said we
saw yuncha stuff not throwing in the
towel he wins against the coronakamura
E6 was not just a head fake to play the
bone Cloud uh let's call it what it is
this is still more than an uphill battle
all Hikaru and Wesley so have to do is
get a single Half Point over the next
three games but if you're Hikaru does
that have a reverse effect in your mind
where you kind of have to be careful of
the Trap of not playing to lose no no
okay
you're here for the concert it was it
was a bad game it was a strange game for
sure it was like but no uh he's got
three more punches and he's telling me
if we're gonna come out of here at four
four he needs half a point that's all he
needs I I believe in the guy I mean I
think it was just largely not to get too
specific but there was an opening
mistake I think ikar might have
overlooked uh that there was an early
Bishop F3 move which would have solved
all of his problems and basically got in
an unusable position but yeah stuff had
a specific tactic there you know I think
he cars not one to exaggerate things in
his mind okay things went wrong you have
three more chances yeah let's go I agree
and it also keeps his channel alive a
little longer hi everyone on hikaru's
channel as well if you tuned in for a
moment but all right before we take a
break all week our own James Canty has
been out and about in Toronto James went
to a local restaurant and got challenged
yep got challenged by one of the waiters
there yeah let's watch and uh and then
we'll talk about it
three minute all right let's do it okay
A little London system
all right quick oh nice development this
ain't bad he thinking he thinking Queen
D2 okay what is that your move
I mean it's cute you know it's a little
part you got more of them you got more
there it is
they actually played no you played good
though you played much better than I
thought right great game brother thanks
Ethan thank you man
you know you uh you check you check the
accuracy of the solar instead you
mentioned you check the accuracy of that
case you don't want to check that one I
don't you know we cgc I want them to
shine you know okay I don't want them to
be the superstars here but how was that
he that guy played pretty well there and
then yeah it's very nice he was he was
probably like I mean he said he was 1070
but he played more like 1400. I was
gonna say like was he like 13 1400 yeah
I got to guess the ELO going on here
yeah
exactly he got knocked out in the first
round but he made it yeah yeah he was in
the qualifiers yeah he's doing all right
and got 50 60 Move games going so he he
looks solid man I mean you know you
overtook that's what happens when Title
players play amateur but that was a
solid game yeah
you like that yeah all right come on you
know it before before we take it before
we take a break a quick reminder from
our sponsor everyone Brave means private
browsing and so much more by default
Brave blocks ads and trackers on every
page and video you visit even on YouTube
no ads means up to three times faster
page loading faster streaming faster
playback it means 35 percent longer
battery life while saving on mobile data
and internet bandwidth for Android iOS
and desktop get the best browser for
gamers streamers and creators switch in
60 seconds at brave.com chess all right
when we come back we will see a player
punch their ticket to will we see a
player punch their ticket to the semi
that's the question so much more to come
from the chess.com Global Championship
Finals twitch subscribers we have plenty
of exclusive content for you at the
break don't go anywhere and don't miss
it
[Music]
thank you
foreign
check it out we are here in Belgrade at
the chess.com Global Championship with
Grand Master Dimitri Andre and Dimitri
welcome hello thank you what are your
expectations for the chess.com Global
Championship Finals I think it will be a
great fight because too many strong
players strong opinions especially in my
side of table because first round
against so Wesley it will be very hard
for me but very interesting and very
funny good challenge
how is preparing for a rapid tournament
online different than preparing for a
classical tournament really it's a bit
different yes but not now because I
forgot how to prepare to classical
tournaments speaking of the internet
this year in the rapid Chess
Championship you have also beaten Hikaru
Nakamura and Wesley so so do you feel
like maybe you are the favorite here and
not the underdog I don't know but it was
only matches with two games it's a bit
in our situation because I think my
strong side is playing critical moments
and I don't think about time
favorite English matches maybe not so
big Underdog but okay maybe chances is
acquired
[Music]
hi guys today I'm going to be playing
some Chess at the University of Toronto
heart house chess club which I've
actually played in from even before I
was a student at University of Toronto I
was playing here when I was like a
little kid that just moved to Canada and
stuff like that so this place means a
lot to me
[Music]
upcoming we have a rapid Championship
but we also have a duck chest okay okay
we like Doug chess here
um process of looking more to get some
ducks
[Music]
ready for a game
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chess but with a duck quack quack
how to play duck chest the duck is a
brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck click on a
square to place the dog
foreign
[Music]
moves of opponent not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no London's
can permanently stop the London capture
the poems King to win oh wow no there's
no stalemate but still wait there is
still meat but the still made the player
wins ooh if only that was real chess I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
I think I think I actually am getting
the hang of it I think this works oh
that's a horrible blunder oh my God I
just blundered I have to move something
else first then dark and Knight will
take my king this is the best way to
lose the dark chess
foreign
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is a fast time winning
duck chess That's so exciting oh no no
no slip no no no no no no I won
yeah duck chess champion give me those
points baby
what's up
[Music]
welcome back
welcome back to Toronto and the cgc
center stage you see the cgc
championship trophy which will be
awarded to our champion on Monday also
pretty enticing is the 500 000 available
here in Toronto first place is a cool
000 prizes and that is really a ton of
money at stake oh yeah
so well we're back here Grand Master
Robert has alongside me is Grandmaster
mod Hampton we will have round six
underway shortly there are some many
decisive games in the first batch we had
in fact all four matches had a winner
there and we have some big leaders hikar
Nakamura despite that loss he still
leads four to one Wesley so shares that
same lead in each Geary he extended his
lead but nihal Saron he nodded that
match up against him seven yeah that
match is leveled up which I think a lot
of us myself included predicted you know
nihal starting to win that match but
ultimately tying it up has indicated you
know this is going to be a dog bite to
the end we might see eight games in that
one whereas anishkiri jumping up three
and a half to one and a half over
rajabov he's got a commanding lead now
well someone was commanding lead is
Hikaru Nakamura but yanja stuffed Duda
he might be feeling like he can strike a
second time in a row he gets the white
pieces now we see his white and red
setup the polish colors and he's going
to have to win on demand once more
that's right and you know I think we're
getting to that point Robert where if he
wins another game you're kind of shaking
in your boots a little bit if you're a
Hikaru Nakamura that for nothing
becoming 4-2 is not what it once was
certainly not and we see a Queen's
Gambit decline will question his answer
to capture on C4 the bishop on G2 is
very happy about that and this is
similar to the nihal song game against
Sam sebian the C4 Pawn is ugly it is a
bit loose it might just be captured but
black gets play around that sacrifice
Pawn that's right and a lot of the
concepts that we talked about are going
to be basically utilized here as well
keep in mind if Knight to B4 you know
Rook to A8 here will attack the black
queen and force the recapture so you're
not just losing material right out of
the gate and this position has been
played so many times at the highest
level I feel like I see Leonard
Dominguez playing this like 3 times a
tournament and Knight A2 you don't see a
move like that very often going after
this bishop here on C1 because while
white is up a pawn if a rook comes to B8
this B2 Pawn becomes a quick Target not
to mention with the queen and Bishop in
the same line This Knight on F3 is
pinned so we saw a trade it does feel to
me Iman like white is just up a pawn but
there aren't that many pawns remaining
there's not pawns on two sides of the
board you're not gonna create a past one
easily because after a swap on D4 that
is your extra Pawn blockaded by Bishop
on D5 and you're you're absolutely right
I mean we have to highlight that that
this is truly an extra Pawn there's no
tricks or gimmicks here uh Duda is going
to be up that extra Pawn but you know
what I think I think that Hikaru
experience you know for the first time
in this competition in Toronto here
experience what it's like to lose a game
that might have been a wake-up call he's
saying wait a minute I've got four
points in this match let me play a
theoretical line which he's in right now
liquidate I might be slight worse but he
wants that draw to get out of this match
before a comeback happens and in all
honesty a loss in that game five because
he had not lost a single game and when
you play against John schistov Duda you
expect to suffer a punch here or there
and four to one is still a monster
performance you know if you have a
little bit of recency bias you may be
feeling badly but you said after five
games you'd be a four to one a car would
say yep I'm gonna take that for sure
exactly and in this position H6 played
by hikara challenging the bishop this
bishop can take on F6 and if that
happens the bishop takes back and
there's all this pressure down on D4 and
I feel like if you need to win games I
don't love the opening Choice from JKD
exactly like it's hard to criticize
because he's got that extra Pawn but you
have to think about the match situation
one thing about the game of chess is
that once you get all the pawns on one
side of the board it becomes a lot more
drawish the concept of an outside pass
Bond Robert and why that's so strong is
that it forces your opponent to play in
both sides to the board but what Hikaru
is doing is he's played the move C5 he
wants to take eventually on D4 get rid
of his only weakness and have one Pawn
Island E6 F7 G7 and H6 pawns all
beautifully connected he's got the
bishop pair I think also he could
consider giving up the bishop for the
Knight I know it looks counter-intuitive
but it gets opposite Bishops Robert and
there might be some real chances to just
you know secure a position where he's
down a pawn but he knows he can draw it
for sure there's so many different
options here that look appealing for
black but he is down that pawn I know we
keep saying they're the position is
level we see the evaluation bar yeah
let's see how we can make use of that
pawn one thing you want to avoid if
you're a Hikaru is this Knight is ready
to go to E1 and we've talked about the
dynamic of Knight versus Bishop here if
we trade the light Square Bishops that
Knight's gonna be able to hop around and
annoy black and the thing about Knights
they prefer it when their pawns on one
side of the board that's right that's
right and I was about to mention after
Queen A5 hey great move I think what we
might see here Robert is Queen A1 Queen
takes Queen I mean what else are you
gonna do Rook takes Queen and then hikar
might just decide it's time Bishop takes
Knight on F3 get that opposite Bishop
position
I mean what do you think Robert you're
up one Pawn it's you know pretty much
all on one side of the board the last
ditch effort is after C takes D4 Robert
would you ever consider playing e takes
D4 I said what you're saying we'll bring
up an announcement real quick the point
is if C takes D4 right here then white
can take what the E Pawn says on I don't
love the look of it because a rook
quickly comes to C8 and pressures the C3
Pawn but if you take on D4 with the c
Pawn which might just happen after
Bishop F3 Bishop this is what Amman has
been highlighting opposite color Bishops
what white will try to do Target the F7
Pawn on a light Square bring your Rook
up to A7 play D5 just take and then try
to expand your pawns on there it's a
long story it's me very difficult to win
we will leave Yan chest of Duda to
figure that out because the next game is
also about to get underway this one
between Wesley so and Dimitri on draken
Wesley so only needs a draw just like a
car Nakamura exactly they find
themselves in the same situation Robert
and you know what we just saw in the
hikara match was his willingness to go
for that draw are we gonna see the same
thing from Wesley so well Wesley he
loves himself a good end game so does
Dimitri on drinking but keyword being
good and game good and that last game
Wesley had an extra Pawn he played
Without risk he was able to convert that
Advantage now Dimitri gets white he was
not really on point with white in day
one here in day two no way
no way well he's on point if the point
is the B4 Square and now today he's on
point Robert so you called it
brilliantly look Dimitri on Drake and he
needs to shake it up uh I didn't expect
this though no and Wesley so is a player
that's nearly impossible to Rattle and
maybe that's why he chose B4 if you just
play Mainline stuff Wesley so is
extremely well prepared and he does not
lose very often so playing B4 is like
all right you are gonna have to pick
some opening you haven't looked at this
in probably 15 years since you were a
teenager and after B4 he plays D5 in the
center of course that's a good response
the reason we like putting our Pawn
Center we take away key squares and the
pawn on B4 does not do the same job
right and he's actually chosen an
interesting line because there is a more
valid opening I'll call it pawn to B3
right the Larson and this is actually a
line you can play against that pawn to
D5 and Bishop to G4 the idea being
you're stopping white from playing Pawn
to E3 and if they play Knight to F3 you
usually snap that off right away
exchange your Bishop for the night
double the opponent's pawns and just get
a really solid setup and speaking of
solid setups Wesley only needs a draw
Robert so I think he's going for that
plus there's a Pawn on B4 so it's even a
little more loose right because as soon
as black pushes the pawn on the e-file
the B4 Pawn has to be defended in many
positions but will Dimitri play G4 here
he started with H3 he plays G4 he is in
a must win position a draw is equivalent
to a loss for Dimitri so he's going all
in yeah and this is going to be a really
exciting round Robert because we have a
couple matches that could end so I hope
everyone is paying good attention to
these matches the pawn on B4 the pawn on
G4 already should indicate you know this
game is going to be wild unorthodox this
is like oh you know when you play on the
wing you should respond in the center
well nobody's playing in the center and
he just started playing on the wings G4
B4 this game is crazy it is indeed and I
think that Wesley he's gonna continue
playing solidly and that's a good
strategy he doesn't need to take any
risky approaches anyway pushes H Pawn
things like that because as soon as you
play H5 I'm already looking at moves
like Knight E5 just challenging this
bishop where it sits so C6 creating a
solid Pawn chain guess what a fan cutter
Bishop does not like to be met by a pawn
chain on that diagonal because you are
blocking its axis restricting it already
so I like the approach from Wesley he's
spending a little bit of time and yet
he's still having the clock that's right
yeah Wesley you know took time initially
because whenever you're surprised in the
opening you don't usually want to move
immediately almost like you're
pretending that you expected that like
no you didn't expect B4 of course not
you're not supposed to instead takes his
time thinks how do I want to approach
this game when only a draw is needed he
doesn't want to sort of go into the
territory that Dimitri is trying to reel
him into he doesn't want to play that
wild game he's staying really really
solid and speaking of solid he's trying
to get that same setup you mentioned
Pawn B7 C6 D5 against Bishop G2 he might
be trying to set that up on the other
side side of the board with G7 F6 and E5
he's playing with all pawns and some
hope and he wants to get that pawn E5
but now it's time for Dimitri to strike
because when you opponent pushes his
pawns you say let me challenge that
setup I like the idea with C4 just
trying to challenge D5 get my queen out
to B3 and black is underdeveloped only
does light score Bishop is out white has
two pieces out there and you can start
putting pressure on Black's Center
exactly yeah you know you also look at
the amount of pieces the amount of time
it's going to take Wesley to get castle
Pawn E5 Bishop D6 Knight E7 castle
that's a lot of moves Robert and in that
time we might see some counter attack as
you mentioned Pawn C4 I love and also
remember that pawn on B4 can slide to B5
well it does it as I'm speaking about it
Robert that's the reason you play these
aggressive pawn moves having said a
you've got to say B you know he started
with b and then he went with G and now
we're in a wild Affair but this game has
the central tension ensues will leave
Wesley so to figure out how he wants
reply to this Pawn under attack we see
Timo rajabov gearing up to have the
white pieces against Anish giri Anish
now has a two-point lead in that matchup
the number one player from Holland he is
proving his might some people some
critics say oh and he's giri he's never
won a Super tournament I think that
ignish is happy to look at these
insights here and say well look at my
accuracy look at how few bad moves I've
made and well rajava can say much the
same yeah
maybe uh you know guys like Yuri and
rajaba I think it's the the bad moves
number the percentage that stands out to
me there's a reason that this match has
been one of the closest ones there's
been a lot of draws in this match so far
it's hard to win a chess game Robert
when you don't have a blunder or a
mistake from your opponent it really is
and we see this one a little bit more
normal in the opening another Queen's
Gambit decline setup with the G3 Bishop
G2 so rajabov is kind of mixing lines
here playing a Catalan with the Knight
already out in C3 500 carwana is
hovering around these parts somewhere he
has played this variation against the
likes of sir kuryakin and has been
increasingly popular and you see a niche
he plays the Catalan from the white side
right he's now pausing because he's like
what does Timor want from me exactly and
you're sort of mixing a few ideas here
you've got what seemed to be more of a
Queen's Gambit start but now you're
looking at more of a G3 maybe a Catalan
Black's got that Bishop out to B4 sort
of like a rickos in setup and you know
you're kind of mixing and mashing a few
different opening ideas but Robert is it
the theme for today takes on C4 and we
might get E4 you know pun to B5 we've
seen this stuff in so many games right
and now anes can think do I want to
develop my knight first do I play C5 and
a move you often use the strike at the
center he chooses Knight C6 and he might
try to keep this Pawn on C4 Rook B8
followed by Pawn to B5 is a viable
option A6 B5 much of the same and rookie
one makes the intentions clear let me
push this Pawn up to E4 claim the center
so I'm on at first glance here rajaba up
over 15 minutes
do you think that he's playing the same
this is my chance I need to win this
game here and I completely agree with
that mentality so yes Robert I think
that is the way he's playing the match
score right now is starting to get a
little bit out of hand like let's not
forget although we have a couple matches
that are four to one and they're a draw
away from a match win Geary can also win
this match with a win so this could be
the last game in this match as well but
you have to feel that you know a guy
like giri you know jokes jokes uh-huh
you know he could draw on demand but I
think that's the last guy you want to
hand Four Points to because the
likelihood of him getting a four and a
half Roberts pretty high right and he
plays B5 he's keeping that extra Pawn so
rajaba will need to prove that this
sacrifice is worthy and will give him
legitimate winning chance he might lose
the game and be eliminated but at least
he's taking the risk let's go back to
the game between the car and Nakamura
and Yan chest of Duda because in that
one we have seen quite a lot of
liquidation it is Rook bishop and
four four white Rook bishop and three
four black but the opposite color
Bishops that is the important factor
here so man you saw this coming a mile
away extra Pawn for Duda it's been that
way for a long time but I feel like
winning chances are actually very slim
right and this is a type of position
where you almost have to be satisfied if
you're either player if you're Hikaru
Nakamura this is the game you signed up
for you willingly gave up that pawn and
orchestrated and initiated all these
trades to get here you only need a draw
to win this match and move on so Hikaru
is probably happy to have this but also
if you're Duda and you're playing the
way that he did in that opening Robert
you can't expect better than what you've
got on the board so I honestly just
don't think either player can complain
here they say chess plays best often
it's gonna be a draw and here we see an
extra pump but no actual plan that's the
problem for due to some positions even
without extra material you see a clear
plan for one side and not for the other
hey Cora's plan is obvious let me
shuffle my Rook back and forth forever
and then for white at some point you
need to play F4 maybe E4 and so on but
there actually isn't a knockout that I
see even if I gave white like five free
moves and that is the issue facing Jan
chistav Duda he may be happy to have won
that round five but here in game six
it's just looking like he doesn't have
enough material remaining to land
another victory yeah that's a great
Point uh you know one of the toughest
things to do in chess Robert is to sit
there and do nothing Hikaru is gonna do
nothing he knows that's the right plan
so it's up to Duda look he's his
tournament life is on the line here
Robert he needs to win this game he's
got the extra pun we'll see what he can
do for sure another must win game but a
matchup that doesn't actually have a
much must win situation is the one
between nihal sarin and Sam Sevin you
see Sam there with his hands between the
middle of his glasses he might be
praying because he did get a second
chance in this field we we see that he
is not quite as accurate as nihal sarin
but I think that's in part because nihal
plays far more end games than Savion
does exactly and you know these these
top players these youngsters they're now
reshaping their games to include the end
games that used to be the area where you
say oh you know these these young
talents Robert well they're coming at me
with tactics we'll just trade pieces
take them to an end game and beat them
there but no when it comes to Nihao Sam
Savion they have very well-rounded games
now including the end game portion and I
wonder if we'll see you know a blunder
like what we saw in that last game
Robert he's got to bounce back with a
solid start here and we see a scotch in
this game so uh an opening that can
actually be quite devious not played
that often the highest levels there are
certain players like Jana Palmer she
Wesley so himself the essay from time to
time but here we see the knight jump out
to B3 now the pawn E4 is under attack
and I believe it can be captured this is
not a blunder it's a sacrifice eyes and
look at Savion he is like wait a second
this looks fishy to me but Niha is like
I have a grander plan I'm gonna get the
two Bishops the open board so even
though it might cost me a pawn it is
worth it right and you know when you get
that feeling over the board that
something looks a little fishy I think
what you're concerned about is that it
looks a little stock fishy you're
worried that your opponent has prepared
something using the engine to help and
you know that's not a place that you
want to be in the opening imagine Robert
you're on move six or seven and you
don't know what's going on you're taking
what seems like a free pawn and your
opponent you know stone cold is just
replying immediately that's frightening
and after that loss in the last game I
don't think he wants to maybe jump into
a risky position like that well if he
doesn't take on e4 he may just drop the
bishop back to B6 and Sam he's going for
a deep think but some players are moving
very quickly as we look at the bird's
eye view in the top right look at how
much that position is changed between
Dimitri on draken and Wesley so it feels
like all of White's pawns March forward
and then black played F5 so the position
is ready to blow up exactly and I I love
this bird's eye views you see all the
games currently in action and that eval
bar right around even across the board
Robert so we have some really really
close matchups here as actually three of
these matches Robert could end depending
on the result that's right and sam7 he's
moving very slowly here so let's tune
back in to the game between Dimitri on
draken and Wesley so Dimitri needs to
win this game this is a must-win game a
draw is not good enough and he's going
for it he is sending his pieces forward
look at this Connect Four from F2 to C5
the B file is ready to open but there's
a big problem here the king is in the
center and that Rook on f8 is very happy
about that exactly and you're
highlighting that file unfortunately
it's impossible to keep it closed
there's no idea to play G5 here and hope
to just sidestep things because black is
going to follow through with Pawn to F4
and the tension between the E3 pawn and
the F4 Pawn means black can guarantee to
open up that file and if the Knight on
E7 jumps into the F5 Square afterwards
Robert we could be seeing honestly a
massacre on the king side so I think
Andre can honestly ask here's a tread
carefully here to not lose the game in a
couple moves he certainly does because
we mentioned whites Connect Four black
has the same and this is a very good
illustration is that you tend to attack
in the direction of your Pawn chain so
white is trying to increase pressure on
the queen set open up files there black
is doing it on the king side and the
last move just was played was Knight E2
I think Dimitri made a smart choice here
he wants to bring that Knight to F4
where it attacks the bishop tries to get
into E6 to and close down the Rook on f8
so I think 92 even though it looks
strange locking in your Bishop that was
a good choice agree totally I think that
F4 move move or Pawn takes G4 it was
just going to be too strong you know
there is an idea to take on G4 here
Robert and try to attack that g-pawn
because the g-pawn on on G4 like that it
is going to be subject to a few moves
white also has the knight move Knight to
F4 anyway that'll threaten Knight E6
that'll threaten the bishop and it'll
finally let White's Bishop on F1 develop
because the one thing about the position
here for ondraken is he's not developed
in that King Robert I mean yeah I know
we're not castling Queen side and you're
gonna have to pay me some good money to
Castle kingside here can only castle
queenside if there were Fisher random
chest but the Rook did not start on B1
here and this looks very dangerous but
it's just the type of game you need if
you're Dimitri on Drake and so Wesley so
he's thinking he's doing all that is
necessary he does take on G4 here and I
liked your choice I think that you can
even give up the pawn but maybe give it
up this way Knight F6 then play Knight
F4 yeah go for this Pawn it's not
meaningful says Dimitri on draken and
now Knight F4 there might be an exchange
sack right away yeah that's a great
Point Queen C7 is almost like a little
bit of a litmus test here because Queen
C7 do you even have the guts to play
Knight F4 I'm highlighting that maybe I
want to sack but the thing is the
sacrifice is not forced so with the
white pieces now you have to sit there
and calculate okay can my opponent play
Rook takes F4 you spend maybe a minute
and a half two minutes calculating that
and then you know what your conclusion
you still have to decide if you're gonna
play the move at all so it's a great
decision Queen C7 but maybe Bluff called
Robert are you taking on F4 here I'm
definitely taking on a four wouldn't be
surprised was it you're attacking my
Bishop any six Let's Play Bishop F7 and
then continue from there but this game
still so much life left and another game
that is heating up is the one between a
niche gear and team over job of where
job of gave away the C4 Pawn in that one
and as we see here here man I think some
pieces are missing from the queen side a
lot of the action on the king side and
there in the center yeah it's like and
finish Geary instead of you know maybe
trading a piece for a different piece
he's traded his Queen side for the king
side by the looks of it because there's
nothing left on Black's Queen side there
the Knight on D4 supported by the pawn
and look at that pawn mass as well
that's four pawns it might not look like
it right now but they start to get going
Robert that's a couple pass bonds that
are going to be tough to handle and the
pressure continues to mount however you
know if you count things up you do the
mathematics here Robert White does have
you know it's a great position and pawns
going on the king side as well right
because white kind of almost has an
extra Pawn at this point when you've
double pawns they're harder to get
moving whereas white is ready to play
move an E5 at some point with Bishop D5
so already E5 maybe traps the Knight on
H5 threatens Bishop D5 all sorts of
ideas here not to mention you can just
win a pawn with Bishop takes D4 right
and we see a trade here and Rook takes
D2 Rook takes F3 can't white just go
down the D file here and say this is
like a nearly winning end game exactly
that Rook on F3 while it's nice to trade
the bishop on G2 for black absolutely
that piece and you highlighted it was
going to jump into D5 but now the Rook
on F3 kind of has to take the long way
around there are some roads closed and
the detour is necessary you got to go
back to f8 then to d8 just to challenge
the file but you don't have time for
that Robert that's two three moves white
is going to be playing Rook A7 Rook
takes A6 B Pawn Falls after that
everything crumbles no this is I think
already a lost ending and look at
regell's clock by the way he has more
than double the time of Anish giri yeah
he's feeling it this game I mean he got
obliterated a game ago but that's how
quickly things change when you're in
form exactly and he's brought it right
back with the white pieces another move
to consider here which I love now that I
think about it is Pawn to E5 that Knight
on H5 currently can only move to the F6
Square so not only does Pawn E5 you know
get that pawn majority going for white
but it stops the only retreating swear
for the night and and although you're
not trapping the night you know and
threatening to win it you are
restricting all its squares so you're
kind of playing up a piece for the
moment yeah Timor is spoiled for choice
and I think he's gonna sail through in
this game and cut that lead back down to
one so this game looking very good for
the player for Azerbaijan Wesley so
against Dimitri on draken that match can
conclude after this game if Dimitri on
draken does not win so as we look at
that position there is a black Pawn on
G5 Wesley says I am gonna deal with some
of the king side pressure with pushing
my Pawn in front of my king and in doing
so he's carved out the H4 Square for his
Knight that's right you actually see an
interesting spot where both sides are
using an H4 an H5 Square as their
Outpost usually you think an outpost on
the side of the board well that's not
that great but here I love it a lot more
for Wesley not only does the bishop
behind the Knight threaten to maybe
capture on H5 but the Knight on H4 also
seems to do a little bit more in the
position the F3 square is tender and hey
if you want to make that King actually
admit that it's not going to Castle
Knight G2 check as well yeah just throw
that check in there and the king is
forced to remain in the center and
they're all sorts of tactics thanks as
Rook on f8 so for Dimitri right now he
just come up with a plan he's been
making some useful looking moves but now
in a situation all right your knight
looks active you have the opportunity to
play B takes d66 open the B file but
opening a file may backfire if you
haven't Castle your Rooks are not
connected so if you do take on C6 then
black plays Rook a to B8 offers a trade
that final that you previously had on
your control that's mine now exactly and
you know the the thing about not
castling and you know you might not even
realize it you think oh yeah I cannot
Castle here it's it's closed off but
it's when the files get open and the
Rooks are not connected that's when you
notice oh yeah that's why we Castle in
chess as well it's King safety but it's
also to make sure those Rooks are
connected and they protect each other
otherwise you lose full control of your
own first rank for sure and guess whose
king is not castling I don't like the
look of Castle's King side no because
black has more pieces more Firepower
staring at that side of the board this
queen on A3 can't get over to the king
side this queen on C7 a sneaky little
piece over there staring all the way
down that diagonal so I really like
Wesley's position I think he's handled
as well and if you're Dimitri a draw is
not good enough you know you can make
some Quiet Moves maybe it's time for F3
it looks very risky but I'm just
challenging the center and if you take
in comes my next night and I'm just
trying to get some possibilities here
and I think that if he was gonna play
this move you kind of gotta play it a
lot quicker Robert because we have three
almost three minutes and Ticking down
he's got to do something here Black's
play seems really easy if you play an F3
I'm gonna take I'm gonna defend G5 play
Rook a to E8 just nice and easy moves so
I find that the position is so much
easier for Wesley to play in that time
situation is only going to help I agree
with you I mean Knight H4 seems very
natural right now and then Dimitri's
back on the clock trying to make b66 and
use the B file but black can even play
Rook to B8 right cover that file
preemptively so I really like the look
of this position for Wesley so he looks
to send Dimitri on draken home eliminate
him from the tournament and move on to
the semi finals and you know this game
it's just one another one of those where
Dimitri's giving it his all trying his
best and just like the game between Duda
and Nakamura just seems like their
opponents are playing well yeah that's a
great Point Robert but this game does
look like we know where it's going let's
get a bird's eye view and take a look at
all the games now because we might need
to do some jumping around Robert as
things are heating up across the board
we certainly might I mean the game
between nihal sarin and sam7 that one
also looks interesting because nihal has
committed his King to the queen side and
Sam is like wait a second my Rook can go
to that open file over there in the
bottom right hand side of the screen The
Rook on B8 is trying to barrel down the
B file use that to his advantage and
Nakamura Duda they're still in the same
place we left them just shuffling around
trying to make a miracle happen is Duda
so why don't we just head into the game
between nihal and Sam we haven't given
them a good look just yet but at first
glance them on I'm loving the potential
of this b-file action for black exactly
and it's that pawn on A3 which is
probably why you're saying that because
if it was back on A2 Knight defended on
B3 you just don't feel that same
pressure but the loose position means
hey if white ever goes crazy and plays
B4 you're gonna crack that position open
with Pawn A5 or Pawn to C5 so that open
B file well semi-open B file something
that Sam is going to enjoy and opposite
sized castling I think we might even see
more from the white pieces here in terms
of G4 maybe we'll see G4 G5 from Nihao
this could be a back and forth attacking
game all of a sudden that would be
something and already in this game
offered a pawn for the bishop pair
Bishop takes F2 is a threat because the
Knight on B3 is loose and The Rook on B8
is happy to see that so if you make some
random move Bishop takes F2 can happen
but I'm not sure you want that right you
give up the the dark squares you give
white the initiative to throw the pawns
forward so that's what nihal is
considering here and well let me ask you
something nihal won the previous game
sometimes you feel pressure to keep it
going and then you start playing for a
win and when you play for a result
you're not really playing chess because
you need to remain objective that's a
great point you can never lose your
objectivity and obviously the top guys
in the world the very players in this
tournament they're the best at that
because you can't let the emotions get
the better of you that's usually when we
saw a JKD play the bomb Cloud that's a
perfect example of letting your emotions
get the better of you when he actually
came back sat down today won a great
match Robert so yes I completely agree
you don't want to get carried away if
your knee held sarin but I'm liking the
way he's setting things up and the way
that he's been willing to sacrifice
pawns already in this game tells me that
he's probably okay with things like
Bishop takes F2 here he wants those two
Bishops willing to give up pawns for it
and I'm even liking the idea potentially
Rook H3 to G3 hitting that H6 pawn and
The Rook also performs a cute little
task there defending that Knight on B3
right Rook H3 a little bit difficult
because you know you're allowing a move
like D5 where that Rook on H3 is under
attack but it is a good multi-purpose
move the Rook lift protecting the Knight
but going for the attack and one thing
I'll add here is nihal has played much
more quickly we look at the clocks he's
up almost three minutes and so that is a
good sign for him because yesterday he
was way too slow I'm sure he took some
advice from his coaches his trainers and
we're like you got to speed up because
you can't play on the mere seconds
exactly because he's such a quick player
in his own right he can do that if he
just speeds up then I mean he's using
the clock as a weapon and the board now
that he's got this match back to even he
probably feels less pressure like oh I
have to win I have to win so you can
focus on the game at hand that's true
but somebody who does have to win is
yonchist of Duda and he's making some
progress against Hikaru Nakamura we were
saying it would take some shuffling and
finally the pawns have to go forward
they have in fact gone forward Iman so
we looked there E4 and F4 and even if
the Bishops were gone there's still some
chance to win position like this but I
actually like the fact that they're
Bishops of opposite color because the F7
Pawn is on the light square that can
become a Target yeah and I think White's
you know maximum coordination here will
be the bishop and Rook coordinating on
the F7 Pawn but from a square where it
can be protected so imagine White's Rook
is on the B7 Square then the bishop
would be able to slide to B3 it would be
protected by the rook and they'd be
ganging up on the F7 pawn and Robert a
concept that you and I were discussing
on the broadcast yesterday was when you
have opposite Bishops and you're
advancing pawns two pawns together white
for example would never ever want to
play the move F5
that's just awful right you're giving up
dark squares black will blockade and
just sit there but instead Pawn to E5
Robert is the intention and E5 not only
does what Amman sings the general
principle in obstacle Bishops it also
threatens E6 that pawn on F7 is pinned I
think hit car is in a really tough spot
but due to down under five seconds now
he needs to make moves quickly he brings
his King into F5 but this Pawn on F4
that's what a car wants to go after not
so fast you can't get to F3 the bishop
covers the square and you can't get to
A4 might seem like a strange thing to
mention now but Pawn to E5 opens up that
fourth rank there's no Rook A4 there's
no Rook F3 and guess what The Rook on D7
guards the bishop on D1 so the bishop is
staying there as well somehow I think
JKD has found some beautiful harmony
with his pieces however with 5.6 seconds
on the clock Robert I'm not sure you'll
be able to keep that Harmony the good
news is there's no risk in this position
he needs to win the game that's the hard
part but he can just give some checks
and watch out because H6 Pawn can also
be loose that's the problem with
hikaru's Pawn structure if he had this
Pawn back over here on G7 he's like all
right not a big deal my pawns are
connected but if this King runs away to
E7 already you have to think is Rook h8
coming that's right I don't think that
you should release and he brings her
back to D4 that way the pawn F4 is
safeguarded in advance but that's the
thing about these end games you may
think I'm just gonna go for pawns but
that actually gives black chances that's
right yeah you can't get carried away
especially with that time ticking down
so low Hikaru you know one of the
absolute best using your own time
against you and King back so not playing
E5 because maybe he didn't want F6 to
happen and more trades right you want to
avoid trades we don't have that much
material remaining and Duda he's down to
6.8 seconds Hikaru well ahead in the
clock and he's using his time wisely
what he likes to do hit car is so good
at this is he'll want to make moves in a
flurry he doesn't want to make a move do
this response immediately and then now
his car thinks for 30 seconds he'll
think in advance and then once due to
response he'll make a move put him on
the clock so right now The Rook B4 he
actually hasn't moved yet I really
thought he had a second move plan but
now your plan Amman could be devastating
yeah I'm looking at that and I'm
actually questioning the move Bishop E3
and for another reason as well Robert
the bishop on E3 is now going to get hit
by King to F3 that's gonna be important
at some point in this position you know
ganging up on that F4 Pawn is not that
easy if you imagine like Rook to C1 by
Hikaru here well that Bishop can move
and then we have Rook to B7 with check
and when that F7 Pawn gets taken by The
Rook it'll actually guard the F4 Pawn as
well
oh well my arrows are a little place not
much time remaining but Wesley so and
each Geary they have some interesting
games going on as well as you see in the
right hand side of the screen well for a
niche it's not good news he's about to
lose that game the night on H5 looks
trapped over there the king 98 might get
checked man as well on the left hand
side of the screen Wesley so only needs
a draw his King is on H6 White's King is
on D1 there's a Pawn on B7 so it seems
like all Havoc has broken loose on that
board and yet it perhaps Wesley just has
a draw by repetition this might be the
end of Andrea's tournament I don't think
his King can escape that's right we have
to tune into this one because this might
be the last that we see of ondrakin as I
gotta say I'm pretty convinced by this
repetition on the board right that Queen
can go to F2 if the King goes to E1 that
forces the King right back there and if
the King goes to C1 well you can just go
Queen C3 this is a draw by force that
means Dimitri and dragon is forced out
of here he is gonna have to leave Serbia
in that tie from 58 place and Wesley so
will have a chance going through to the
semifinals that's right and Wesley
completes the draw by repetition and you
know that eight game match is now over
Robert four and a half points has been
reached by Grandmaster Wesley so and
knocking out Dimitri on draken a great
match from Wesley he just was so
composed game one he could have lost
that game and lost the match very early
instead he fought and he managed to
survive that one we see the final score
is four and a half one and a half it is
eight game matches first to four and a
half wins and the first player in the
cgc to four and a half is Wesley so and
congratulations to him they will not
play the rest of those games of course
Robert you know you don't send a
defeated guy back into the ring for a
couple more rounds when he's already
knocked out but what a match by Wesley
it started out so shaky for him as that
guy right there Dimitri on Drake and had
him against the ropes there was missed
mates in this match but ultimately he
came away with the victory and we have a
few players with just seconds on their
clock with this game here between nihal
sarin and Sam Sevin the Queens are off
the board it's a position where the both
sides have even material the Knight on
A5 a bit offside but D6 is loose that
we're gonna do one staring along the
open file so without the Queens on the
board doesn't look so scary but look at
these games here we see Duda and
Nakamura Duda is making progress that
pawn on H6 is loose The Rook comes to F6
to attack and defend but the problem for
whites is always this Rook A4 type of
maneuver for Hikaru and that evil bar is
going up I'm on it's going up and I
think it's because if Bishop takes on F7
Robert but missed due to the time
pressure and the eval bar is you know
it's sort of keeping consistent here so
I mean that one looks really interesting
with Duda you know playing for his
tournament life here and I think we
gotta jump to that one Robert
yes this game here with E6 now the pull
into F6 the one to E6 and the E7 square
is under Black's control so Hikaru
Nakamura has blockaded the pass Pawn but
there might be some tactics there there
was a rook GA check I think he missed a
rook G8 maneuver and we can show that
eventually that the The Rook coming to
see if the king took with the bishop on
the diagonal the pawn could have pushed
so just watch out for those Maneuvers
but all Duda is doing is bring his King
in and is the king reaching the other
side it looks like that might be enough
it's time for King to E8 Robert yeah the
King goes to E8 and now Bishop B7 the
pawn gets up to E7 so can you move your
king at that point that's you might be
like getting your king in its own box
here oh my gosh he makes space for it
because King date there's Bishop A5 but
if you want to see it there's Rook C7
checks so this is should be a win for
Yan she has a both players in time
trouble here bring the Rook back now
it's time to retreat The Rook he goes
the d8 if you take I get a new Queen but
I think you can bring the Rook back and
Nish Geary he is in trouble he's just
down upon in the end game against team
of rajaba he actually equalized for a
moment there I don't know how but this
end game actually looks like a very easy
win with White's King helping the Jeep
on up the board but right now Hikaru
Nakamura he's on the verge of losing his
second game in a row the King goes back
to D5 Rook G4 and is Rook G8 the threat
yeah he resigns that's gonna be game
over and he is quickly out of there as
JKD is starting to make this comeback a
real thing Robert it's now four to two
can you believe it I don't think anybody
can believe it including Yankee stuff
dude he played the bomb cloud of all
openings yesterday he memeed it but he
is here for real he has won two games in
a row to start day two and akara
Nakamura shakes his head runs away from
the playing Hall and if he wants to win
the cgc trophy he needs to just forget
about this day so far and just make a
draw yeah he's been trying to do that
Robert it's four to two but we talk
about Chess being a momentum game and
that guy just on your screen there JKD
he has the momentum in Hikaru he needs
to make a draw to conclude this match
because it's starting to get out of hand
Robert and while this match still goes
on so does the one between Niche gear
and team over job up Geary lost this
game Timor strikes back after anisha's
great win in round five now here in game
six rajabo says not so fast my friend
today we are going to be combative
that's right two wins to start things
off for either player not the draws that
we saw yesterday and Robert day two of
the action has been so exciting it
certainly has Anish giri you know he is
probably going to be licking his wounds
a little bit that game it looked like it
was all her job of the opening was
interesting you have to applaud rajaba
for sacrificing that pawn and playing
towards the king side but for Anish giri
he is going to regret how that game went
he will need to forget about it quickly
but now that those other three games are
done we do have this one here between
nihal sarin and Sam sebien and savings
pawns look like they're about to be
picked off one by one on the queen side
yeah something about this position it
feels it was first of all it's
interesting that the Queens got traded
we have opposite sides castling I
thought we would see big attacks from
both players instead Queens traded but
what about that last decision you
mentioned the pawns were about to
disappear instead it was the bishop pair
that disappears for Sam Sevin he gives
it up to try to keep his Pawn but he
can't do that he has to lose something
here Robert yeah he does the D5 Pawn can
in fact be captured here that is a
hanging piece in the center of the board
but what does seven get in return for
that if the bishop takes on D5 maybe
eventually a rookie too and if not then
he can finish his development and say I
know I'm down material that's not good
for me but my pieces are actually
getting active that's right and you know
something that he might want here is
let's say you know we capture on D5
Robert if you want to put a line on the
board for fun takes on D5 let's say
instead of recapturing Bishop to F5 and
after Bishop five you know we might
capture on C6 Knight C5 you know Rook H
to E1 oopsies Knight to B3 it just shows
how quickly things can turn around of
course you know these strong players
knee how is not gonna be blundering and
mate like that but uh when when things
like that are even in the air you have
to worry for the safety of White's King
and that may seem like hot players don't
just take free material you could
probably get away with it but if the
Rook takes on D5 there's like Bishop E6
The Rook has to move back then Knight C5
and there are threats Knight B3 wasn't
just a Checkmate threat no Bishop on A5
is a bit loose so he plays B4 which I
think is a fantastic move this Knight on
A6 is going nowhere I'm on C5 underwise
control as is C7 yeah that's a great
move because even if Knight C7 is
possible you can take that and just play
an end game light Square Bishop against
light Square bishop and probably be
better we talked about the concept of
Pawns on one side of the board being
very drawish we have the opposite here
we have an outside pass respond
potential for white with the A3 B4 pawns
against the A7 Pawn so amazing to see
that with you know basically the
restraint Robert not to take on D5 it's
hanging twice
and nihal sarin may only be 18 years old
but he plays like a veteran in these
moments and Bishop F5 it doesn't
threaten Checkmate but it does threaten
a pretty nasty check because there will
be a second check to follow on C2 and
then the F2 Pawn is loose so big
decision here for Neil good for him he
is over three minutes the time
management has been Stellar it has it's
been perfect you want to be a little bit
ahead of your opponent especially when
you're putting that pressure the clock
only adds to it a really interesting
move here to show absolute restraint
Robert might be king to D2 kind of crazy
move King D2 saying you know what that
outside pass Pawn is enough but he caves
and he takes the pawn not necessarily a
mistake but certainly inviting a wild
position of complications right because
there is a check on C2 but what he's
relying on the fact the bishop hanging
on F5 so he can bring his King up to B3
and you can't get away with capturing on
F2 when your Bishop is loose over here
so I think that was good calculation
right over everything by nihal sarin
that's right it is calculation over
everything for these young guys the
talent that we see here Rook C2 playable
but you get in this position where after
King B3 it's like everything's hanging
by a thread and I'm not sure he can do
that because guess what he's kind of
playing down a knight here you have to
take the time to play Knight to B8
Knight to D7 Knight to F6 like to
activate that piece it takes so long
yeah and you might lose it soon because
your piece is already hanging the bishop
on F5 is under attack if you play G6
that probably gives white the time to
slide the H1 Rook over and trades
benefit the side with extra material and
here that's especially true the Knight
Still Remains offside and white has
these past pawns that black will not be
able to do it Sam needs to step up here
and try to make this complicated because
Robert this is getting out of hand
Bishop to H7 but that Knight on A6 is
still not playing the game and the
momentum is starting to mount if Nihao
wins this one that's a couple in a row
for him and all of a sudden he takes the
lead in this match right and now they're
a back ranked Checkmate possible because
the bishop takes away the king's Luft so
Rook E1 could be played here if you take
me oh free rook no no no Rook d8 is
check and mate on the back rank so I
think rookie one is nice Rook D1
followed by Rook d8 looks good enough
and the 996 I think is just trapped I
think that black might just lose that
piece and I'm gonna combine your two
ideas Robert I'm gonna go rookie one and
after Rook e to C8 then I'll go Rook D1
and now I'm threatening Checkmate
because of rook d8 and if I want Robert
I can even trade all the pieces he just
trades him he trades the Rooks on d8 and
this Knight on A6 can go back to B8 but
Rook E8 is the Checkmate thread yeah and
look at this rookie two com chess you
can just bring that Rook up here and
start trading pieces if you want and
nihal has over two minutes the clock has
been his best friend today yeah and I'm
looking at moves like even G4 here you
know there's ideas like Bishop going to
B7 for white I can see so many tactics
working out for Nihao here I I think
with the time time he's just gonna take
a moment try to find the trickiest
solution here because the bishop is
still Tethered to that Rook on C2
there's rookie eight there's G4 I I
think with everything hanging yeah he's
just chosen a great variation here this
is dead in the water for Sam's heavy
it's over the bishop is actually trapped
if you go to G6 H5 kicks into D3 and you
go Rook D5 and that Bishop is lost so he
goes Rook D2 but now you just go full on
Pac-Man take every single Pawn in the
position and Sam's Heaven might just
resign here and with that a player who
led by one point entering today he's
about to go down a point and I don't
know if he'll be able to come back from
it indeed I we're being spoiled right
now with the results so far in day two
Robert so many unpredictable results
some matches are starting to see
comebacks even if this goes the way we
expect he could overtake his opponent
and suddenly be in a leading position
unbelievable play by nihal son after
disappointing day one Rook D3 check and
again he spends time he's in a winning
position he knows it he has plenty of
time remaining on plug so that what is
the best Square for my king he goes up
to C4 back to B3 that's resignation and
that's a lead for nihal sarin now he has
overtaken sam7 who must be extremely
frustrated yep we follow Sam out of the
room there and what what a shot Robert a
guy who is leading early on suddenly
sees it relinquished and nihal sarin who
a lot of people favored coming into this
match has now shown them why he was
given that nod he's up three and a half
to two and a half but what a day he's
having two nothing so far Robert he's
blanking his opponent yeah really good
game and good day so far for nihal sarin
and as we see all four scores up for us
here Wesley so is the player who is
moving on so mon as you look across who
else will join Wesley yeah that's a
great Point not only is Wesley Moving on
but I'm actually thrilled that so many
of the other matches are still going
purely from an entertainment perspective
Robert we see Wesley moving on I think
he car Nakamura needs to pull it
together and I believe that he will join
him but you know at what cost how many
losses have to happen before he says you
know what let me just go back to that
day one chess and play that again
because all he needs is half a point
here will he be able to secure it I
think in the other matches of course
Anish giri he he did suffer a loss here
but they've been trading blows and he is
ahead so I still think Anish Geary can
pull it out but Nihao needs to be
stopped if you're Sam savian even a draw
at this point just something to get some
momentum back and stop the bleeding well
speaking of draws Wesley so Drew this
final game against Dimitri on draken to
allow himself through the semis but this
game was probably the most Wild game of
all true we left off around here and
Wesley showed tremendous restraint with
Rook a to B8 the tension remains he says
if you want to open things up my Rook is
going to be well placed and after the
next few moves Knight back to G3 Hayden
F5 it looks dicey for both sides if you
don't know how to evaluate this position
but Amman again Wesley just showing move
after move that he is here to win this
tournament yeah he's he's not missing a
beat that's the thing with Wesley so
with these strong players but especially
Wesley when you give him something he'll
he'll take it to the bank like in this
game right here it could have gone
either way but the way that he handles
these tense positions where you know
that eval bar is not really jumping in
either direction but you just always
feel that he has a plan and on draken
down on the clock as well I think that
was a big factor in this game and in
this match and look how this game
continued Knight F6 B6 here come the
pawns and after the swap Queen D7 F5 was
loose so Wesley said give me your best
here come White's pawns up the queen
side but F2 is a problem it's been a
problem for a long period of time and
after Knight C5 he went H5 now that's a
move I never even would have considered
the point is that you can start trading
on the H file but it's going to backfire
because after Bishop F5 I will gladly
start pinning you and winning on the HL
right away so H5 pushing Pawns in front
of his own King if Wesley's not just I'm
gonna be quiet and make a draw I'm gonna
be loud and show you that you can't beat
me exactly and when you're looking to
make a draw the advice that people
always hear is don't play for a draw
play for a win and then you know you'll
get a draw what is it aim for the moon
land on the Stars exactly and look at
this just that pawn went to B7 that
would scare most players but not Wesley
so he trades brings his King up to H6
after opening diagonal and then he plays
Bishop G6 calm move and once the pawn
started fall calling he gave up his Rook
on B8 but it was a draw by force so just
great foresight from Wesley so this
looks scary it would be winning if not
for the fact that the white king can't
escape the checks and that means it is a
draw exactly I mean basically at this
point earning that draw was all he
needed so he found a position where he
was actually threatening to do even more
than that and it was on draken who
simply didn't have better than allowing
that Perpetual check so nothing he could
do to get out of it if there was I'm
sure he would try it Robert but Wesley
just played a great game in a great
match bringing that down to a draw
position which is the result that he
needed yeah he deserves to be through
after surviving game one I think that
was really the turn of the match sounds
weird to say that game was a draw but
Wesley was completely lost in that game
yeah and to survive that honestly just
shows that you know the nerves you know
being on stage he also offered a draw
when he was in a worse position in
another game and I think those small
things those small victories Robert all
contributed to the overall result
well he's gonna have to use those
successes going forward but for now
we're going to take a quick break when
returned to Toronto more action from day
two of the cgc quarterfinals spots at
the table for the semifinals are still
at stake twitch subscribers hang tight
for some more exclusive content from
Toronto we'll be right back to Toronto
soon
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
how long have you been working out
because the way that you grab that King
and broke the top of it shows that you
have some Incredible strength Sam yeah
I've been working out for I think at
least the last eight years until right
now you see them you see them yeah
exactly right what scares you the most
anything like spiders bugs movies
[Music]
if anything it probably hurts them right
yeah really okay you get like a Friday
when you throw up or like is it like oh
man I can't just go up there no no no
when I'm like standing on a cliff
possibly before yeah that's actually
probably the same for me too don't do
the home chat what's the most of
interesting the skydiving back flipping
off your back porch or something sadly
no but I hope I do one day actually okay
favorite openings and why oh canvas yeah
yeah okay initiative really quickly yeah
this one's in particular I like Evans oh
Evans okay
congratulations on all your success Sam
and a good luck to you in the cgc thank
you
[Music]
one million dollar prize pool sorry I
was peeking should I do it again because
I was peeking I could just stand farther
I could just not like I could just do
this to continue one
I'm shouting again I feel like as the
day goes on you guys continue to
distance the mic more and more away for
me I feel like they might like notice a
pattern go and this is me without my
voice too
imagine if I was at full capacity break
the mic I dare you
you know historically in Third Ward you
would have more formal places for folks
to get together corner stores cafes but
you know through the history of the
neighborhood you've got a lot of
disinvestment over the years I mean
starting from the 1930s you had
redlining and so the area where the
chest parking was a formerly redlined
part of Houston and when they came and
built highways in the 1950s they you
know tore through sections of Third Ward
separating it from the rest of the city
and that just left huge swaths of the
neighborhood empty and vacant
we are going to transform this park into
an area where people can come enjoy
themselves feel safe and
play chess and checkers just kind of
doing things piece by piece
incrementally so kind of a tactical
urbanism approach we're not waiting on
the city to do any Grand project we're
just doing what we can do step by step
as private citizens and working together
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to Toronto and our coverage
of the cgc quarterfinals Hikaru and
janak shistoff are getting ready for
their game seven let's begin by
reviewing today's scores thus far we
have some fascinating matches one match
is already decided Wesley so has
defeated Dimitri on Drake in four and a
half one and a half he advances to the
next stage but the other three matches
are all in play none of them have been
decided we have plenty to watch and we
are going to watch it alongside my
partner my good friend International
Master Levy Rosman the one and the only
Levy welcome I'm super excited are you
excited as well dude I'm absolutely
flabbergasted at what's going on here
you told me at the beginning of the day
Wesley so would be the first person to
be done with a match I would not have
expected that the entire crowd here has
been electric waiting for this potential
comeback that we're seeing from Young
Crystal the other two matches as close
as can be with one side leading the hall
with the comeback decisive games abound
I'm so pumped me too but all the
conversation has been about hikaru's
match a shocking turn of events as we
review Hikaru nakamura's player card he
was leading 4-0 yesterday what a resume
what a path to the cgc finals Levy but
what a turn of events in these last two
games yeah I mean what more can you say
on that bong Cloud decision is looking
more absurd by the minute but we don't
have any more minutes remaining we are
just about ready for game number seven
I'm so fascinated to see what we're
going to get here from the opening stage
I mean that last game was smooth but
yeah it's just a what an end game we are
a silly in defense this is the first
time that he's played it in the match I
believe indeed and Hikaru responds with
an alopin which is a totally valid
choice we remind you that a draw wins
the match for Nakamura all he needs is a
draw and Levy the allopin is one of the
most solid ways to fight the Sicilian it
gets young shistov already thinking
there's D5 there's Knight F6 what is he
going to choose yeah by the way this
move order in particular is very
interesting because white normally plays
C3 in the second move so I guess Hikaru
was looking to force a draw in one of
the main lines like a knight or Sicilian
with D6 or E6 but he sees Knight C6 and
now he plays C3 so Black's best chance
here is probably to go D5 straight away
yeah I mean there's no Force draws in
the allopin but there are a lot of
positions that are very very hard to win
D5 generally leads to positions where
white has an isolated Queen Pawn we
could get that structure Knight F6 leads
to a completely different tenor nature
of the position and that is indeed what
the Polish Grandmaster chooses now we're
going to see either D4 or Bishop C4 yep
there's D4 by E car they're following
the main line left there's a line here
cdcd and then white plays this move
Knight C3 it's a really annoying line
for black and it kills the game and
okayhikaru chooses to play Bishop C4
that's absolutely a great move
yeah Bishop C4 played so he doesn't go
for Knight C3 he goes for the more
traditional main line and now the Knight
usually drops back to P6 but Levy if
they follow the main line after Knight
B6 Bishop B5 this leads to a position
that historically is really really hard
to win like really hard to win yeah
really hard to win and you play the
Sicilian Defense yourself you've played
it a lot of times in classical chess
I've never been that brave and you know
if somebody wants to really really
depress you and not give you any
opportunities to play for a win with
black it's by playing this you really
have to squeeze juice out of a fruit uh
about Duda doesn't look extremely happy
with the opening choice on the board but
uh he's the one that played the Sicilian
so yeah I mean we won't go too far down
the rabbit hole here we'll wait for
yonsha stuff to choose a line but the
reason he's thinking in almost any other
game he would take on E5 in this
scenario Levy he would take on E5 and
after Knight takes E5 he would go down
the main line which is dead equal but
right now he's thinking hey I have to
win what am I going to choose in order
to spice up the position is it D5 is it
E6 yeah
um so the bishop on B5 pinning the
knight uh and making it very tough for
black to figure out kind of what's next
okay easy there we go yeah very cagey by
the way I mean
this is this is very tough a move that
he would never love you'll co-sign me on
this he would never choose this in a
classical game you can see the eval bar
shooting up white is slightly better
here but at the very least black leaves
all of the pieces on the board yep yep
yep it's uh so does black want to
capture on E5 or does black want to keep
it closed with D6 to D5 at some point
and then but how do you develop it looks
like a really bad French defense well
you saw him in a French defense
I do mean a French defense you don't
need to put an unnecessary adjectives I
mean listen
who won with the French defense in this
match
how is it yeah two games ago yeah you
take C4 French that's like you know
hardly a friend it's like when you go to
Paris and hang out in your hotel room
the whole day exactly exactly you're
hardly a vacation in France but Hikaru
is currently thinking what is he
thinking about he's probably trying to
decide whether he wants to take on D6
and force an iqp position isolated Queen
Bot or does he want to keep the tension
in the center by castling I feel like
castling is more up he car's alley he
likes to keep the tension that would
toss the ball back to Yonk shustoff and
allow him as you said Levy to decide
between d e and D5 but no Bishop C1 to
G5 well by Nakamura trying to induce a
trade of dark squid Bishops what exactly
is so wrong about that move by the way
black wants to play for when can black
play F6 here
how bad is that move because you gotta
win okay please Queen C7 fine and again
notice young strategy this is so
fascinating uh Levy the fact that he's
refraining from moves he would normally
be playing Bishop E7 equal position he
wants to keep the pieces on the board
and now the other Bishop comes out I
like the way the Polish Grandmaster is
handling this opening he's getting an
interesting position he's getting an
interesting position I don't think that
we're going to be seeing any sort of
long Castles by the way first of all
because it's illegal right now but
second of all uh it's gonna be really
tough to Castle onto a C file where only
a knight and a queen blocked the king
there has to be a pawn somehow in the
way and I doubt we're gonna be seeing
that probably gonna be seeing H6 very
soon by black I agree he's gonna try to
chase this bishop away get his own
Bishop out in Castle kingside will
monitor this game as it transitions to
the middle game but right now we need to
monitor another fascinating match
between Anish giri and Timur rajabov and
Levy as we review rajabas player card
the 35 year old ozera Grandmaster puts
together a necessary win against Anish
he continues to impress he impressed at
the candidates and Levy he impresses
again with a clutch win in the last
round yeah to be honest he hasn't
impressed in the match until the last
game that's not to say that he hasn't
played well but Anish gear has played
fantastic chess and as we get ready for
game seven here we said this match was
gonna go seven or eight I mean it's
tough to go in any shorter than seven or
eight of course in this format but the
niche struck three and a half to one and
a half you think it's over because he's
been so great with white but it's more
sacked upon played a really aggressive
type of Catalan nimso Fusion last game
and what are we gonna get this game
how's Timor going to win with black yeah
and this is interesting because he
actually can ooh the French for the
second time
B6 what C6
oh this hey this is a crazy crazy line
to play this is just much better for
white I was sure he would Channel
yakshita but instead he plays B6 Levy
the only time I'm ever facing this I
think nihal played this against me in a
Blitz game a couple of weeks ago but
this is like such an obscure line Bishop
comes out to B7 yeah and the reason this
is so obscure is white can just play
natural development not the best move
according to computers Play Bishop B5
check first which is very funny to
induce a move by black like blocking
your own position because Knight to D7
would land you under severe pressure uh
which looks like of course let me show
that actually if I may Knight D7 looks
so natural after 95 I think blackened
resigned yeah yeah because Knight to F6
uh oh Knight to F6 you take it yeah and
then yeah yeah exactly let's not talk
about this exactly but that you're just
you're straight up just succumbing to
all the pressure there on the on the
attack on the king so Bishop B5 check
actually would be the meta move and he
didn't did it he did it he's smart you
know I always say don't give those
checks if they're not good but in this
case it is good black has to block the
light squared Bishop so Timur is going
out right here his strategy he was not
draw this game go win with white like I
just did this is a massive risk he did
not have to do this and he's taking more
risks Lobby look at this last name of
Knight F6 yank shistoff played this move
against zikara but when janak schistoff
played it after Knight takes F6 he could
recapture with the queen of course
teamwork can recounter on the corner of
not such a good idea because of Bishop
G5 this move didn't work in the Hikaru
game because the light squared Bishop
was unblocked here he has just taken
with the pawn wow what a crazy opening
choice for a teamwork I love it I love
it yeah I love it but at the same time
Timor is essentially saying uh like he
he's opening up the opportunity for a
niche to play all these moves and saying
oh I'm gonna take all these risks and
he's saying yeah but these these wrists
are bad yeah this position is bad for
you exactly the position's just
objectively not good now I've actually
played like this with black I've played
the D takes E4 French and I've put a
knight on F6 without any provocation I
take with the G Pawn but I'm playing
three minute games against 2600 rated
players on chess.com and I have a pretty
decent score because I just attack and
play fast and beat them on time in dead
lost positions that's not a possibility
here let me all I'm looking at is the
chat message by clever King 11 Roger is
good because of Levy's course finally
someone revealing the truth it took two
days about time yeah that well that
person doesn't quite understand that
that my course doesn't recommend that so
if that person has the course but
doesn't actually play it correctly on
move three that no refunds right that's
not my fault uh yeah this is not what
I'm recommending in my course this kind
of resembles the beer and variation of
the French where black is just
sacrificing all principles out the door
bad development weird Pawn structure but
it's like you still gonna beat me so
let's talk for a second conceptually why
is teamwork doing this somebody looks at
this for the first time they see the
terrible Pawn structure on the king side
the terrible structure on the queen side
they see the black thing is still in the
center White's about to play C4 put a
rook on E1 and Checkmate black on the
e-file what is the redeeming fact here
what are the redeeming elements of the
position 14 or well if you go back and
move right if you go back and move
computer is things plus 1.7 yes no no
before a shortcut before long Castle
short Castle is plus 1.7 mm-hmm but that
looks so counter-intuitive because why
would you Castle into the openg file yep
but now you go this way it's only plus
0.9 half the advantage is gone I guess
it's because the King on C1 is actually
a little bit flimsy the queen could go
to D5 the Knight could go to D5 and Levy
later on I'm talking three four moves
from now that a pawn could be sent down
the board and if it reaches A3 you're
invoking a big weakness on C3 and
there's a knight on D5 fully poised to
exploit that
this is actually not as one-sided as it
may appear at this has been some
incredible play for Timor yeah white had
to kind of Castle and say bring it
because black has to justify the play
but right now black is enough to justify
anything he's got the Knight on D5 he's
I think he's about to play A5 and he's
gonna oh can we be six same type of idea
and you would love to try to kick the
night out with the move C2 to C4 but
that just invites this and now hello on
the B file that King's looking mighty
uncomfortable this king's actually
tremendously safe and enjoying life I
mean and maybe it's time to make the
king not enjoy life with something like
G4 G5 just send the pawn up down the
board but maybe rajaba is making a play
on the fact that a move like G4 is not
really an Anisha style Anish likes the
slow gradual play Rook H E1 and you
can't really break through Black's Pawn
Mass with your pieces alone maybe some
sort of Bishop F5 Bishop takes C6 idea
but again very clear provocation type
play from timura job of here and this is
how you win a game with black yeah this
has been a great great start to this
game it's going to be tremendously
exciting but we cannot forget we have
another match with the exact same score
as we pull up uh nihal sarin and Sam
Savion there on the screen getting ready
for game seven that match has been
amazing okay four straight games uh of
fun stuff but the player card here for
nihal sarin uh well gold medal he's an
Olympic gold medalistanya I mean what
more can you ask for you I mean would be
nice if he had some other achievements I
mean such as number one on chess.com
Blitz rating over 3200 maybe that
defeating World Champions dingley Run
Newhall star runs pedigree precedes him
he's amazing and he has just come up
with two wins in a row Sam Sabian is
reeling he has the white pieces though
Levy that's the good news and he's very
very stable he's mature we've talked
about it he needs to put through a great
performance yeah but H6 on the board H6
is a sideline of the Queen's Gambit
decline variation and that is not
something that you play with black when
you are up a game in a match but he
doesn't care and he's going to play the
Knight to C6 I think this is the way
when you play this bishop D6 and Knight
B8 to C6 super counter-intuitive setup
but actually very very provocative by
now he's saying I'm going to put away
the match right now if I have a chance
yeah that's exactly what he's saying
Anish Geary by the way did play G4 I
need security to play G4 I mean what
aren't we seeing today yeah this is uh
wow I'm having so much fun here and Sam
Savion the one who's down to point seems
to be playing the tamest opening of all
as you said putting the pawn on E3
and how is he going to continue his
development he's already taking his time
does he find Bishop D6 that's surprising
that is he's just trying to play chess
and I understand that's what we've been
playing for the last couple of days but
when I say he's just trying to play
chess he's not looking for refutations
of openings no he's not and B6 by by
nihal sarin preparing to fianchetto his
his other Bishop puts it on B7 I really
like the setup personally for black
bishops are very harmonious he's got
good control of the center you're right
Sam seven just wants a position he wants
just a middle game a complicated middle
game and that's been a strategy the
entire match it's not like he's doing
anything systemically wrong he's just
gone out played two games in a row he's
not tilted or anything he's just gotten
beat yeah that's exactly right yesterday
if Savion had taken a 3-1 match he
probably would have not even been
playing anymore to be perfectly honest
with you because black would have had to
now would have had to take a risk at
some moment and that could have
backfired and Savion could have just won
and been a four and a half but because
he didn't win yesterday in game four
that momentum has completely shifted and
when you lose two games to start the day
it really doesn't get any worse unless
it's imagine Nakamura dudo which is just
it's just all over the place we're not
talking about what we about to our talk
about that match this position looks
pretty tame indeed let's go back to two
of our most entertaining matches we want
to look at Hikaru we want to look at
Anish giri because this hikara match I
honestly cannot believe that it's dude
four
I can't believe that it's due for a levy
yeah what is going on there there's a
king just standing in the corner of the
board on H1 I what is happening wait
Duda actually did lone castle that's
crazy wow yeah so so in that game on the
left-hand side of your screen everybody
when when I literally said there is no
chance that due to Castle's Queen side
and he did if you notice his King has
gone there the Knight and the queen do
block the King on C8 but he's marched
all the pawns up the board now
apparently it's still in the balance
which is somehow what how is it
that's that's so wild Let's uh let's
pull up the rajabov and Geary match a
little bit closer once again because it
does seem that a niche uh did begin an
attack with G4 and G5 yep and there's a
there's a king is gone so King's out of
the center uh so what happens now do you
take on F6 and try to move your knight
to the center of the board what do you
do there well I suppose I assume that
that was the idea of G5 obviously black
had already castled Queen set so the
idea of g45 isn't to like open up the
king it's not what it usually is it's
actually quite positional it is indeed
to carve out the E5 score for the Knight
so let's talk about what happens if
white just takes on F6 okay black takes
are the bishop right
and if white plays 95 level you can't
quite get away with it I think because
the queen captures on D4 suddenly you
have the battery now the engine is
showing that the game continues after F4
Knight takes F7 though I'm sure Anish
will go for this game but not continue
if Knight F7 happened yeah I mean
knowing any issue probably isn't capable
of seeing a line like this but you know
we'll give them benefit of the doubt
right
okay so the current position is after
Bishop E7 Anish deciding whether to take
on F6 or to make a move to keep the
tension such as Rook hg1 H4 the position
becoming more and more Rich yep will
Timur initiate that Queen side attack
with A5 is really my question this is
the second game in a row that Timor has
a massive time Advantage last game he
seemed to have played some sort of
Catalan nimso Fusion preparation this
time it just seems like he's doing
whatever he wants yeah I mean he just
doesn't get he's just getting a position
he's done a great job of it that Knight
on D5 is getting on my nerves so it must
be getting underneath giri's nerves and
the fact that you can never really go C4
you nailed it earlier this Knight is a
huge piece ift Moore wins this game I
mean the opening choice will have a lot
to do with it but I like the way their
Niche is handling he's not panicking
he's not doing anything drastic he's
just saying hey you want to keep the
tension I'll keep the tension I'll keep
improving my position show me what you
got he plays H4 the last time that a
niche was white and the game was an E4
E5 something very standard it still was
Timor trying to attack and in this game
by playing B4 by playing A5 by playing
E5 getting in over here that's the only
real way that Timor can win this game
unless I need to just blunder something
crazy and there we go there you go so
he's indicating that he understands the
plan but can white do like a full Uno
reverse and yeah King I want to just
start with C4 you know we said that you
can't play C4 when the king's on B1 oh
no reverse Black's not letting you and
her black is just going after you with
C5 I just want to rewind for a second
Levy and explain why King A1 was
necessary if you had played a nonchalant
move I believe that Knight C3 check
would have led to very nasty
consequences especially if you take that
Knight with a pawn after BC you simply
get mated and if you take with a bishop
then well after BC you have to make this
dreadfully weakening move leading to
Lobster pincer ideas so that was out of
the question Anish had to invest the
tempo for prophylaxis and that lets
Timor open up the queen side even
further what do you make of this
transformation I I really like it by by
black and Black's King is going to be
just incredibly safe over here on A8
white is not in any business of
attacking on that side of the board but
still there's like Rook C1 and various C
pawn put bushes although again they
weaken this and a niche with the time
ticking and almost getting to half of
the time of his opponent he's going to
be in a tough situation because he's
going to make these decisions where do I
weaken the position a little bit but is
it a correct weakening of my position
and that's I think the only weak spot in
the niche's game no I mean we are not
disputing this opening strategy has been
a success for two more and I just love
the way he's playing he's playing with
so much confidence King b80 is making
the right improving moves at the right
time we're praising Tim Moore's play a
lot but and the reason we're doing that
is it's just not easy to generate
winning Chances with the Black Faces but
Rook to G4 by a niche preparing to swing
The Rook over to C4 what an idea yeah
that is a fascinating idea I will say
after the move Rook C8 by black it is
the lowest evaluation of the entire game
thus far literally because computer
thinks French defense is 0.4 so from
that point move one yeah from move one
and this is the lowest point that it's
gotten so Timur has completely made it
back he's made it back by an entire
point of evaluation after the fourth
move B6 you know the Evo was something
like plus 1.2 so what a choice for Timur
he's got 11 45 on the clock plenty of
time to figure out how to continue
making improvements on the Queen's head
I like the move Rook C8 Levy Rook C4 is
not inherently scary the queen can drop
back to B6
and you could still consider pushing the
ape on forward the king Side Pawn mass
is still very very healthy yeah
absolutely is I love this position for
black it's so much fun to play your play
is so natural you just push everything
forward and white doesn't have that
luxury look at white making some sort of
rerouting a detour on the highway to get
somewhere you were because your exit was
closed this is uh strange I mean like I
always like to say a rook that ends up
on C4 is like a cow on the highway
you're like I don't understand how this
happened I don't know anything about
closed roads and closed exits
that's not no we just stand in traffic
the whole day right yell at each other
yeah but apparently again now Rook C4 is
Gonna Come and what's the Rook doing
there is it an asset or a liability I
don't know I'm not into taxes all right
so we we don't know not either I'm sadly
yeah anybody watching it exactly
somewhere down oh we are in Canada oh
that's true I don't have to send the
Auditors over but the position is
incredibly complex where Jabba has done
what he wanted to do out of 20 moves the
position has somewhat stabilized so
we'll keep a close eye as this game
proceeds I think we need to go back to
the Hikaru because crazy stuff has
happened there this is a must win for
Yamcha stuff Duda he's one two in a row
can he pull off the unimaginable and win
a third game in a row this ladies and
gentlemen is the position on the board
let me take it away a queen trade
offered he seemed to be very confident
in that pawn up end game we've seen a
lot lot of Pawn up end games in this
match and with Bishops left on the board
you guys eight nights okay I feel like
there's I've never seen a knight on the
board in some of these games Queen F7
yeah dude us up a pawn man he's just up
a pawns again you and your controversial
comments just Levy come on I know well
he can't play Queen B7 by the way that's
our repetition yeah he has to move his
king that's a problem though that's a
big problem because if you play the move
King D7 I mean just look at the
placement of this King now you could say
well I'm threatening Queen H5 Queen H2
Checkmate but all white needs to do is
make one prophylactic move slice off the
bishop and say you want to give me a
check you're more than welcome to do
that I'm just tucking my king on G1
Queen D7 is coming next Black's entire
King side is falling apart this is a
very very nasty position maybe black
could try something like F4 but my worry
Levy is that at best black is going to
get a Perpetual on the king side yeah
that ain't gonna cut it yoncho stuff
he's got no choice he can't repeat so
For Better or For Worse he has played
King D7
and the small noun hikaru's Court yeah
we might be seeing uh Hikaru advancing
the semi-finals here in just the next
couple of minutes because G3 is a real
cold shower and just to Echo your point
there's really not a whole lot of time
there you want to play H5 H4 open things
up that looks absolutely great problem
is white goes first right so white can
strike back with the move F4 white can
play the move Bishop G5 to cut that out
I can also at any moment play the move
Queen B7 but there are some cases where
you know it's maybe not not so simple
Hikaru King Jean yeah he just says I'm
doing a little I'm doing it alone I'm
moving my king away I love that move wow
but that's so I guess he didn't want
what we call a hook on G3 for one of
these two pawns to hit wow and the thing
is like black can still play out for
here this looks intimidating but it just
sends the bishop where it wants to go
anyway so White's gonna play Bishop C5
and now black is experiencing tremendous
logistical problems if you go rookie 6
already the check on B7 is incredibly
scary doesn't quite lead to Checkmate
King 88 Queen state is made black has
this move but after Bishop B6 black is
tied you know hand to foot on the queen
side you have to play Rook C8 and you
flip the switch at that point you're
just playing by defense bang B4 B5 open
up the C file you you nailed it black is
just too slow on the king side if you
add another three four moves you'd play
Queen Queen H5 G3 uh I don't see this
happening Duda has preemptively played
the move Rook to C8 by the way okay
let's go back to the live position so he
has defended his King against anything
incoming and it's
good move practically speaking yes and
the best move for Hikaru is the exactly
why are you even trying to play it why
you don't believe that Hikaru can play
them yeah Rook C7 is now prevented and
queen B7 will pry the king away and I
think Duda may have underestimated that
move yeah wow that's a talk about cold
showers how do you stop Queen V7 like
it's not like a car is trying to hide
his intentions gee I wonder why he
played Bishop B6 yeah you can't move the
king or The Rook it seems can't move the
king because you dropped the Rook can't
move the Rook because it doesn't help
with Queen B7 I think you have to move
the other one wow that's the best move
Bishop C7 that idea we talked about this
could be a transposition to the line we
were just analyzing Queen B7 check
Bishop C7 and then the B punches is sent
down the board
will have two moves exactly two until
his Queen side and his King is are torn
apart there's another idea there which
is that I was gonna say it's Rook fd1
you could have given the check first but
now Rook B8 stops Queen B7 and The Rook
is defended by the bishop also Rook be
it stops Rook takes D5 which is another
huge threat in this position you have to
move the C8 yes Rook D5 CD yeah and I
mean if if you're prompted with the
necessity of moving the rook and C8
you're gonna move to B8 can you move it
anywhere else Queen B7 hello god dude is
walking on a tightrope he's also Walking
the Tightrope on the clock he's got
three minutes and 40 seconds we will
keep you updated on whether he finds
Rook B but it is clear that
hikarnakamura has everything under
control now we need to go back to our
other game with a player with his back
against the wall Sam Sevin he has the
white pieces he has to deliver and is he
on the path to doing that I think he
very well might be Levy we see him
having established what's called a
Pillsbury Knight on E5 I liked nihal's
opening setup now I suddenly really like
the way Sam Sevin has managed to
position his pieces are you on board
with that I completely agree and his his
next move could declare very nasty
things going on and move his Knight to
H5 you get Knight H5 on the board you
trade your Queens in there you've gotten
rid of the one one of the key black
Defenders you're threatening Queen takes
F7 Devastation for the black position
there okay he doesn't agree with me he
likes the he likes the night Square all
right he likes the convention of horses
over there in the center of the board
Knight F5 is a beautiful move Bishop f8
is a is an ugly necessity but it defends
the position and uh Queen F3 now Queen
G3 all right the positions this is and
that's exactly the worst thing about
these positions you know there's some
positions you have to find a bunch of
accurate moves here these ideas have
been known since the dawn of Time Queen
F3 Queen G3 you could lift The Rook up
you could do the same thing with the
Rook but why would you do it with a rook
when you can do it with the queen let's
analyze the lip let's after Queen F3 I'm
gonna play Devil's Advocate let's
actually try to go G6
is there a knockout blow do you go Queen
G3 anyway yeah I was thinking stack on
G6 he's too early yeah well I made never
too early to sacrifice uh sacrifice and
then go Queen City what happened what
happened Queen G3 how do you defend the
position okay I'm gonna go King H7 oh I
mean I'm looking at Queen takes G6 but
it doesn't work yeah Knight D6 Knight H6
sacking at all I mean just breaking down
all the pawns right no you roused
Michael Tall from the grave wow he's
sitting right next to me I have to tell
you no those nights look good on E6 and
F6 they look great don't just really
they do no but they're like cars with
their engines they're gonna take the
queen on H5 yeah except you're gonna
take on H6 and then you're gonna lift
The Rook up to F3 The Rook on F3 is like
me at uh science project you know I'd
let my partners do all the work and then
I'd write the lab right up when the
experiment works oh so you're just a
terrible person that's basically what
I'm saying yes you didn't have to say it
that bluntly but you know yeah yeah and
listen group projects in college I feel
like that's that's a big learning
experience you know personality wise and
patience wise and
that Queen getting to G3 yes he's going
to G3 took the other freeway yes a lot
of car references today driving and do
we miss it I don't think so I flew here
I didn't drive here I didn't drive here
either it's a 12-hour drive from
Charlotte means it's probably 25 from
New York yeah Queen is going to G3 with
some uh seriously how do you stop this
yeah how do you stop Queen G3 Knight
takes H6 you can't move the king because
if you preemptively play King h8 right
now can we just show that you know for
fun we absolutely I don't want to get
mated on G7 okay we'll just hang your
Queen instead thank you 96 F7 and Knight
takes d8 and if you try to play
something like Knight to E4 to literally
control the G3 square there's a
mind-boggling Bishop takes the force
that's a shocking shocking move to just
you know get right yep now I think you
can throw in the move D5 to reopen the
dark Squad Bishop so you're kind of
darned if you do darn if you don't no
matter how you handle this with black
some other piece opens up nihal star and
I think tries the only thing that he can
realistically try to muddy the waters he
opens up the center he plays C takes D4
I think he senses that the danger is
coming and in a lot of these positions
by the way the best move is ignoring
what's going on Queen G3 who cares about
the C file who cares about the D4 upon
leave all of that alone there's nothing
going on there is what you're saying
Queen G3 just threatens literally mating
too look at the evil bar I I do see it
you know the position is bad when you're
up one point of material and it's six
points the other way yeah that's a bad
thing no does Mark literally have no
moves after Queen G3 no if you go G6
Knight takes G6 no it ends the game
Queen G3 is the house that's on fire we
get a kick out a window and hope there's
a mattress at the bottom I mean queen G3
G6 a G5 I don't know something but Queen
G3 is a Checkmate in two Knight H6
Knight ef7 is game over so it's so
vicious this is unbelievable and you can
even just come back and take on D4 look
at these Bishops look at them Snappers
this is why we we like the young guys in
the event because they're gonna come to
fight it's a shame we didn't put them on
to someone else they were making them
beef against each other now again
savion's in a unique situation obviously
he's uh lost in the rounds of 16 and
he's and he's back and he's played Queen
G3 this is insane this is gonna go eight
games and he has plenty of time he's six
minutes on the clock I unless we see the
craziest Miracle of all I agree with you
the only reason he has six minutes by
the way is because he's a little nervous
that's it because he senses that this is
it I'm gonna get back in the match dead
even it all comes down to that game
eight you get a little I'm so excited
we're gonna get a game I know and in the
match that like we absolutely expected
we called that and Nicole looked like he
was running away with it three games
drawing the Lost position with two wins
and here we go right I mean Sam seven
I'm just impressed by how level-headed
he is I'm impressed by how mature he is
and this opening Choice he didn't do
anything crazy
he played 1d4 he said I'm gonna avoid
the theory I'm just gonna get a position
and I'm going to adhere to my pre-match
strategy just to get complicated middle
games and try to outplay my opponent
this time it has succeeded nehal we see
him on camera there intensely
concentrating trying to find some way to
defend this position this is completely
lost you see that he literally just
shook his head I mean nothing exists
when I take stage six is coming G5 there
is still the top move we don't have to
talk about it there was literally no
move no this is this is losing I think
nihal is gonna probably try to play on
for a couple more moves at least so I
think we'll take this opportunity to
check in on some of the other games but
we will keep you posted on this attack
as it unfolds objectively the game over
yeah that image of Savion with with the
holiday it's like if something from a
Black Mirror episode you know like you
go on a date with just like a virtual
screen and it's necessary no I know I'm
not it's not a criticism it's just funny
all right it's just funny that they're
playing a human against the screen you
know yep no and this is these are the
two remaining games we see Power on the
right Nakamura on the left and I think
Jan shustoff's time in Toronto might be
coming to an end unless I'm
misperceiving this position yeah two
wins though I mean let's put it this way
right he he knows he has to fight on
he's down material but uh
this look it looks to be over the only
reason he's down with zero by the way
because he couldn't make a draw yeah
let's exactly in a classical game he
would have taken like the five
opportunities he had to make a drawn
That's The Power of a draw winning you
the match you get to play in ways that
you normally wouldn't play listen kudos
to Young chistoph for his performance
today but Levy this makes it all the
more painful that he played the Bonk
loud yesterday you were talking about
this in the break yep he played a normal
opening even if he had made a draw this
game ends in a draw the match ain't over
yeah and imagine somehow he didn't get
blown off the board before he actually
won the game it's a tight match yeah he
had those pieces of course Hikaru would
have been on higher alert right like
it's a little bit different or nothing
you relax a little bit but uh yeah
that's uh I hope he didn't book any
plane tickets let's put it this way if
we didn't say okay this game over and uh
yeah no this is but this is game over
he's up in exchange he's got two
uncontested queen side pawns the attack
has fizzled out look at how just how
clinically Hikaru is converting this G3
I'm not even giving you a chance to push
your F Bond and if he garu wants he can
play Queen to trade Queens but that's
not how these top guys converted
advantages they don't do it from a
position of weakness they do it from a
position of strength I think we're going
to see Queen C8 by Nakamura in order to
be able to infiltrate the sixth rank
with one of his Rooks yeah Queen CA
Queen d8 not Queen E8 I agree uh you
couldn't even probably go back to yeah
that was just about to say that and
just play Rook C7 on the next move this
is all but over yeah Rook cd1 here I
think is the surgical move forced the
bishop off the diagonal open up the D
file we are watching the Polish
Grandmaster carry out his last couple of
moves in the cgc I'm very impressed by
the way he handled himself in the last
two games but going down 4-0 against
mura it's not possible it's not humanly
possible to make this comeback today his
games he played like a man who had
nothing to lose you just kind of wish
that he did that yesterday why didn't he
do that before he got the sleeves at
rest and then recovery and yeah it's a
bummer it's a bummer he's going to be
kicking himself but maybe he just always
kind of thought after games one and two
that that was it and his last 10 seconds
here will he make a move will he call it
a a day or an afternoon he might try
yeah Bishop C okay but Rook takes D5 and
I think he's gonna go Rook B4 hoping
that Hikaru doesn't see the lateral
attack on the queen and after Queen C7 I
think he's gonna resign I'm calling it
Queen C7 resigns no and maybe a couple
more moves Bishops
are off yeah that's just put the period
on okay okay does Hikaru see the attack
on his pieces oh he's thinking I think
Hikaru was like waiting for him to
resign yeah I'm kind of studying
hikara's facial expression like why did
he play this move rather than resigning
yeah King back to G1 Queen B6 check and
queen E3 yep King H1 is mate in 12 which
all of chat saw how like oh Hikaru
misses the maidens this is the maiden
12. he offers a queen trade instead
unacceptable unbelievable and that's
that's it that's all she wrote we see
Hikaru there headphones out little sigh
of relief if handshake beautiful stuff
there the matches over there there were
some criticism yesterday like dude
didn't shake his hands because the match
was not over it's because they have to
play many games against each other
Hikaru confident but probably relieved
and a bit annoyed a mix of emotions for
him yeah he's he holds himself to the
highest of high standards we see the
final score it is five to two it was a
4-0 lead after game one yanchised off
coming back putting up two points but
Hikaru he's a buzz saw and he played a
nice professional solid game winning
this match and advancing to the next
round yep uh Hikaru by the way and Duda
played Seven decisive games they really
did not like one another they just
showed up and they were scrapping we see
them there on the screen they were yeah
now of course that was necessity because
Hikaru was a four nothing lead right but
uh yeah we see Hikaru getting up there
and now we have on the display in front
of us the last two remaining games you
have Timur on each giri on the left with
rajaba down a point and you have nihal
up a point but losing his game
consternation space can we pop into that
Geary Gabriel seconds on the clock and
he's losing on the board he's losing on
the board look at her job response he is
down in exchange if Timor brings his
Bishop back to B7 he will be threatening
a back rank mate levy on C1 holy smokes
oh my land complete turn around here and
very simple just trade the Queens off
that H Pawn for White's not going
anywhere he's got two Rooks the other
guy's got one I wouldn't be so confident
though H6 H7 are both defended squares
after you trade Queen's Levy how does
black proceed does he try to play F4 and
get to this F2 Pawn with his Rook oh F4
so nice but F4 also if Queen E3 Bishop
E3 F4 yeah and then Rook takes F2 and
the back rank for white is so weak I'll
show this line because Timur has time we
presume that he'll think Queen takes E3
if you play fe3 you slice off the bishop
he just make his game over and and you
get made it on C1 so you have to take
with the bishop and now we're talking
about this move F5 f4y because after
Bishop F4 Levy you were giving this line
Rook F2 Bishop B5 and now Rook F5 I
think and just these minor pieces are
not self-sufficient you move piece to
one square here comes the other Rook
there is no way Gary is surviving an end
game like this with six seconds if two
more trades queens and finds that four
that's he might have just won another
game oh my God unbelievable three and a
half did find it yep three and a half
three and a half we're looking at and
despite in this this one's totally
different than the how one because he
was down two games he was down two games
and oh my goodness and and look at that
opening Choice bites him where we were
praising it all he needs is a couple
more accurate moves that's what stands
between him and a tied match at three
and a half what a match he was dominated
for five games and again it's a it's a
necessity of the moment right so he
takes certain risks in certain games and
they backfire Anish giri was Habib
nurmaga medaving which is a which is a
verb now Timor he was just all over him
and these two games Timor has made it
look like he was the one up the whole
time they're about to be in a tied
manner not to be the party pooper this
game isn't over Bishop takes H5 but wait
a second after Rook F5 TK Bishop D6 oh
no oh he's gonna take on B4
what a teamwork just do why did he allow
this yeah what is it he was a four
minutes I was hyping it up for a side
match Rook G5 but just repeat this is a
draw it's like Matt's not over though
yeah it's not over it's not over it's
not over imagine it's not over no but it
is over I mean this is a fortress no no
but the match is not over there rookie
oh I'm gonna jump out of my chair oh my
gosh
oh my gosh Anish giri
that is devastating devastating it that
might be the most devastating defeat of
this entire event for anybody that
roller coaster of emotions all he had to
do was do nothing keep the Rook on the
first drink Timur has no way to make
progress none get his King to B3 it
doesn't help oh my gosh three and a half
three and a half is the match we're
going to a game eight in the worst
possible way you can lose two games to
lose a game like that is devastating I'm
I really don't know what to say that was
insane we're seeing Timur rajaba of the
hero of that game on camera he did
everything he had to do to win messed it
up with a shocking oversight forgetting
that the B4 Pawn can be captured with a
fortress and then Anish giri blunders
the bishop oh my lands ladies and
gentlemen what a game eight we are in
for yep now we've got the last game of
the round remaining Savion versus I am I
am I'm still what both Queens are
hanging this is exactly what we need in
order to calm down a position where both
Queens are hanging yeah and another tied
match I think move the queen out of the
way Queen G4 game over yeah Queen G4
yeah but time is even again Savion good
for him that he has yeah that's also
winning
um you know when the best movies nothing
it's probably yeah and it's very
important that Bishop takes F5 you would
then take the queen correct so Queen C7
and think Queen H5 with just a couple
more moves required I mean I have seen
the hall pull out the craziest comeback
so at this point it's literally never
over and that's not a cliche anymore we
just saw that in action yeah in the Gary
rajabov game yeah exactly Knight takes
H6 is probably winning because you have
some Rook F6 after Queen goes to C6 but
yep uh Savion needs to avoid having 30
seconds on the clock this is a disaster
of a position to have with no time you
know why brain goes full crazy mode and
goes oh darling right now and you just
break through and then you hang
something and you that's it if if Savion
loses it's not a Geary loss you don't
play game mate you put you book your
tickets home no this is this is
literally a must and I mean Knight takes
H6 Bishop takes H6 let me just make
these moves on the okay never mind he's
played Queen takes H5 in H5 let's see if
he uh can chill out a little bit well I
mean listen you can move the bishop away
from C2 but that isn't quite as
satisfying let's Nino eliminate the 9
out of five he's gonna I think he's
gonna play Bishop D3 the alternative is
just to play H4 I don't know if you have
the if you have the guts and the nerves
here to play the move H4 just give the
bishop away
and just look for like various HG stuff
but your ideal Levy I think is after H4
Queen takes C2 and I'm not making these
moves just because I want to wait Knight
takes H6 my idea was to take the Knight
but then you hang the Knight on F5 so
apparently Knight H6 there is the
winning you were just testing my tactics
but H4 Queen C2 and then Knight H6 I
mean that's not that's not human like I
mean
but the human move here is to move the
bishop and if you move the bishop and
the hall eliminates the Knight and guess
what to add insult to injury he brings
his dark squirt Bishop to G7 he offers
the trade of Bishops and let's not
forget about the psychology will Savion
be still winning after that absolutely
but he'll have a minute the win will be
harder than ever yep and you know your
throat starts to close up in those
moments how am I screwing this up those
negative thoughts enter your mind we've
all been there regardless of our rating
everybody in the chat can relate to that
yep and I say they're young guys but
savion's 21. all right the more you the
east 21 the hell is 16 that's five years
that's five years of potentially
building up the ability to have negative
thoughts and he's down to Energy bill
he's H4 all of that and then Here Comes
Knight takes H6 surely
don't call me Shirley HG is tempting
Until you realize that after all things
finished up what
oh my gosh he thinks that he's still
winning he thinks that he had to play
Knight takes H6 there he had made on G7
and h8 and queen I think Levy that he
thought he had Queen E5 threatening made
on h8 the queen from C2 drops back to H7
and here's the thing if you lift your
Rook up to F3 the bishop steps into D6
and guards sarin do this to people Sam
Sabian might actually lose this game
he's down to 38 seconds the evil bar is
showing equality all white can do here
is a draw and and now he's down to that
30 second Mark you see the handling his
head he's probably thinking what are you
guys these are some of those
unbelievable 10 minutes I've ever seen
in any kind of Chess yeah and I couldn't
be happier spending it with you ah there
you go you inject injected so much
wholesomeness into that moment now I
told you savion's got to avoid this
situation does he know does he have to
flip that switch he has to think there's
a draw and I gotta find it and let's not
forget a draw does not lose in the match
again with four points you do not
Advance you need four and a half he's
played Queen E5 Queen H7 is going to
follow yep the only move there's also
Queen takes you two sacking the queen
but I don't think we're gonna get that
so after Queen H7 he's going to go Rook
F3 threatening Rook G3 you don't have
this bishop D6 move and what you can do
is move the bishop out to E7 and vacate
vacate the Escape Square for the king 10
seconds so Savage Rook f37 is down to
seven seconds because he doesn't see a
win he's played Rook F3 now nihal I
think is going to move this bishop away
from f8 this is absolutely insane just
don't take on H6 here because after Rook
G3 King f8 you are letting the queen
drop into D6 yep you're met right there
trying to escape no so the bishop has to
stay on actually any move on this
diagonal even Bishop A3 except Bishop D6
except Bishop D6 don't play quiet no
good point is is a draw it's a draw and
he's got two and a half minutes and he's
not rushing there's no need to rush zero
your opponent has nine seconds by the
way I would normally see the situation
in Reverse Right In Reverse we would see
the house nine seconds and we would
still expect him to play the best move
he's gonna come up with something he's
deciding where to put the bishop
probably he'll put it on B4 but A3 is
also completely fine this is about as
nervous as New Hall getsman that display
of anxiety just like you know fiddling
with his lip yeah that's about as
nervous as nehal gets they're both lip
twiddlers by the way another one is
biting nails or you know like twirling
their hair they both kind of like have
the hands here no I mean it's true it's
an extremely nerve-wracking moment and
Savion has just he's he's thrown it away
in this game but it's still not over we
just saw that the problem in this game
is where is it not over where is the
Hell's Channel well the question yeah is
deciding where to put his Bishop he
doesn't know that all these moves lead
to the same result obviously he's trying
to discern tease out the difference
between them after Bishop E7 The Rook
comes into G3 gives a check the king
moves on to f8 if you want you can
actually trade queens and I think
deliver a Perpetual in that resulting
position Savion probably see this maybe
nehal is thinking whether he can play
for a win here
I think he's got to leave himself with
at least a minute though does Savion
know that he has to make a draw because
that is so frustrating and I don't know
if you can all this time nihal is
thinking Savion might be talking himself
into it by the way someone might just
make the draw but if they play quickly
Savion might have not done that because
his time is thinking he's just gonna
play moves he thinks he has to win you
don't know what the evaluation is
remember they don't have that we do we
have the luxury of saying oh he's messed
it up Savion might also know that but he
might also not know that he might still
think he's winning he's played Bishop G4
has me all that is good actually that's
probably good enough Bishop G7 was a
move there yep oh there might just be
Perpetual here probably Perpetual check
but with 10 seconds it is a three result
game I mean I don't know if I'm too
convinced with this a defensive approach
Black's King remains kind of weak black
remains on the defensive nihal could
snap the pawn off Levy or he could hunt
for White's King with Queen G6 check I
have a feeling we're gonna be here for
another 100 moves entirely possible is
Queen G6 just a Perpetual though because
if the King goes to Queen C2 Queen C2
yeah that's what I'm saying just you're
absolutely right King is stuck Queen G6
Queen G6 if the King goes forward yeah
that's it it's just the draw no Savion
is not going to press his luck any
further
yeah there was a moment there that
nihal could have decided to keep the
game going but I think he's just gonna
well he can play Queen B1 Queen A2 but
then the king runs to the other
direction yeah that would be the best
way to to lose Queen A2 King G3 and then
H7 dislodges the king from the bishop
okay a draw a draw by repetition Sam
Savion breathes and he can't believe it
yeah he can't believe it he knows that
he's got one more game and that was the
best chance that he had of the entire
map and that's what's going through his
mind how does this person do it again
and again or maybe he's replacing person
with something a little bit more yeah
colorful colorful but the upshot the
upshot is that nihalt maintains his one
point lead he leads the match four to
three it is now a must win for sam7 an
official must win a draw does not
satisfy him anymore the Indian
Grandmaster The Prodigy he is a magician
he is the Harry Houdini of chess
is the is the light version of Hikaru
and and he's he's getting to the be the
version defensively we've seen him pull
off incredible comebacks his entire
career and he's pulled off two in this
match that have saved him one and a half
points no this was amazing and just the
concentration the focus that nihal puts
into every game we don't talk about that
a lot
it's just amazing but let's review our
scores after this ridiculous epic round
Wesley so he already clinched the
victory in the previous round he is
through hikaradakamura he stems what was
a miraculous comeback attempt by JKD he
wins the match as well Anish giri and
timuro but we'll talk about that game in
a second yeah Levy and Sam Savion fails
to convert the advantage Levy which
match really stood out to you here well
I mean it it's like you said that that
final moment between giri and rajab of
that entire game was just absolutely
Bonkers right like we we had a game
where uh guy uh plays a completely
offbeat opening easily the mo well then
draken definitely gave uh offbeat
openings a run for the for their money
in the event but uh what a game by
rajava what a two games by rajaba okay
we need to need an instant replay of the
blow by blow that we saw in Gary or job
now Levy we could talk about the first
part of this game and it was a textbook
textbook positional tactical effort by
Timor he wins The Exchange he gets a
winning position Gary has 10 seconds
Timor has five minutes he does
everything right the craziness starts
here after Bishop E5 yep when Tim Moore
initiates a tactic that should have
ruined everything yeah I mean he he he
plays this uh his next few moves Bishop
F3 Rook G1 and sacrifices which that's
not a blunder he doesn't blunder the
bishop yeah that's not the mistake part
of it his whole idea was to win back
material but what he completely just
failed to realize is he wins back the
material and the game is a dry medium
yeah because the G4 Pawn is the heart of
Black's position this allows white to
set up just the most watertight Fortress
of all time everything is protected yep
the bishop is now protected and all
Anish giri had to do was Chill on the
first string yeah
and here's the thing Lobby that occurred
to me you get this position anytime
teamwork goes King C4 you actually can
allow King B3 but the easiest is to go
Rook D4 yes because King B3 is a great
way to lose it's a great way to go home
immediately right there is no way the
Timur circumvents this if he moves his
own Rook away then you can move your
king up to A2 now you can do this
because Rook C3 doesn't work anymore
there are no chances this isn't like oh
it's a positional draw you have to find
something this is agree to a draw peace
treaty you're up a point I mean I get I
get it it's it's really hard five
seconds on the clock I think Rook before
oh yeah preemptively just attacking and
just blundering check and take on C3
it's just unbelievable unbelievable that
is what nerves do to you ladies and
gentlemen and we are sympathetic to a
niche we're not sitting there there's a
reason for that it's incredibly hard to
keep her composure but as commentators
you know we have to highlight the insane
Insanity of the moment we had a lot of
insane moments in this round how many
insane moments are we gonna have in the
next round no idea so we've had so many
fascinating story lines the Dimitri and
Drake and Wesley soga match got started
with some total total total chaos but
Wesley so ultimately wins then Hikaru
right to scare two games lost this dude
are gonna make this comeback what was
that bong Cloud decision but Hikaru
pulls it out in the end now we got two
matches that are so close and we get
game mates let's go Levy that was
amazing we will head to a break but
before we head to a break a reminder
that the women's candidates has kicked
off and we have already reached the
semi-finals for pool a late J versus
Anna music who will make it through to
the finals and one step closer to the
coveted seat across from reigning
Champion juwen June and the 2023 Women's
World Championship do not miss a thing
ladies and gentlemen game three is
tomorrow right here at twitch.tv chess
what you're currently tuned into Type X
Glam women's candidates exclam women's
candidates in the chat for all of the
details and folks we are going to take a
quick break when we return will inch
closer to punching our final ticket to
the semifinals at the cgc the final game
will get underway we have plenty a fresh
subscriber content during the break so
if you subscribe do not go anywhere
we'll be right back here from Toronto
foreign
[Music]
obviously after playing in Iceland and
doing well I'm just looking forward to
the CG scene hopefully I can win this
one too
so nice to have you here in Toronto are
you excited for the cgc yeah it's um I
was here a couple weeks ago in Toronto
filming some other stuff so it's good to
be back where would you personally rank
rapid chess a mom's Pro chess formats
for me rapid is I would say right now is
close to my favorite or uh or it's Blitz
one of the two Raptor Blitz but
definitely not classical I also think
that with less time more blunders occur
so that's why rapid I think is a truer
test of of your overall skill ability
Blitz will always be my favorite if
there if there's nothing on the line how
is preparing for a rapid tournament like
cgc different from preparing for a large
over-the-board tournaments is there a
difference what's your process like um I
don't think it's much different
classical chess it has to be quite a bit
deeper you have to do look at many
different lines many different
possibilities and Rapid generally I
think if you have an idea and you look
at a couple of lines before the game
that's for the most part good enough I
found I was going to ask you what are
your own internal expectations for
competing this week as I said I'm just
going to try to play my game and if it's
good enough it's good enough if it's not
it's not but I don't really think about
anything else I love that answer just
playing the chess that's great
[Music]
Canada officially has it all Andrea a
True Canadian time to Sing the anthem uh
Oh Canada
[Applause]
[Music]
the best line of the Canadian anthem is
the first line and I'm not the only
Canadian who doesn't know the recipe
where exactly the only line
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
it's it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest muscles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
foreign
yes my sister was born in Vancouver but
as wonderful as Andrea and Vancouver are
it's pretty tough not to fall in love
with the city of Toronto
natural beauty abounds inside Toronto
and pretty close by
largest city in Canada the people here
have been playing chess and clubs in
universities and in public parks for
well over a century remember when
amaranth played chess in the hot tub
and now this wonderful place plays host
to the very first chess.com Global
championship finals
facing elimination for weeks eight of
the world's best players have survived
to continue their quest for the
queen-size share of the one million
dollar prize pool go get a garbage face
the car was like really wait what is
going on is he playing a fun club I'm
speechless
my friends you're in the right place
it's time for the cgc finals Toronto
Canada officially has it all
we agree we love Toronto welcome back
everyone Wesley so and Hikaru Nakamura
are through to the semi-finals but there
are still two matches remaining at the
quarterfinals of the chess.com Global
Championship as we bring you back here
inside the gameplay haul I am now joined
by Grand Master Robert Hess feed a
master James Canty and Grand Master
Amman Hamilton we have we've had so much
happen today we need to recap where we
sit on the scoreboard for everyone who
who may have been missing it but uh
two players have punched their ticket to
the semi-finals Wesley so and Hikaru
Nakamura I have five to two four and a
half one and a half respectively Geary
and rajaba are deadlocked will we have
Armageddon and then Sam stevian is now
in must win territory going into the
eighth game versus Nihao sorry we're
going to talk of course about these
matches coming up guys but let's talk
real quickly about our two players who
punched their tickets
who was more impressive in their round
obviously it started as hecaro but now
that we're here who was the more
dominant player moving on to the
semifinals between the two Americans
yeah interestingly I think since game
one of that match which Wesley so should
have lost I thought he was absolutely
dumb and he withstood all the pressure
that he faced I think in the end game he
was showed Exquisite technique so Hikaru
maybe there's some recency bias against
him but I do think Wesley was a
Powerhouse in that match yeah yeah
that's a great Point Robert I actually
Danny thought that NACA was cruising
right 4-0 it looked like nothing could
stop him and all of a sudden JKD pulled
out these two wins where you start you
stop actually and say wait a minute it's
like Unthinkable gonna happen is this
gonna be the 4-4 most insane comeback
maybe of all time but no Hikaru just
sort of calmed down went back to himself
and you know he took care of business
well he was nervous too he was visibly
you could see his car I mean he was he
was he was rattled maybe I jinxed him at
the start of the day by saying how well
he was playing
commentators curse is real yeah exactly
any commentators Chris is real well
Robert said that too he was like yeah
Danny you said it it was Danny and he
pulled him up grabbed him by his shirt
he said you did it and I was like dang
man that's crazy that's what happens
when you talk to you exactly exactly
right so it was really crazy with that
but uh Hikaru never seen he's very rare
that you see Carl get hit with a
two-piece spicy like that right real
quick
got hit real fast and then he bounced
back like he should right so I don't
think he was still the most what are
your thoughts about how Wesley so has
played now absolutely funny in fact
after the first game him uh suited
losing that game in another one too but
I mean he kind of stabilized and I think
actor he had to like warm up once you
warm up I think he's pretty warmed up
especially going into these these next
matches should do well yeah your
thoughts on so real quick really just
exceptional performance he gets to play
Hikaru so that's gonna be the reward
yeah he said to be spicy there that's I
don't even know who to choose there yep
I mean so after after that game which
again we know Wesley would be hard on
himself than anybody that he missed a
mating too but really he was super
dominant in that match with on Drake and
a guy that is that is not an easy beat
person to beat so your thoughts also on
Wesley joining Hikaru well Danny I also
called ondrakin I'm not trying to admit
that either I thought that on draken
would pose some problems for Wesley and
you know to an extent I was kind of
right at the beginning but Wesley is
just so slippery he just doesn't go down
he's able to Bob and weave he even
offered a draw early on kind of a
tactical draw offer he got out of his
bad positions but his good positions his
slightly better positions he always
seemed to win them so he's getting full
points out of half points and he's
getting half points when they could be
zeros yeah absolutely I mean Wesley has
always been uh of course we know him as
a forced to be working with he's a U.S
Champion how many times now Robert you
know do we have that many I mean you
know from Wesley winning once U.S champ
uh
19. I think he went twice yeah he's won
twice yeah twice of course I mean just
being as strong as he is playing against
these players bro it's like you knew
this was going to happen right you know
so and then um who does he face next he
covered right yeah that's a second
that's not fun you know what I mean I
win yesterday
for the first time Wesley will actually
be playing someone in Toronto yeah
that's true it's face to face Wesley's
clock Mansion was also very impressive I
think we'd like to think about how
precise he is his accuracy is through
the roof he we know he's one of the most
precise players of all time yeah but the
speed with which he played today that
end game against andrekin where he's up
one Pawn his Pawn structure wasn't great
yeah he was up a couple minutes on the
clock so he kept that pressure as well
and that allowed him to succeed yeah
well it'd be interesting to see what
happens in that matchup picaro versus so
they played each other many times
definitely rivals in the U.S and what
will they have for us in the semi-finals
of the cgc we're going to find out but
after his win Wesley did catch up with
Nemo and let's take a look at uh at what
he had to say
congratulations Wesley on winning your
match and advancing to the semifinals
how do you feel after your games today
I'm very happy and very relieved because
I think the quality of my games except
maybe the first game has been relatively
high for my standards like I'm playing
much better than I expected to to be
because I just came from third
tournaments that didn't go so well so
maybe third time's the charm yeah maybe
maybe the third tournament is the lucky
three yeah I mean there's a lot of
potential for you in this in this
tournament
um in your round five game today against
andreakin after you play Bishop takes E3
were you nervous at all what were your
thoughts after that move Bishop takes oh
yeah Bishop takes E3 well I thought it
was quite desperate at that point I mean
I wasn't nervous because I had many
pieces defending my king and uh
uh at the same time it feels like a
desperation sacrifice like I didn't see
a way to win for me although the
computer showed it after a game but on
the worst case I thought I could just
castle kingside and then try to play it
safe but I also found this Rook D1 Queen
F4 which is not the best idea by far but
it trades queens and I thought I could
win this Pawn on a chicks
and that was good enough for me but uh
uh yeah the opening that he played was
interesting but I think he knew it very
well I'm not sure if he played it before
on this one fact like Magnus Carlton
plays this but if interesting yeah and
actually speaking of openings how did
you feel after Andre can open with move
one B4 also known as the orangutan or
the Polish opening whatever you want to
call it how do you feel about that yeah
it's fun uh it's a better opening than
the bomb cloud
but uh at that point he was down three
points uh in the match
I
I mean the meter is a very strong player
he's one of the best Russian players
around but this match didn't go well for
him at any stage like he should have won
game one for sure huh like I feel so bad
that he didn't win the first game for
instance like he truly deserved that
after I blundered the opening and the
oh so he wasn't putting too much
pressure on me in the opening which
which is always good yeah and honestly
you're so nice
um thank you thanks so much Wesley and
congratulations once again on moving to
the finals
I agree with Nemo he is he is the nicest
interview in chess you can see he
genuinely feels bad uh when he says that
he felt bad about winning that first
game versus on Dragon but okay Hikaru
Nakamura will be waiting for Wesley so
in the semi-final we see the battle of
the two Americans uh they they have a
lot of history and there's so much to
talk about in that matchup we will of
course be unpacking it later but but
right now we still have two matches
ahead of us guys two more people will be
joining them in the semi-final will it
be Geary over job off Sauron over seven
or vice versa uh let's let's go back to
the uh the top one there we saw Anish
losing a super tough game
a game that uh he he could have drawn
right and uh it got away from him so I I
Robert your thoughts on what Gary needs
to do emotionally mentally to kind of
gather himself given that he's the one
now that they're tied who blew the lead
yeah the problem is he's lost two games
in a row and that gets in your head but
the same time that second game there
that lost it was a mishap at the end he
was fighting I mean he was in time
trouble his position was bad and then he
secured what would have been a draw if
not for that one specific blunder so
anisha's repertoire is super solid so in
order to survive with the black pieces I
think he has that under control and you
can't jump ahead to Armageddon bidding
process and things like that but I do
believe that he is as well prepared as
he gets and so he can right the ship
here in the eighth and final game of the
match but regardless of preparation
among when you're when you're mentally
the guy who was leading and now it feels
like you're losing even though the
scoreboard's tied right how do top
players not let themselves go into that
kind of dark place and just stay present
in the moment well Danny I think that's
why they are top players honestly
because I could say like I wouldn't be
as objective and you have to be
objective in chess you can't let the
emotions dictate the match you can't let
your emotions dictate your moves you
always have to think about what's in
front of you and what's in front of it
is a tied match honestly he's got his
chances just as much as her job off he
just needs to stop the momentum you just
don't want to let that train keep going
from her job off all right well Kenny
you know where I'm going with you you've
been you've been asked to be his coach
all all day since you guys got to
Toronto what are you telling your boy
Sam Sabian in a must-win situation he
has to win and force Armageddon or he's
going home man we got to go all out we
came very far right we only lost to
LeBron we not losing this time right
that's it we're going to do what we got
to do right and he gotta first then
first things first you got to calm down
you got to stay calm collect yourself I
have to win this game okay and you got
to play chess if you focus about
anything else then any any other
distraction I must win he can't even go
in there like that I mean he has to go
in there like look I have to play my
best yes that I can't I get Carlos says
I'm always gonna play my best chest like
how you gonna do today I'm putting my
best chest and then he usually does do
that right so you have to mentally do
that easier said than done but that's
what I'm gonna tell them so the mental
game play your best chess specific on
the X's and O's what would you be doing
if you were Sam Sabian in that chair of
a must win game well I feel like that
non-win is soul crushing because it was
there and he knows it and nihal knows it
that said nihal plays very solid opening
from the white side he likes his London
systems how do you beat the London I
don't think anybody knows that so I
think what he has to do is just remain
composed that's the first and foremost
step because if he gets anything I need
to win yeah he does need to win but then
you go all out and that often backfires
so I do think he needs to keep the game
going and then he can outplay nihail he
showed that earlier in the match yep
well will he show it again and outplay
him once more he's got to do it now or
he's heading home so we're gonna find
out all right it's time chat we've been
teasing an announcement for something
big that's been making making you wait
and we've seen people questioning what
will it be on Reddit and on Twitter for
the last few days but this is in regards
to the huge tournament we have huge
names coming you know what it is I think
maybe at this point uh you'll find only
on chess.com so without further Ado
let's roll the video
the speed Chess Championship is back and
bigger than ever
blundered and he had to take the pot on
t7 the 2022 speed Chess Championship
features the most exciting lineup in SCC
history and over 100
000 in prizes representing the next
generation Our notorbeck Abdus Torah
Arjun Eric icy nihal sarin and gukesh
domaraju defending their Elite status we
have Dimitri on draken Anish giri Maxim
bashiella grav Wesley so Lavon aronian
janapamnishi dingly Ren and Fabiano
caruana headlining this incredible field
are the reigning world chess champion
Magnus Carlson and the reigning speed
chess champion Hikaru Nakamura these 14
combatants will be joined by two
qualifiers oh my God 86. oh my goodness
you missed it the speed Chess
Championship 2022 begins November 21st
fasten your speed belts
I think I speak for everyone when I say
that the big news we're going to get
into with Magnus Carlson obviously
playing again in the SEC but really well
done you completely lose his shirt this
year in the SEC like he almost did there
uh what are your what are your thoughts
on that
I'm not sure about dania's shirt
collection but I'm super stoked I did
know about all the contestants in
advance that's why I may not be as
excited as others but I think Dimitri on
draken is a name to watch he loves these
quicker time patrols he's won many title
Tuesdays so watch out for andrekin in
this field well I'm gonna throw to you
guys but I'm going to jump in and say
even though I obviously knew Magnus was
going to be playing I am super pumped I
know he wants revenge let's let's
remember him on did Magnus win the last
SCC he played Magnus tends to do that
with almost everything and the thing is
Danny yeah
he wants revenge right I mean he lost in
the semi-finals to mvl so I don't know
what do you think about a Magnus
rejoining the field I think he's a
motivated Magnus well I think Magnus and
Hikaru is this like this you know ever
present matchup at the top and yeah they
have this uh fun but competitive rivalry
and I know it means so much to both of
those guys they might never admit it but
it means so much to just finish above
one another and right you know make it
to the top of the table so what's
exciting have magnets in this tournament
I think there's a big rivalry at the top
there absolutely yeah I'm pumped for of
course with Magnus and Hikaru playing
that's always super content maybe a
hundred thousand people watching Chess
at that point every time they play right
then you have of course the youngins you
got an order back there go cash Origins
there they are very young 2700s and they
are only getting stronger that's scary
to even say but of course you know it's
gonna be a lot of Chess so it's going to
be a lot of chat it's going to be super
exciting again Magnus Carlson rejoins
the SEC field two more of course need to
qualify their way in but stay tuned as
dates get announced for that and we we
move into what the SEC will bring you my
favorite event every year so all right
that's it for us guys that's it for us
for now anyway we will be back with the
post game and the post game highlights
of course and some more in-person
interviews let's bring in our
commentators now it's time to throw it
on back to Donya and Levy guys take it
away thank you Danny that was an awesome
Illuminating discussion well our speed
belts will be fastened in about a month
but our seat belts are fastened right
now as we enter for the final game of
today's CTC action nobody I'd rather be
covering it than International Master
Levy Rosman Levy how are you feeling oh
I'm feeling so excited man I mean Anish
giri most brilliant moves in the field
highest percentage and he's gonna need
to find some brilliant moves in this
game number eight because it's three and
a half three and a half but it's not
tied from a momentum standpoint it's not
tied from an emotional standpoint Geary
devastated in that last game but the
good news is even if he held that drunk
he would have had to play game eight now
it's just a slightly different situation
he just has to not lose any smart I mean
we can see him on camera here he's
smiling yeah he's he's feeling good I
mean I asked you how you're feeling I
should have probably asked the niche how
he's feeling two losses in a row Robert
mentioned in the pregame discussion that
that might be the biggest battle Anisha
is waging there's the battle on the
board which is just commenced and there
is the psychological battle can he push
those two losses away let's find out we
have a rigos in here Timur playing one
to D4 and they're currently following
the most popular variation of the
ragosan in an early C takes D5 by Timur
Levy we're not We're not gonna get like
a moment in here where they force an
Armageddon right that would be crazy I
think they're keeping some pieces on the
board but this is a very solid line from
Timur yeah I mean I think both of them
have the same approach like neither of
them really Minds in Armageddon but
neither of them necessarily wants a
force draw I think both of them want to
fight now watch me say that and then
there will be a draw for on move 10 that
would be shocking yeah Timur doesn't
repeat the line where he won last uh
round and I think that part of that is
because Anish giri on the break likely
reviewed that line for 30 minutes oh
however long he had while the guys were
over there discussing all the good
things and fastening your speed belts
and so on and so forth they're still
getting fastened yeah they're still
they're still strapping after that
announcer was so annoying that SCC guy I
don't know they shouldn't hire him again
to do the voiceovers no no I I
completely agree I mean speed belts no
who invented I mean this let's not even
talk let's talk about the game C6 by
Anish building up the ponche now
generally uh Levy as far as I know I'm a
king's Indian player through and through
but as far as I know that Bishop from B4
often drops back to D6 he's could do it
on this move yep you could get the other
Bishop out to G4 I know a lot of people
probably tempted by that move anything
else catches your eye well I mean I
really like the plan of Bishop D6 and
then G5 G4 even though we're that's
completely unnecessary and likely just
positionally lost for black clearly your
speed belt isn't fastened if you're
proposing that idea yes and then I have
various very nasty things going on over
here but you play like that if you have
to win or if you have to lose right
you've got a flight in a little bit uh
Anish giri certainly does not he was up
two games in this match it's a spoiled
for Choice kind of moment now does white
want E4 is that yeah I mean I think that
depends on the placement of Black's
Bishop Knight D7 by a niche I think he's
actually I was maybe even worried about
E4 so after Bishop D6 I think E4 is very
very likely because once the E file
opens that black queen has to plan
itself on E7 and then the Rook slides
over to E1 and things could get nasty in
the center so a big decision here by
gearing I don't think he's gonna take
this Knight I don't think that's
necessary I'm pretty confident that
we're gonna see Bishop d 6 maybe he
wants to guide the bishop towards C7 but
that would help to more expand on the
queen side of the B4 there's Bishop D6
yeah there's Bishop D6 taking the Knight
a move ago would have just helped white
and you don't really stop E4 so now we
have E4 we're gonna get a rook on E1
likely but I think after rookie one
black has this move Knight D7 F6 and
people have this phobia of discovered
attacks you can't just say oh rookie one
discovered attack you actually have to
see whether there is an effective
discovered attack and if you put these
moves on our well actually players will
put these moves on the board there we go
see we don't have to do anything else
yeah there's there's nothing uh there's
nothing here for white either thing that
you take bishop or Knight with your
knight the queen will happily recapture
and avoid any sort of danger I think
there's a I would put it at about 75 at
this point that we're going to see a
draw yeah but things can always explode
why am I so confident there's so many
pieces on the board it's just neither
side has any weaknesses there aren't any
imbalances both sides of the Knight and
the bishop and you could argue oh but
Timur has the isolate related Queen pawn
and the square in front of it is
blockaded by black but on the opposite
side white has a little bit more piece
activity nice Queen on B3 and with his
last move yeah Timor is trying to make
it difficult for Anish to get his Bishop
out so Rook B8 comes to mind but then
maybe the Knight jumps into E5 in some
of these positions I was gonna say can't
you just play like Bishop G4 if you play
Bishop G4 I think you can oh because if
you take on B7 you of course yeah it
will damage your structure if you play
Knight E5 I was thinking you can take on
okay he plays Bishop E6 so similar idea
wow so what is his idea after Queen
takes B7 let's analyze a little bit Rook
fb8 right because the other one you
would lose another Pawn yes Forest I
thought Rook B2 but uh maybe not no I
think I think that's his idea then I
guess white could try to go Rook B1 to
rest control of the B file from your
hands and okay Rook B1 Rook B1 even this
position maybe not the best execution by
black I have a very hard time believing
black is truly worse here after
something like Bishop G4 yeah but no
it's definitely an equal position but uh
some chances I mean practically speaking
for both sides I would say that Bishop
E6 is a very forcing move we could see
the game end and oh Timor offers a draw
Queen takes B7 on the board oh wow Fury
has declined it oh wow giri did he know
that he there was a draw offer yeah I
don't think any gear has ever declined
to draw that quickly I was gonna stop
there but be careful with your memes all
right he's in the other room he's gonna
finish his game come out here
all right well uh we think that these
guys are most likely going to trade a
lot of pieces here so let's check in
with the other match remaining for the
day and that is the match between Sam
Savion and nihal sarin it's 4-37 a
devastating game seven so close to
Victory uh let's jump into a closer look
yeah as we take a look at Sam savion's
player card listen he qualified he
wasn't expecting to be here he made the
most of it things were going so well for
him on on day one I've sung his Praises
so many times at age 21 he has built to
name a career for himself and that
career is only on the upswing he defeats
mvl Rasmus vane tarasak on three
incredibly strong GMS to get here he's
won tournaments his pedigree needs no
explanation but right now his back is
against the wall that last game was such
a tough pill to swallow and to make
matters worse even a draw doesn't
satisfy him and we see that reflected in
his opening Choice G6 on move one G6
he's throwing it all all out the window
the modern defense is a very reputable
defense but it is something that if you
asked a grand master you have to win
with black what do you play probably 60
to 70 percent of them would say this yep
because it's kg it's uh it gives white
an edge but white still has to play and
Cena Hall is thinking like does he play
The Long castles the short Castle which
kind of setup is he gonna choose and
Magnus Carlsen recently has been playing
the modern in a lot of online rapid
games and we're seeing that by move 1015
he's equalized then it's three chances
to win lose and draw all three results
are possible good decisions a very solid
line by the way yeah Bishop C4 this is
popular nowadays the queen often comes
to E2 and the idea frequently is to just
push this epon up to E6 but we'll get
that we'll get there when Savion
develops his Knight to F6 we'll talk
about it I just wanted to add second
your point that the modern is a sort of
societally approved way to fight for the
win is it a second raid opening
absolutely it's not as reputable as a
sicilian or a caracon or E4 E5 but in so
far as you want an opening that doesn't
lose on the spot and is a little bit
less outlandish than Timur rajabov's B6
which
apparently worked the modern is the
opening that fits the bill and here we
see Sam sebian taking a modern approach
to the modern delaying the move Knight
F6 the advantage of that is that now E4
E5 does not come with Tempo will he play
B5 though Levy and allow the bishop
perhaps to induce the move C6 or is it
going to take care of his King side or a
E6 97 situation oh yeah that's another
thing right he's 697 also possible yes
that would be an invitation to play The
Hippopotamus For some reason that's the
name of that opening definitely a second
rate opening but at this level this is
what we have to really really Hammer
home is that at 99.9 of levels this is a
great opening for black absolutely it
doesn't matter what the computer thinks
chess has this overhanging entity of the
engine that tells you what you should
and shouldn't do and you don't always
need to listen and this is one of those
cases that Savion doesn't care he just
knows he has to play for a win there's
no way to kill the game here black gets
to keep many pieces on the board in fact
all 16 so it's a good choice and I've
had students and friends come up to me
and say well Magnus Carlson said in the
press conference that this line of the
Berlin was bad I need to change my
entire repertoire I'm not playing Five
anymore you're not playing hikarnak
should stop Duda with full due respect
and neither am I so you're safe if you
play the modern but is Sam Sevin safe in
this position I think you're exactly
right I think he's deciding two things
the first does he want to push B5 the
second wow where does he want to put his
Knight you were absolutely right and
Levy I would argue that the hippo is a
lot more appealing because now the
bishop on C4 is just kind of biting on
granite exactly and then black can play
B5 C5 whatever expanding in the center
uh rookie one is of course a very
natural move notice how nehal has not
committed wow H6 that is that early yeah
so he he he uh he wants to play G5
that's the idea and also this prevents
the natural development of the bishop
204 of course it doesn't really prevent
discourages it you could do it but uh
then G5 at any moment and the Knight
comes here it doesn't also prevent the
development of the bishop to G5 that was
just having a blown of the bishop yes or
to H6 just might might as well just go
the entire distance right uh yeah so C3
in the hall is just sort of like you
gotta win dude yeah and I think it's
important to point out you might say
well why did he put the bishop on C4 B5
now comes with Tempo when the position
is this closed the value of a Tempo
diminishes greatly this isn't the same
as the tempo in the night or for a
king's Indian where every Tempo every
developing move matters here yeah Nihao
can afford to make the same you know two
moves with the same piece and I'm very
curious how he's going to position the
rest of his minor pieces is he going to
bring the Knight to G3 as one would in a
rue Lopez this would make a lot of sense
Levy because the big drawback of the
move G5 is that it creates a big
weakness on H5 and there's no better
piece to occupy that square than a
knight especially with a black Bishop on
G7 I'm betting we'll see Knight F1 at
some point yep Bishop now goes back to
D3 just basically preparing for the next
wave of game uh that is to follow Savion
has made all of the natural moves now
will he finish the hippo with B6 and
Bishop B7 will he Castle you know
sometimes you don't even Castle he just
leave the king in the center I need to
interrupt you yep we just had a result
Anish giri thought better of that draw
offer and he has just offered a drop
back something funny happened where I I
see more offer to draw again Anish giri
didn't notice it but then immediately
offered a drop back is that offer
reasonable we have this final position
with the Rook on V6 we see a new
security on camera there looking
intently at the monitor what's he
thinking about right now it's going
through his head I'm playing it oh my
God and I'm so nervous yeah I'm this is
always a very fascinating decision to me
what what goes into forcing an
Armageddon right because that's
essentially what Timur did yeah
four four yeah it's our four four it's
our four four yeah we we got here with
two decisive games per side dead even
and Armageddon is on the way not for
society but for these two players as
this is it this is the way we break ties
in chess For Better or For Worse this is
all we got I'm very pumped and we
predicted this listen whatever the
outcome of the Armageddon what a
comeback buy team or a drop if he wins
two games let's take a quick look at the
final position of this game Levy I want
you to tell me whether the draw for was
justified my answer is yes if I would
have to choose either side I would
probably take black here with that nice
D5 score for the bishop but I think what
Anish was saying first of all I'm
reeling after these two losses let me
take a little bit of a break now I'll
have some time to rest and after Queen
A4 Bishop d595 I think the offer is
totally reasonable yeah but Bishop B3
wins upon oh whoa whoa whoa it does win
a pawn bishop B3 Queen A5 and queen
takes D4 and you can't move the Knight
okay so maybe he should have played on
is that what you're saying I love you uh
yeah wait is he better after Rook B6
well maybe Queen A5 instead of Queen A4
but still Bishop D5 and yeah well but
now there's 95. yeah yeah now the
there's no Bishop B3 okay so I would
have at least waited for two more to
play Queen A5 maybe before yeah but but
this position is sort of uh stalemate of
both sides right it's difficult for
black to move the C pawns difficult for
white to move anything and okay they're
forgiven yeah but this is still very
stressful forcing an Armageddon is uh
it's a gamble it's basically what it is
because now uh there's a wagering system
right so I mean it's this is very
stressful it is and what's bad for the
players is good for the commentators
we're happy we get an armor yet we'll
let the players last or less we'll let
the players rest love those letters like
when I was calling you uh Wesley
yesterday and we have one more game to
look at ladies and gentlemen passenger
speed belts yet again because it's 4-3
in nihal's favorite Sam sebian facing a
must win game and this is the position
on the board the pawns on in the center
have have been traded so we have a wide
open D file anything that leads the game
closer to equality in a draw is
obviously in the house Iron's favor Levy
First Impressions from me I'm pretty
pessimistic this looks Rock Solid for
the Indian phenom
I know creating counter play here with
black is going to be unbelievably hard
because if you play H5 you weaken the
dark scores you play G5 you weaken the
light scores you play at five a week in
the structure and you weaken the king
what else can you do oh that's a that
was that was such a nice explanation
you're exactly right whichever Pawn you
push your Castle to that side maybe if I
were to choose between these three moves
I would definitely go with F5 that's my
King's Indian influence speaking but I
think nihal might not even allow sam7 to
play F5 I think he's gonna throw in the
move Queen D2 the point is not to win
the H6 spawn obviously black is going to
go King H7 but after you put the King on
H7 F5 is even less appetizing because it
walks right into the pin exerted by the
Light squared Bishop white could also go
Rook ad1 black will go rook d8 and a
simple move is just to let's say move
the Queen off of the D file and if black
insists on playing F5 then what
immediately comes to my mind is takes
takes and Knight F3 to it and look these
remind me of nihal's Pawns in that
London game I mean yeah he's being
hunted is what they're just standing in
the center of the board and once you
have to played this move look at all
these dark Square weaknesses yeah I mean
then I can go to H5 okay enough of this
because they have gone down a slightly
different path nihal has gone Queen E2
immediately rather than Queen D2 yeah
but Rook D1 is coming he can also play
A4 but no no Knight C8 Knight D6
actually that's a great idea by the way
Levy yeah Knight C I like yeah but then
what then F5 but and F5 yeah but the
Knight is still defending at five for me
seven so I guess there's less Tempo
depending on where the Knight is
positioned because the Knight on D7 will
be weak white we'll still play Knight H4
so I guess the big question is can you
play F5 immediately because now Knight
H4 there's no King on H7 you can play
out for forking the two miners I don't
think you can play F5 immediately
because Queen C4 it's a moot point he
has played Knight C8 but Knight D6 will
stop Queen C4 check oh I have to show
that's very important for an
understanding the position if he had
gone F5 immediately you're absolutely
right there's not maybe not Queen C4
right away but right away yeah take on
F5 or even Queen C4 right away and the
simplest most plebeian option just take
the pawn on C7 Savion doesn't want to
give that pawn up this threat of f4 is
not that strong white can move one of
these minor pieces is away and B7 is
also hanging and B7 is also hanging
bonus so he's gone Knight C8 rerouting
the Knight closing down the D file
making F5 even stronger this is a
serious idea yeah and the King will go
to h8 or H7 and then somehow black has
bolstered the center quite significantly
huh so nihal taking his time I think
what we're arguing here is that if he
just sort of sleepwalks in this position
yeah Rook 81 let's play H3 let's make
some random improving moves F5 is not to
be trifled with anymore Knight D2 what
is the idea of Knight D2 by the way can
I play H5 also H5 H4 that's something
yeah now it's more appealing because
there is no Knight to occupy G5 anymore
right exactly you don't exactly uh
squares I got it I cracked the code if
Knight D6
he wants to put his Knight on C4 why
trade the knights well that makes F5
impossible so nihal is playing against
the A5 and there goes your move yeah
there's H5 and white does not want to
say oh that's so scary I have to prevent
it because this punch just becomes a
Target and G4 uh to use some of donya's
blue highlighting the skills there uh
here I got another one for you look at
that one though
like don't party too hard we have
commentary yeah I know I know I'm sorry
but G4 is severely weakened right so the
Knight can come back here and just hang
out so it's uh White doesn't want to
overreact to this yeah H4 Bishop F6
you're absolutely right so how yeah and
he plays H3 so he finds a middle ground
where he says hey I'll let you go H4 the
downside of that moves that this G4
square is weak and white can plant a
queen there maybe even plant the Knight
there and reroute it but the black pawn
isn't going to get all the way to H3 and
that would be very problematic because
there's a bishop on B7 that would have
been perfectly poised to exploit the
light score weaknesses why doesn't
Savion Go full crab he played on H5 why
doesn't he play f 5 as well full crab
you know like this uh one of my arms is
outside you know we'll just get in here
like this you know because now A5 uh
prevents this Knight C4 idea A5 prevents
Knight C4 and maybe prepares Bishop B7
to A6 in some cases maybe you want to
reposition attack White's Queen
that is how you generate winning chances
in this type of position you can't do it
all at once you just have to play I
think the best word you used earlier is
kg that's the style you want to adopt
kind of Bunker chest you know make small
improving moves you got to play the
waiting game here knee Hall's not gonna
lose this game on you know on his own
that's exactly right he won't so
savion's gonna have to throw him a
couple of opportunities to mess things
up like the move H5 it's a mutual risk
it's a calculated risk at some point
though the forces are gonna clash and
that's where we're gonna see if Savion
can actually pull off a win with black
can you imagine two Armageddon dude I I
really can't I really I can hardly
imagine one now eight minutes 50 seconds
right now the time is not a factor we
won't even really mention the clock
until one side let's say gets below six
minutes but you don't want to get two
below your opponent and he has played
fast he's played solid he's played
reasonable chess but if you showed Sam
Stevie in this position Levy and you say
well that's the position you're gonna
get 17 moves and I think he would accept
it I think this is a serviceable type of
position in which you truly can play for
a win yeah absolutely tend to agree and
you know Paul is stuck in this weird
situation where the the it's not just
playing your best it's I don't need to
take too many risks I'm up one he has to
win that's usually not how chess Works
usually chess is well I have position
XYZ and you know the benefits of my
position are this and negatives are this
and this is my plan and A5 wow now any
chess player who gets to play H5
followed by A5 is just tremendously
happy and they're both good moves even
if it's on move one and move two well if
you did that against me you would win
but yeah maybe not exactly against
people of a similar skill level um but
yeah Queen E7 and I mean we have zeros
but I don't think this is a zeros like
the position is dead right computer
shows oh it's zeros I think computer
just doesn't want to evaluate the
position yeah some point too lazy I'm
you know let me drink my coffee and
relax but this truly is an equal
position this is the definition of
equality and a lot of people conflate in
their mind oh it's equal it means it's
going to be a draw I could give you
planning as zero zeros that are draws
this is an example of a position that's
totally equal but with chances for both
sides very rich middle game lots of
pieces left on the board and I would say
it's a smidge harder for white to play I
mean black has a bunch of improving
moves on the docket 96 Bishop A6 Rook 88
guess what he has already brought his
Rooks into the center he's having a hard
time putting his Knight on C4 because of
this bishop A6 move and to make matters
worse if he moves his light Square
Bishop out to D3 and says I'm not going
to let you get to A6 that walks into the
other Knight escapod to C5 so it's just
a little bit uncomfortable here for
knee-haul let's see how he handles the
next couple of Moves In Knight C5 and
then white really doesn't want to trade
Bishop Bishop for Knight because they've
watched enough Gotham videos they say
you know seven or eight times out of ten
you don't want to trade a bishop major
level super high yeah in this case that
we're not going to see any danger levels
for example computer here one of the
moves that it suggests of its infinite
zeros is the move not that one uh it is
the move by the way you see black is
better immediately that's a big move
yeah so essentially in hell just wanted
to do nothing and by doing nothing he
did something and he did something bad
the best one of the options was F4 but
like why would you play this move like
why that's a completely
yeah allow your opponent to put a knight
there and put the silly Pawn on e4 so he
does the baby version of that and like
you said savion's position is playing
itself right now yeah it is a knight C5
you can see how quickly he played that
move now you might as well why is F3 a
mistake it's not just because Ben
Feingold calls it a mistake right it's
also because you're I mean it's I think
the reason is pretty simple you're
making weaknesses on the dark squares
that Knight can migrate around to E6 and
then F4 now obviously knee Hall saw this
yes I think he just may have
underestimated the extent to which these
squares are gonna cost them black as
Queen H4 maybe get the bishop his idea I
think his idea was just Queen F2 to hit
the Knight and then 96 maybe Knight E2
so let's make these moves on the board
yeah Queen F2 96 and you know maybe 92
and he's basically saying haha you have
nothing but uh well that's not a
strategy to win games yeah but I
personally the other night and then F5
once again comes becomes a real option
you don't have to convince me you got to
convince nehal that black doesn't have
any play and he really he does because
he's made every improving move and he
has more and once again if you check the
engine it's again proposing F and I
don't think we're going to see this move
at any point in this game he's already
played F3 signed a contract I'm not
pushing this Pawn at F4 Aiden's actually
signed a contract by the way just the
legal league
contract in front of him no contract the
NDA uh but let's go back to the live
board nihal is pondering uh the position
after Knight C5 guess what he's down on
the clock imperceptibly he's down on the
clock it's definitely harder to play
this with white I won't go so far to say
that white is worse yeah white is worse
may be practically speaking I will be
extremely impressed if he suddenly
changes gears and decides to break out
with F4 because it's such an inhuman
move I feel like I had no time format of
Chess do you play a four I'm talking 90
minute chess I'm talking correspondence
chess I am also talking about hyper
bullet and 10 second chest which nihal
plays all the time we just played it yes
yes and this is not you do not play the
move F3 to F4 if you're going to not
trade Knights if you just play that move
and you know 92 F4 at least now makes
more sense I think he's gonna go 92 what
other good stuff by you I think you
called it I think that's his exactly
also 92 takes the sting out of the move
H4 you could also contemplate a move
like Bishop B3 but that does allow the
Knight to jump into F4 and the last
thing you want to do is give away your
dark Squad Bishop it's the only piece
that supervises your dark squared
weaknesses on the king so I don't think
white wants to do anything overly
committal okay Bishop D3 is on the board
yeah you see why does shuffling like
white is basically moving the material
of his soup left to right right black is
preparing for the next of the Brussels
sprouts getting shifted from left side
of the plate to the right right from
your grandfather he's just like I don't
wanna do anything I'm gonna wait and and
black meanwhile is actually making
constant improvements with his moves
there he's not just shuffling back and
forth so that's the difference and
that's why the computer is slowly but
surely going yo dude you're going to run
out of moves here right so Bishop D3
what is the idea of Bishop D3 I don't
know yeah and also attack at your point
Levy it's like White's position is still
incredibly solid but it you know if your
economy of your position doesn't
function yes you're gonna live on your
reserve serves for a while but
eventually Something's Gonna Get You
eventually Black's going to play F5 and
your position is going to start
crumbling so I'm fully expecting Sam to
go 96. I think your old idea to meet
Knight D6 with Knight C4 might make an
appearance
it goes to show you just how much these
peculiar openings can confuse even the
best players in the world right yeah
because the hippo is supposed to be not
great and anybody watching this is right
in the beginning oh he's playing the
modern oh he's playing the hippo you got
players out there expert level players
and chess going oh my God what is he
doing all right this opening is not good
I can't believe he plays but yeah it
wasn't playing then it's move 21 and
Advantage uh Advantage Savion it
definitely practically look at that is
the cameraman shaking the camera shaking
his leg out of the table exactly I think
he's like hitting the table a little bit
but cameraman's just standing like the
the no which is a classic can I show you
a line yeah just for a little bit of
comic relief yes if he plays and right
now there's a big decision he might take
on F4 I'm not ruling that option out if
he plays Bishop F1 and black responds
with Knight T6 great idea is to go after
black snide with 92 there's one small
problem Oh micro Knight D3 the queen is
literally trapped that's what's fun oh
no it's not trapped I guess you have
Queen Jesus but you lose a lot of you
lose a lot of material with the pawn on
H4 it would have been trapped yes and I
think on the basis of this line the fact
that you can't get that night out he's
decided to get the night out but of
course he has captured it that's a big
big transformation and now black has G5
always black just has various attacking
ideas and storming the castle this is a
big moment in this game but the problem
for black is that if you plant the
bishop on E5 that an old friend Knight
C4 comes in and makes an appearance
that's why I love Bishop H6 yep Away by
the way the bishop is not immobile hello
hello dark squares right hello thanks
for putting four pawns on the light
squares and trading your dark squared
Bishop yeah there was an interesting
idea for anyhow to sack the E5 pawn and
vacate the E4 Square for his Knight now
it's off limits because Bishop H4
threatens to win an exchange she's gotta
move his Queen I think he missed that
like I don't know how he missed it I
kind of feel like he look I mean if you
watch his expression there he got
annoyed yeah because you just don't
think you think Bishop H6 is defensive
you don't think that Bozo and H6 is
going to walk to H4 right yeah Bozo and
H4 is winning some pieces on the board
he might sack The Rook when he won I
don't know he might play Rook F1 but
then how do you get rid of how do you
get rid of this you don't that Bishop is
eternal I think nihal is seriously
trying to push the spawn up to E5 yeah
his lights his minor pieces on the
default are all complaining like we
don't have anywhere to go the Knight on
C4 dead end yeah this the the spot where
you need to not lose with white is a
weird one because you try to do nothing
and by trying to do nothing good Lord
you do so much crap you always do
something you just can't you're in your
own way yeah look at this I mean how
many moves has niho made left and right
in the last like 10 turns he hasn't done
but his position is still fundamentally
healthy Levy I would argue that yeah the
evil bar is now showing an edge for
black yeah and and last game it showed
us plus six so yeah we should ignore it
yeah yeah but white is still
fundamentally yes there are weaknesses
of the dark squares you can put the
bishop on G3 you're not gonna get a
queen to H2 though yep so Sam has to
avoid getting in his head and say oh I'm
better and what was what's that happened
the last two times I was better well I
messed it up Sam just has to keep
playing the way he's been playing the
clock now showing five and a half
minutes for both players yeah
percolating we're getting deep deep down
here into the waters is good good job
though by Savion keeping it close on the
clock we know what happens if he doesn't
we do indeed now will he try to stop the
movie E5 you could put the bishop on F6
if you're worried about it no no no no
no no no you don't because he's gonna do
something like Queen G5 I feel like he's
always going to try to make progress he
might play rookie eight he might play
Queen G5 yeah
oh yeah Fair Point Bishop B5 is
extremely annoying I would uh
yeah Knight D6 here walks into E5 that's
the worst thing you want to allow is
Knight E5 with Tempo yeah you five with
Tempo man Bishop six of dude that's hard
that's a hard problem to solve how do
you actually stop white from expanding
with E5 you don't want to go C5 here I
would imagine Levy because that weakens
all these Central squares but C5 Knight
B5 you could try to trade the Knight
yeah but the light squares that you're
surrendering they're Knight A7
I can get behind that I think he
actually might be preparing C5 in
certain cases he's also preparing to get
this Rook into the game yeah that's
definitely an interesting move
Bishop A6 here is such a wild idea for
white to just trade light squared
Bishops just sneak it in there yeah
because how else do you make progress I
think nihal has had way too much
shuffling back and forth it's time to do
something it's time to do something so
but but let's Okay what if he goes E5
you really want to make this move I
Really Wanna because I want that
breathing room for the pieces I guess
after B5 black and go Rook ae8 I thought
oh and that's maybe one of the reasons
he played Knight A7 Levy ah because if
now E6 C5 well yeah there's no Bishop B5
which used to be a move so you're
absolutely right though E6 C5 and fef
after Queen F7 yeah I'm saying the
Knight is hanging yeah there is
complications of the move Bishop C4 but
this is exactly the kind of position you
want yep exactly exactly right Knight A7
is a fascinating it's a multi-purpose
move and computers kill the Allure of
Moves Like Knight A7 97 is actually a
brilliant strategic Knight B5 Bishop B5
computer's like ah stupid move prevents
Rook from seeing a significant Basics
what a dummy allowing he's like sorry
these guys yeah because actually 97 is
very interesting and now has to play
Basics because literally he has he has
no other way and just the fact that he's
made me halt take another minute off his
clock even more is already a sign that
Knight A7 tosses the ball with intensity
and intention into White's Court I mean
yep ideas are being carried out the Rook
is coming into the game Bishop A6 is a
move that shows that you understand that
there's a sense of urgency yep and as we
see sevi on there on the big screen he's
not focused at all is he no stop
watching Netflix Sam come on all right
yeah don't talk about that they have no
access to anything I tell you there's
like a Black Mirror episode right you
got like nehal just in the history
dating you know I'm telling you I've
only seen a few episodes of Black Mirror
that was a good one yeah love Black
Mirror yeah Black Mirror is uh pretty
good
um anyhow super focused do they have the
lights on in Serbia like we got like
giant lights yeah they're like no you
guys are for not being able to make it
to Toronto you're sitting in a room you
got one lamp all right if you lose we're
gonna turn it off he's played Bishop A6
yeah Bishop A6 on the board hunkers down
doesn't Rush fig figures out what the
best move is the flaw of Knight A7 the
only Flawless the only flaw is that it
let's go over the A6 Square gets white
this move and now the bishop pair is
going to be eliminated
will Savion capture that bishop and try
to use that placement of the queen on A6
to get his Knight somewhere but where
you can't go Knight actually you can you
can go Knight C6 in that position yeah
you can go Knight C6 wow and then you
have various Queen c5s at the end do we
want like a queen Rogue Bishop versus
queen Rook Knight situation I don't
think so because I feel like it's too
Josh at that point yeah I don't think so
either with every piece that gets traded
the effect of Black's dark Square
control gets diminished right every
piece okay big deal you've got a bishop
on G3 if it sits alone it's not
participating you know in the rest of
the battle yeah look at that chair
shaking okay yeah the chair wobbling for
Sam Savion three minutes a piece
literally dead even on the clock dead
even on position dead even on the clock
were we not that even on the scoreboard
Simpson has to win and I think maybe the
best middle ground is to trade on A6
Levy and I just wanted to show that
Knight C6 doesn't fail tactically you
can't take because of the check on C5
but it's just a big deal okay you're
attacking my queen I'm moving the queen
back what exactly have you achieved I
think Sam has to do better than that so
I I'm guessing he might make a neutral
move such as Rook idea maybe Rook FDA to
preserve the possibility of a discovery
he's got to make a decision fast though
he's now down 30 seconds on the clock
yeah and again this happened last game
this happened last game where it was
even and he was completely winning and
now he's not completely winning and he's
going to get one minute down we might
have a total repeat this is exactly the
way that I thought Nicholas orange was
going to win this match I did not think
the halzarn was going to play 25 moves
of prep that Sam Savion didn't know put
him away in four or five games I thought
it was going to come down to these tiny
critical moments where Sam's better
Sam's completely winning like last game
or nehal's a little bit better and their
time is ticking and you got to be clutch
you gotta hold your nerves now Sauron I
think holds his nerves better than like
anybody in the tournament maybe not
named Hikaru yeah no I literally was
opening my mouth to say that at his age
what and I'm a big you know I'm I'm a
fan of both players but what impresses
me especially about nihal sarin is just
what you just outlined that ability to
keep his nerves and keep the objectivity
he's in a must-win scenario he hasn't
had too many of them tons of money on
the line he continues to play the way he
always plays he doesn't artificially
modify his style he finds Bishop basic
by the way uh Samsung has spent about 50
percent 50 of his clock time has been
spent on this yeah Levy it's happening
again he's down to two minutes he's
Gotta Move yeah he's got to make a move
I'm getting to 60 of the remaining games
stressful yeah this is just Savvy you
got to make a move man you gotta make
FDA again your default should just be to
make a weight almost a semi-weighting
move but one that hopefully improves
your position yeah he's looking for
something that's not fair yeah he
doesn't want to play this it's exactly
how he lost the last game he's trying to
be too forcing okay Rook have been Rook
fd8 is reasonable as well he doesn't
want to play the B8 move because he just
it's an ugly move no I like Rick FDA and
I think he could very seriously
contemplating dropping that Bishop back
to F6 it's done its job on H4 I think
you have to try to win this game down
the default for that to happen you're
gonna have to find a good way to get rid
of this Knight on D4 yeah that was back
in the Hall's Court what does he do it's
not easy for him either yeah logically
what you want to say here is nehal you
got to keep the clock right like I mean
you see Savion is tanking but nehal like
somehow it just also may not have the
best time management skills he will
happily get down to 10 seconds
into it yeah he has the nervous system
to get out of it but I'm good you know
put the pressure on him as well he's got
to play fast but does he have the
nervous system to keep his Queen on A6
or will he withdraw that Queen and bring
it back to E2 there's nothing inherently
wrong with keeping the queen on A6 I
would even consider moving the king to
H1 in order to eliminate this old friend
Knight C6 then you can take on C6 and
there's no more check on C5 but that is
a ice cold prophylactic move and with
245 on the clock is nihal going to want
to do something a little bit more
drastic than that you know King H1
despite there being no danger whatsoever
playing this move it feels weird to put
your king king on a light Square when
everything is on a light square and the
bishop and you're like oh I'm gonna get
mated over there yeah the Queen's don't
teleport all right they move in many
directions they don't teleport it's hard
move to play you never want to play King
H2 because you allow Bishop G3 check
yeah believe it or not I'm not even sure
that's good for black to play Bishop G3
because Knight E2 back so yeah the
bishop is banished to the island and it
can't go get back into the game but
Queenie two to me my eye keeps getting
caught by that movie bring the queen
back to home base and again you say hey
Sam what is going to be your next step
toward improving your position let me
answer that my own question these guys
gotta hurry it up man they can't
literally they're spending all their
time both guys 56 60 seconds sorry of
their remaining time has been spent
they're about to be dead even again I'll
deliberately seemingly does this he
can't help it he's addicted to it but
let me tell you I think what worries him
is the prospect of black doubling Rooks
on the D file instead of losing the
Knight
well I mean if we move back from A6 yes
yes if the queen moves back to E6 which
it just did wow I think Sam might go
Rook D7 double Rooks play C5 and say I
am going to just smash you down the D
file yes 146 each I feel like it was
just 346 each time together they're
going hand in hand excellent move
excellent move I stamps have been
expanding on the queen side and
controlling the B3 square and knifing
his way into White's position and A3 is
not a great move because this bishop in
the long run will eat every one of these
pawns it will any end game name it yeah
absolutely right now the bishop has a
clear dream scenario get it to C1 in an
end game wow the eval apparently is -1.2
with a queen E5 Queen C5 maneuver and
then there's no Knight coming to B3 and
there's no B2 to B4 the queen can live
on fun C5 forever yep that's an
excellent square and to add to make
matters worth the bishop I'm into
getting the move he's played the move
Bishop back to F6 harassing the Knight
on D4 and Libby if the Knight moves back
to C2 not to sound like a broken record
but if the d-val opens up black is more
active black is better poised to exploit
that defile opening up getting nervous
again you can tell you can tell he's
kind of leaning forward he's got the
hand there again he's like I know I'm
better all right I don't care if I'm
down four games of our other four games
to three not four games but he's lost
two of three games today but he knows
he's better he's got to keep that
composure he's now up on time nihal to
move the hall to move 70 seconds on the
clock if why not Queen C4 isn't that
just a very natural move what are you
worried about there oh the Knight has
gone back and now black can bring his
own Knight into the game which Sam
Sabian does without delay he's taking
over the game five he's taking over the
game he is for now but the hall is still
pretty solid Sam in a must win scenario
even a draw does not satisfy him they
have Sam wins we go to a second
Armageddon yeah Knight C6 Queen C5 the
position is going to play itself Queen
B5 back yeah 95 and then okay five yes
oh my goodness we're on the same page
there you could even go Queen C5 check
and get a queen trade looks bad because
it ruins the pawn structure but it opens
up the B file what how is the queen not
trapped oh my goodness Rook A5 what
happens there the queen can go back to
you just go baby keep getting booted and
then maybe and then it'll be harder for
black to double on the D5 I think nihal
is actually luring he's luring The Rook
to A5 one minute now for both sides yes
and he wants Knight to D5 which looks
scary but I'm not sure I'm not sure
that's like a great Square though you
could just move some pieces and get
booted well but I would play C6 I
wouldn't take the chance with a minute
left I would just go C6 here stop the
knight from getting to D5 play it safe
and Knight C4 let me you called it Queen
C5 check always going to be there unless
one moves his King which maybe nihal
will yes C6 King H1 don't even think
about it just I think he's but
then Queen C5 is still possible
preemptively but how do you stop the
move Queen C5 you can't yeah yeah you
just have to buckle your passenger speed
belts passing those speed belts I hope
they're fast and tight 45 seconds now
for both sides oh my gosh this is crazy
these guys are going hand in hand to to
uh to the depths and this is what we
wanted when we knew that this match was
going to be uh Upon Us in the first
round of the quarterfinals but the the
one it's getting harder and harder to
breathe for nehal star and Sam continues
to grab space and control key squares
will nehal Player move like C4 trying to
just break open the position in sam7
time pressure this is the same structure
we had in the game yesterday by the way
yet that C6 Pawn was on C4 and he was
completely restricted the other way
right it was uh it was the reverse just
C4 he's looking to break out amazing
move what amazing just sense of the
position for anyhow this this is exactly
what he has to try Levy the problem is
that if white takes on B5 the D5 Square
opens up again I don't think black can
afford to get that Knight of D5 no in
this version and and the thing for
Savion is he's nervous because he knows
what his opponent is you ever catch a
big fish I don't really go fishing you
it starts flapping around and that's
basically the equivalent of Nelson he
finds the one way to get counter play
and that record is playing through
sam7's head it's happening again it's
happening again he's got to put it out
of his mind the city file is open the C6
Pawn is weak he was so afraid of
allowing the Knight to D5 even if it
wasn't the best move in the position
that he ended up taking with the rook
and now he's introduced major long-term
weaknesses on his King side the Knight
acrobatics from knee-hole star and as he
Maneuvers his Knight to a better Square
K5 now nihal is improving his position I
still think black's in good shape though
yeah I think at some point black has to
play G5 G4 let's not forget about that
attacking idea I would also contribute
that Bishop E7 is possible lodging the
night from before maybe black can shift
to the pressure from the D file to the B
file and now King G7 10 seconds for
knee-hole these are pass back nervous
moves with 15 seconds they are dead even
I would go G5 I would step on the gas
pedal no he steps on the gas pedal but
on the queen tonight takes A4 oh there
was a tactic Knight takes A4 but Knight
D3 played oh that's a good move too
though because F4 is hanging with Tempo
you can't go 93. oh my gosh Knight takes
A4 once again by the way oh there was
Knight C5 oh Knight E3 there and now G4
is upon us G4 has to happen nine seconds
for nihull to deal with the explosion on
the king side this is looking good for
Sam wow this is looking fantastic 91
what a calm move wow g h g h g h you
gotta open up the king side you gotta
ignore that Knight on E3 C5 on the board
he allows the Knight to D5 but now he
can take it not a great move though Sam
with two seconds Bishop to G5 oh Sam's
losing his nerves he is totally losing
his nerves and he's just lost he's lost
the Knight and GH he's gonna lose a pawn
too Rook B3 but there's gotta be a
knight of five checks that's it well not
quite because the Rooks are hanging
though no but I hope the Rook hangs on
A5 and queen H6 nehal throws in Rook D6
what an excellent instruments attacking
the queen oh Sam's chucking the queen
for the two Rooks but remember a draw
doesn't satisfy him I think niho can
just Queen T1 for petrol on D7 oh my
gosh Queen D1 is a disgusting move it's
perpetual it's perpetual China
unbelievable he did it again Queen D1 is
a Savage move with seven seconds on the
claw Sam has to try to move his King to
G5 but nehal's not gonna let him do it
that's it that's it that's it yup
geometric draw here and nihal sarin by
the slimmest of margins knocks out Sam
said you believe you know where it all
started C4 that was the golden move just
sensing the exact moment
can't believe it I mean Savion probably
has never played a player with that
degree of resilience listen he's done it
himself this is what Sam Sabian is known
for the roles just reverse the nihal
siren has just won his first cgc match
this is insane yeah and he's one I think
what is it 25 000.
let's do that trick just with that move
C4 incredible stuff he literally was
down to a point in this game and in this
match when he had one move for like five
positions and he kept finding it
this was just I mean this is gonna take
a while for me to settle in you can see
any Hall star in there the concentration
the just ice water in his veins Levy
these cliches cannot be repeated enough
because he keeps doing it again and
again and again it's it's insane yep
Savion can't believe it I I can't
believe it I can't believe it either all
of the results there got all the scores
we called this right we uh from the top
down right we know that hikarnakamura
5-2 versus young trishtov Duda Wesley so
four and a half one and a half they will
meet in the semi-finals dominant
displays from them putting away matches
in seven and six games respectively but
we have nehal sarin taking it down and
literally the slimmest of margins just
now against Sam Savion and we have her
job of giri all tied up just incredible
matches all around the Nakamura and
Wesley matches were our lopsided ones
Neo Hall has just secured the win and we
will have one Armageddon ladies and
gentlemen but I'd like us to revisit
what we just saw this brilliant
defensive display for the umpteenth time
by the Indian Grandmaster and it all
started in the position that's in front
of you Levy black is making progress
he's controlling squares it's looking
good for Sam and then the unthinkable
happens again yeah the from here uh
nehal played Just Sublime chess C4 only
move uh and then we got Queen to E6 a
trade the constant threat of Knight D5
that was the point of C4 you want to
carve out that square yes exactly and
now you get him to play Rook B5 and now
you've created two Targets A4 and B5
Knight B1 whatever it is what a move
this is a ridic this is a hard move to
find a classical game he finds it with
eight seconds left Knight B1 now people
know what I'm up against when I play
bullet with knee Hall yeah and and from
this point forward look at this Knight
C3 Rook A5 and it still look like seven
Rook C1 just making small improvements
yeah by the way Rook C1 on its own is a
brilliancy just to play Rook C1 and and
rook fd1 and all this stuff he's just
improving his position Sammy tried to
get his Knight to E3 now there were some
tactics there were some tactics but we
enough all right they got 10 seconds
like you know give them more credit yeah
and and uh right here with G with G4 it
really felt like this like if nehal is
black in this game not in this game
against Savion but just against most
people he's gonna win because Rook
rotating from A5 to G5 and then Rook
rotating to h8 from B8 and then Savion
the nerves Knight B1 and Knight D1 yeah
Knight B1 Knight D1 and then uh the move
here that lost in the game was C5 C5
shut the door on his Rook shut the door
on the on his attack and the Jeep door
on the match and the only other move was
GH this is what he had to do he had to
open up the king side and yeah guess
what we could be singing a completely
different tune in a position like this
yep but again it's a battle of nerves
Sam Sabian makes that impulsive decision
lets the Knight get to D5 and once
knee-hal eliminates the pawn and gets
his Knights F5 and his Rook to D6 this
was Exquisite play by nehal and he
forces a Perpetual to win the match yeah
and just one just one more time I mean I
I uh there was Queen D1 there but I oh
that's all I wanted to show
um but it just it was amazing nerves
just amazing nerves knee-haw iron
punches his ticket to the next round and
we will have Armageddon for you but
before we take a quick break and move on
to Armageddon Brave means private
browsing and so much more by default
Brave blocks ads and trackers on every
page and video you visit even on YouTube
no ads means up to three times faster
page loads faster streaming and faster
playback it means 35 percent longer
battery life while saving on mobile data
and internet bandwidth for Android iOS
and desktop get the best browser for
gamers streamers and creators switching
60 seconds at brave.com
chess when we come back oh my Lanes
it'll be Armageddon time here at the cgc
quarterfinals who will move on to the
semi-finals will it be Anish giri will
it be the resurgent team or a job of
only one way to find out and we will
find out when we come back to the cgc
foreign
[Music]
hey guys welcome to the Madison it meets
every Wednesday we call it the Maddie
great place for just like a hangout I
love the atmosphere casual you can like
grab a beer have some fries Crush some
noobs and chess and right now they're
running a blitz tournament but it's a
great place to hang out every Wednesday
they host it right here at the Madison
and as you can see behind me we're in
full session here it's a great place a
lot of people have dropped into this
very location including Grandmaster
Hikaru Nakamura as recently as I believe
it was last week or a week before and
then guys like me also come once in a
while so it's a fun place to hang out
foreign
.com's newest mobile release for Android
and iOS now with game review
game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play use
retry mistakes to get another shot at
finding missed opportunities
game review is available today on both
Android and iOS
download our app and try it yourself
[Music]
foreign
here at the chess.com Global
championship in Toronto this is the
moment we have all been waiting for
Anish giri there deep in thought on
camera he will be facing off against The
azeri Grandmaster Timur rajabov playing
from Belgrade mounting a ridiculous
comeback first and foremost ladies and
gentlemen we need to review our
Armageddon format in Armageddon the
players bid on time in the lowest bid
the player who bids the lower time has
the black pieces white on the other hand
starts with 15 minutes always regardless
of what the player with white bit black
plays with uh draw odds which means that
if the game is drawn black wins the game
here alongside International Master Levy
Rosman covering the Armageddon for you
Levy this is really the moment we've all
been meaning for Speed belts quick speed
oh yeah it's fast speed okay absolutely
fast and folks uh you have to understand
chess is this very unique uh game sport
whatever you want to call it where we've
gotta find find a way to break draws or
ties and unique Styles so what usually
happens is you take a game format and
you cut the time in half and then in
half again and then less and less and
less and something like the World Cup of
Chess that's usually what happens but
here you'd just be sitting here for
hours and what you gotta play seven
minute five minute two minute right no
we're just going straight to Armageddon
now this season Armageddon has had
probably 11 minutes as the most popular
right but seven minutes was once bid by
vishy Anand and he ended up uh losing
that at the cgc yes losing to Pablo Punk
crowd of great memory by you and Anish
gearing Timur a job off two of the most
accurate stable players on tour at the
top I don't think either of them is
going to be bidding seven minutes no
they're super solid we are going to
review their rapid insights to Anish the
more experienced player but look at
their average accuracy Levy is it any
surprise that the match is tied no it's
dead even and Anish has obviously a much
bigger sample size about three and a
half times but uh they make very very
very few bad moves now anisha's games
tend to be a little bit more wild that
is true and oftentimes when he plays
Black actually he has played many
aggressive games one of the best wins of
his life against Magnus Carlson that was
some years ago but it was a very very
aggressive game uh and I made a video
about it in Niche commented that he
loves me so that was adorable uh and
yeah so that's why he has a little bit
more Wild games than Timor but
Armageddon is just I mean all bets are
off this is the ninth game that is the
maximum amount of time at the chess.com
Global Championship that it takes to
decide a match and leave we've got a
eyes on Geary we do have our eyes on
Geary and each Geary he doesn't by the
way yeah who doesn't fiddling there with
his headphones and the players are
making their bids Anish Gary is putting
on those headphones getting set we will
be telling you what the players bid and
here it comes we're getting the bids
right now we're getting the bids right
now as Anish giri gets settled into his
chair ready to play who will have white
who will have black this is a huge
decision Levy everything is on the line
we have the bids and ishqiri has been 13
minutes and one second and one second
indeed so not going too low so he wants
black but he doesn't want it that badly
not at all I would argue because the
most common bid you called is like 11 12
minutes I actually think he really wants
white yeah but why didn't he BET 14 then
yeah I guess if you really wanted Whitey
would bet 14 so he's like I'm fine
playing black but I don't want my time
deficit to be almost anything intimura
job of his bid drum roll please ladies
and gentlemen whoa wow we just got word
that Timur a job of his bid if we can
get that on the screen is 14 30. he
wanted white a whole hell of a lot more
he didn't want no negotiations wow cut
me out of that business I'm playing with
with white I don't care that a draw
loses me the match I want the time
Advantage wow that's uh that's huge so
Anish uh actually maybe a niche thought
team War would want white maybe Anish
knew Timor struggled with the black
pieces and yes he won that game with the
black pieces but that game was crazy uh
and he said you know what I'm happy I'm
gonna have 13 minutes so I'm gonna get
black I'm gonna get a full result in my
favor think about that chess has three
results win lose draw you can't just
seize two of them nope that's ridiculous
and you only have to give away a minute
59 I actually think you got a great deal
that's a great no that is a phenomenal
deal he got boardwalk and park plays for
a pretty low price I think Anish has to
be happy but Timur in their first game
of the day Levy uh or is it their second
game with the white pieces demonstrated
some amazing preparation in the nimso
Indian I mean he was basically winning
on by the time that the preparation
ended so I think we're gonna see D4 from
Timor here's the moment where it's
revealed he is playing D4 and will Geary
modify the nimso Indian power off folks
why Knight F3 yeah I know he didn't play
C4 man here three and then he's G6 not
even going for E6 this is so fascinating
wow rajaba must regret playing C4
not regret playing uh Knight F3 in the
second wow maybe that was his strategy
along the Tory attack like not a
frequent guest at the top but a really
good Armageddon opening because you're
guaranteeing kind of a long positional
grind which is good for the side of the
time Advantage yeah now the question is
will a niche play D5 right that's kind
of the grunfeld move which is D7 D5
controlling white from playing the move
E4 if you do play D6 there could be E4
stuff wow just castles so he's giving
white the choice and oh no he's punting
he's uh he's going King's Indian boys
playing King's Indian setup and E3 by
two more very modest approach E4 is a
legitimate move there but two more kind
of going London system style yes
obviously a very similar structure to
the London system is the bishop better
on H for f for that is debatable that's
why both of these openings are entirely
possible on a trade on D4 upon and
balance created in the center what do
you make of this yeah and now see if
Black's Pawn was on D5 we would have an
exchange Karo hun right that's what
that's what we would have instead of
that we have well I don't really know
like what opening is this from basically
yeah this is an odd structure the
benefit of having the pawn on D6 of
course is that black can push the pawn
up to E5 and grab space in the center
but that move comes with the price tag
he's inducing D5 yeah he wants him to
play D5 he prefers that Anish turn the
game into a Karo Khan style position
rather than being able to play the movie
five very interesting and guess what
there's the other consideration there's
no increment in Armageddon zero
increment so every second is gold and
he's trying to force a nation to making
a lot of these early decisions yes and
maybe extend his his time Advantage
Queen B6 is a very natural move opponent
B2 is hanging you can defend it by
moving your queen or your rook and he
does in fact move his Queen wow but now
if Black's Queen drops back you have to
reckon with this Knight A5 threat oh
yeah yeah and and now uh just like we
had the crab last game with H5 and A5 or
the lobster we have we have Knight A5
Knight H5 potentially and this bishop
suddenly hits nothing it's hitting
nothing they can't even go back to G3 no
because after Knight takes you through
your entire King side is is going to be
ruined I think we're drop off missed
Queen C7 this is a big moment in the
opening arnisha solved his opening
problems that's not up for debate but is
black actually even better here you
could play Rook V8 G5 before he goes E5
yeah that's a natural move
um and again something like d takes E5
white sort of doesn't want to do that
really but also kind of faster yeah you
kind of have to because if you Castle
here well I guess E4 is not really
possible because Bishop takes F6 and
Timur exploits that he does Castle maybe
we'll see your move Knight F6 to H5 yeah
but is that in a niche move this is
again this is always comes back to this
they're like a niche sticks to a style
and it's gotten him top 10 in the world
but it has how do you break away from
yourself yeah
rise to the occasion though Libby I mean
he played G4 in that French game which
she ended up losing tragically but we've
seen a niche you know we've seen a niche
put on different types of hats 95 on the
board so excited Drive is on the board
now you could argue the drawback of that
move is that it gives up the E4 square
but 94 yeah just doesn't look appetizing
at all there's Knight takes D4 ideas no
no this is a great position for a niche
rajama has beaten people like this his
whole career with black now he's facing
down the entire oh rookie 21 out of a
necessity not because he wants to play
this move yeah but I mean that move like
what happens if black doesn't take on D4
well then wait I guess goes Rook fe1 but
what does C1 doing you're gonna have to
play Rook D1 anyway okay it's
prophylactic you know you're preventing
it takes D4 no but I I can't get I can't
get behind that I mean G5 and each has
to start firing there he goes you know
what's tough here Timur is making a
niche play for the win yeah but that's
exactly how you approach the arm again I
think anybody will tell you that you
cannot play from the play for the drop
from the outset if you have a Perpetual
you take it but you play the way you
normally would in a classical game you
don't artificially modify your approach
and is he going to snap that Bishop off
the border is he going to let the bishop
Live Another Day I actually think
Armageddon there's no strategy involved
like I know there are meta strategies
but in Armageddon the players are too
nervous and it's uh and the audience is
nervous I just saw that chat I'm nervous
I mean producers a million miles an hour
yeah I mean uh our parents and relatives
are nervous watching us up here
everybody's nervous
um hotel is nervous you know that we pay
our fees Bishop F5 okay so and he
chooses not to take at all but why would
you let the bishop Escape yeah you but
Seymour took exactly half a millisecond
on Bishop HD says you don't want to take
it wait why did he let the bishop Escape
though this is well I think some people
will tell the bishop as passive but the
bishop has a lot of potential energy
because it was hitting the E5 Pawn now
Geary invites Timor to trade on F4 right
but I'm anticipating a move like Rook
Cafe one I think Timor is going to try
to keep the tension here and continue
trying to milk anisha's clock I still
like Black's position for the record I
know you could milk a clock that's a
very interesting uh Rook fe1 I I was
gonna stick to the chess board here uh
yeah and if Bishop takes F4 by the way
which way do you take with because my
first instinct is to take with this Pawn
to remove the tension but it's I mean GF
and something down the G file absolutely
I would go GF and look at how solid your
Center is in that case yeah my problem
with timor's position is that I don't
really see a plan he's kind of making
these wishy-washy amorphous moves
they're about to run out they already
have run out what is his next piece that
he's going to move even if Anish plays a
move like A6 which I think he very well
might yep the problem is Black's
position is very much your style of
Chess right a niche would prefer yeah
again he's always going to make that but
but see now like that slight improving
move and apparently black can uh yeah
well that time might be ripe for Bishop
takes F4 yeah yeah yeah exactly okay
is there some like tricks here I'm
trying to find like some some way to
take on E5
well there's the G5 Pawn guarding the
Knight as well and if you take on a four
now Levy the drawback of trading on E5
preliminarily is that now I think Anish
will take with the e-pawn and the open
defile only only favors one side Black's
pieces are more active black is more
than happy uh to have both of the center
files open I don't know if if Timor had
a follow-up in mind I don't like d takes
E5 at all again I don't think there's
much strategy involved I think it's uh
just a nerve-wracking experience
honestly you can't kind of look at the
clock a lot because there's no increment
so yeah you definitely looking at 94 but
just yeah Rook 88 it's the only piece
that hasn't moved yet actually very
important because Bishop f8 would get
you would get forked on F6 so KD comes
just in time Anish does see that yep I
think Timor might have forgotten about
Rook Ada I mean the confidence with
which you took on E5 and now he's taking
his time Rook d8 yeah and Rook 88 and
Niche would have played anyway so right
he plays that move and D6 is now
completely covered and life is good life
is good time on the clock what is pretty
good what is it okay thank you there he
goes I mean it's the nerves you called
it yeah we started the game with a 159
time difference and normally what
happens in Armageddon is black catch is
white it's just what happens but by the
time black catches uh like you you catch
up on the clock right like uh the
position is already not so great for
black in this case Timur is just pushing
and pushing and pushing the time
Advantage he's trying his best but until
Anish gets to five minutes I'm totally
unconcerned about the time situation B4
like this move by Timor he's trying to
make lemonade out of this situation it's
a tough situation his pieces aren't good
A5 a niche thing I'm not giving a mile
here I'm not giving an inch wow B5 is
just in he's basically saying this B5
idea is bad exactly is it bad well
that's what he's saying I mean what else
can you play here no that is totally
what he's saying is he does he want to
go like Knight C6 back to B8 and open up
an attack on the bishop then maybe
reroute exactly use the dark squares on
C5 I'm so confused I'm confused by
everything that's going on three
teamwork keeps the tension aims at the
F7 Pawn Yeah the problem is anisha's
strategy did not have this in mind
because now if you play oh my gosh he's
opening up the road he's opening up the
C file hey Levy you asked why the Rook
was on C1 he saw up to this point I
don't like that but I get it now A3 may
be by white what else can you do and you
could be visited by this old friend
Bishop takes that four forces now G
takes F4 because ef4 runs into Knight
takes G5 yes discover the discovery on
the queen yes not Knight on F3 holds the
Knight on G5 and The Rook on E1 does
everything so what I would do I would
snap the Knight off and maybe reposition
the light squared Bishop to D5 start
pressuring the Knight and really justify
the placement of white truck and the
White Knight on F3 doing such an
important task it's guarding the D4
Square yes the problem is that if Anish
at any point can make a draw that's
really bad news so Timor has to always
struggle with the fact that his opponent
can try to find a way to trade
everything that's not usually the case
in chess a draw is a draw a draw is not
a draw in Armageddon nope a draw is a
win for the black side and we remind you
that this is is our only Armageddon
between her job of and giri as the game
enters the Early Middle game stage speed
belts fastened to Moore contemplating
his next move Bishop takes it for very
committal very committal decision time
by the way no he doesn't and there's
Knight T4 snap immediately yeah Anish
not concerned about discovered attacks
on his Queen Once Again Donnie and I
have been saying this all day if there's
nothing actually substantial there is no
threat yeah an x-ray alone isn't going
to you know put bread on the table a
trade you get paid per x-ray
yeah it literally will put bread on the
table so F3 now I guess by white I
suppose you have to play F3 but then
initial thing doubles on the default and
he asks you more politely how are you
going to win this position everything is
compact everything is solid it's not
weaknesses it's not polite anymore ain't
nobody being polite they're friends but
not right now you got no friends on the
chessboard and guess what in a normal
game team would probably take on F4 and
calmly make a draw with rookie D1
casually that's totally out of the
window
how is he going to generate chances here
he is now it's 40 seconds between him
yeah and Anish this is that part of the
Armageddon game where black catches up
to White this ain't looking good for
Timor at all and I'm not just saying
that because oh the evil bar is showing
minus Point too it's the type of minus
point to Advantage that you have you
have an incredibly easy to play position
with black with no targets that's the
worst thing for white in an Armageddon
game yeah stockfish doesn't understand
what Armageddon is right it's just a job
in life it's just look at this
chessboard it's kind of a depressing
life actually but uh yeah if you told
stockfish right now that black actually
wins this game if a draw happens it's
going to be minus one it's going to be
minus two t more knows that so he plays
a move like this and well it's now
better for black but it was better for
black when a draw was on the table as
well yeah I'm into more strategy at this
point keep the tension for as long as
possible get this game into a Time
scramble you can the best move here for
for black you you see and I see it it's
it's King HH G6 are those like what yeah
well they're part of the plan to play F7
F5 but push the Knight away but is the
niche gonna play for F5 that's my
question is he gonna play forever I
think he's gonna double his Rooks right
exactly
wow well it also could be prophylactic
right various tricks here but yes in
general it does a lot I mean it doesn't
hurt life I mean it protects even if you
don't move your King on the next move
yes Bishop G6 is not going to hurt you
it's a solidifying move I still think he
might play Rook d8 on the next move it
totally depends on what Timor does maybe
Timur should contemplate the move Knight
C5 maybe he takes the bishop the Knight
on F4 I'll point out Levy that after
Bishop F4 EF yep there's Knight F6 check
obviously Anish still will play the move
G takes F4 one more thing I want to
point out please do six there's various
tricks of here here getting a queen
twitch for and Bishop H5 which didn't
use to exist you get the queen out and
then F3 and you seal the white position
and you start hammering home over here
but of course that's very sharp do we
need all that I don't know time is even
time is totally even now to more down on
the clock for the first time in this
Armageddon game he needs magic he needs
a miracle at this point and I'm not even
exaggerating this position is as
watertight as it gets for Mr Geary yeah
something's gonna happen the next five
moves yeah something's gonna happen has
just artificially explode this position
but you can't just sack all of your
pieces you're just going to lose you
actually have to pose problems for black
it's not easy how on Earth do you do
that yeah you pose a problem like Bishop
B5 he just plays Rook d8 yeah problem
solved now what I mean G3 he takes on H3
Bishop F4 he's just gonna take with the
Jeep on so yeah I don't see a single
move and neither does team or a job of
maybe bishop B5 and then a rook goes to
C5 there's like zero thread but it's an
idea oh there's ideas there with the
Rook D4 to D3 trying to trap the queen
but I think you're absolutely right
Anish isn't going to seek adventurers
out when he can just make solid moves
Bishop H5 also in the mix as Kanti would
say yeah yeah Queen could get trapped if
a white Rook lands on E3 as we're
talking timorua jambov who had two
minutes up on the clock at the start is
actually down on time he's down a full
minute it's a three minute turn around
it's a positional turnaround God I love
this event he has no idea what I know
this is amazing but he has no idea what
to do the worst sign is when white is
worse than an Armageddon and has less
time hey we got colleagues in the chat
gmjx that's of course Jeffrey Jean
saying commentary team is fire I guess
that would be more fire if he was right
here absolutely
B6 anisha's position is fire right now
look how quickly he's playing he's not
even hesitating yeah and you know that
night went from the center and I think
it's getting slapped directly back into
the nope it goes this way he goes this
way okay okay I can get behind this but
just Rook D6 again the problems that
rajaba is posing are just one move
threats right now yes yes and he's
hoping he's desperately hoping and he's
just something crazy and he's not doing
anything crazy not doing anything crazy
I think he's just gonna keep it going
with Rook d8 that old idea King h8 and
F5 still very much again still very much
in the mix you could try to push upon E4
black is kind of spoiled for choice I
just want to show something real quick
let's see white says I'm I'm too much
stressed over here I'm gonna go make a
pat I'm gonna go make a queen because I
read in a book somewhere that yeah you
just get obliterated oh you get
demolished and Bishop D3 Rook D3 Levy
yeah and it's not a rookie three exists
but then the before Pawn hangs yeah then
you just lose B4 so Brook takes C3 and
queen takes before you try you try yeah
okay I can one move threats oh rookie d8
is there Bishop F4 and queen F4
let's pull up in another analysis board
really quickly that is what Anish is
thinking about Bishop takes F4 GF Queen
takes F4 oh I think there's something
here but well guess what worse comes to
worse you don't find it take on F4 go
Bishop B2 is black Really Gonna Be Worse
you're gonna recapture A3 look at your
Rooks look at your Bishops that Knight
on B3 is totally out of the game yep no
this is incredibly incredibly depressing
14 more and Anish I think he calculated
it precisely that line yes and he has
played Rook e to d8 and again it's a
must draw it's just a must not lose
situation for Niche once he finds Bishop
doesn't even care about anything else
doesn't care about anything else wasn't
the best move there was some Queen X7
move minus two he's not thinking about
that he is thinking about I need to not
lose this game yeah that's the
incredible power of having it the game
literally changes the rules of the game
change what you're looking for changes
you've talked about that and see more of
a job of I think coming to the
realization that Bishop takes that four
merely accelerates his demise just look
at the position look at how black
controls every single Square in the
center I'm every score I'm highlighting
is under black control not to mention
that 93 is now a legitimate threat as is
E4 as is Bishop D3 White's position is
in free fall I don't want to overly rely
on the computer because it's annoying if
I do besides the move Bishop F4 which is
the only reason the positions minus 1.6
stockfish is literally saying Knight A1
when that is your second best move
that's a problem okay what is Knight A1
I mean it moves the Knight away from the
from the purview
yeah
preparing for the next game and he has
taken and he sees nothing better than to
take and the fact that teamwork spent
like a minute and a half on this one
just means this is the best the Lesser
evil yes now e takes F4 is in force
there's Queen A7 Queen A7 is minus 1.7
and then you get in here will a niche
play that or will Anish Play Bishop B2 I
I predict Bishop B2 he's been surprising
as this game he has and I think Anish
has made this accent put this accent on
objective play can you blame him for
this bishop B2 on the board yeah that's
that how do you win this with him he's a
couple of moves away and to make matters
worse let me if you play Rook C4 to
attack the F4 the other Bishop swoops in
Bishop D3 yep uh pinning that's not a
fork that's a pin against the bishop on
B5 The Rook is no squares Timor is
stumbling on his own on his own feet on
his own pieces
oh this is tough yeah let's try Rook C7
but just take on A3 take on A3 maybe
bishop C4
but then Rook D1 check and Bishop takes
B4 I think yeah yeah or even can you no
no Bishop F7 is check oh that line is
painful after Bishop C4 I think if I've
calculated this correctly check and
Bishop takes B4 yeah just move the king
yeah I I thought I thought this as well
it's over yeah yeah yeah now Anish you
know he had a position uh down in
exchange here he'll be up in exchange
withdraw it's Timor is just going to
resign if they reach this position
Bishop C4 has been played wow Bishop C4
has been played now he has I think he
can take on B4 first by the way right
with the same idea with the same move
order yeah Bishop F7 oh that's beautiful
King f8 and then you you have this check
on the next move yeah yeah and that's
precisely what Anisha is calculating six
and a half minutes he's gonna find it
yeah Rook D1 as much go back to the live
position much more forcing and of course
I I don't know if there's a difference I
I that's why I thought Bishop before to
reserve the right to play Rook D1 but
maybe just Rook D1 you don't even need
to this might be the the last problem
that a niche gear has to solve in the
first round of the cgc if he finds
Bishop takes before barring a Force
Major the game is over yeah he's gonna
be pumped uh dinner's on him tonight by
the way people most certainly is he has
a nice prize fun bump I I am paying for
his uh for his mocktail and his dinner
anymore after what he put us through the
two losses and Anish double checking
triple checking it's on the board and
it's your execution yeah it takes on
before first then king of Fate that's it
he's found it and uh I think he's in the
clear I don't think there's anything
else I mean why can play King H2
preemptively but I still play Rook D1
and we'd be commentating this completely
differently if this was a normal game
because black is not guaranteed to win
that resulting position black is
guaranteed not to lose and I think Timor
is simply going to resign after Bishop
takes you that's how hopeless this
position is there are literally negative
winning chances for white so white has
nothing no because white has too many
problems Rook D1 and Bishop and free
Bishop on on them you can remove this
yeah you could literally remove this
yeah
can you actually I think you can because
the Rook has no squares on the seven no
matter what even like rookie one rookie
one is still actually good that's so
funny oh my gosh yeah you can literally
pre-move Rook do one whoa yeah no words
four minutes now 40 more his clock
ticking down what a clutch game by him
no this was I have to say after the two
losses the stabilizing draw by Anish was
such a good call it gave him a little
bit more time to rest calm himself down
he played this like a pro yeah right he
was a pro a rook do you want to check
that's it he's just gonna be up in
exchange now uh rajaba will not resign
you said he's not gonna I exaggerated of
course yeah
Bishop D6 now
just don't play Rook D4 listen if the
time situation was flipped I would say
he has minuscule micro chances even with
three minutes then you shouldn't have
any problems here by the way just real
quick yeah please I just want to say um
anisha's so nervous right now like any
human being F3 check and Rook takes D4
oh and Bishop takes G3 that ends it
officially oh that actually does end it
I'm sorry to cut you off no no no you're
a computer if not if no Knight D4 I
think that's it resigns resigns he
resigns he resigns oh my goodness Anish
breathes a sigh of relief and he has
punched his ticket to the semi-finals in
the most dramatic of ways wow and he's
taking a sip of water finally he allows
himself a smile a modest smile indeed
and a hug wow oh my goodness what an
Armageddon we just had what a
performance by Anish giri it is official
he is through to the next round
unbelievable unbelievable Levy I I have
no words yeah that was one of the most
clutch cold-blooded performances I think
I've ever seen black play in an
Armageddon definitely held by his bid
fantastic the bit I think he knew rajaba
was going to try to get white I think
that's what it was and we'll talk to him
but not right now but we'll uh you know
we'll talk to him in general and we'll
we'll see if that was the Strat just an
unbelievably cold-blooded Armageddon
game I would I would go so far as to say
as we see it is official we have updated
the score Anish giri wins five to four
this Armageddon might be the best like
quality game we've seen all match
including the non-armageddon game which
is actually really rare we see a lot of
crazy Armageddon and he's had it under
control from the very first moves and
that turning point when he brought a
screen back from B6 to C7 Levy and the
way he handled the middle game I mean
you just gotta take your hat up no
matter who you rooted for yeah I mean
just super super well done by him
just fantastic nerves and I think we're
gonna take a look yeah at uh oh my
goodness all the uh scores those scores
indeed I'm sorry I'm so tired I can't
imagine how they feel I can't either but
the quarterfinals are completely they
are complete ikar Nakamura he wins his
match Wesley Timor loses the Armageddon
to Anish Levy This Is A Feast for the
eyes this scoreboard yeah wow I mean
okay let me just recap real quick
everything that happened Hikaru jumped
out to a four nothing lead we thought it
was over in one game uh today it wasn't
due to one two and got it back to four
to two and the seventh game was really
close as well that match had seven
decisive games Wesley so turned it
around after a very Topsy 30 first game
it took six to put away Dimitri and
draken I would say he was even more
dominant than Hikaru and his reward
besides 25k is that he has to now play
Hikaru that's gonna be a fantastic side
of the bracket we had nihal sarin
ultimately taking down Sam Savion in one
of the closest non-armageddon matches I
think I've ever seen in my life showing
off all his defensive capabilities and
last but not least Anish giri winning
the Armageddon and delaying about two
games you know oh my goodness what what
a quarter finals we just had living the
greatest aspect of this might be that
the tournament continues this is not
over and things are going to get even
more intense oh my goodness well we're
gonna continue diving into stuff but
first we have Danny standing by with his
thoughts Danny in the gang we go over to
you
thank you Dania and Levy man that was I
I'm exhausted from watching you guys
call that game I know that Anish and
tame over Jabba are probably exhausted
let me go around the horn real quick
remind everybody Danny wrench alongside
Robert Hess James Canty and Amman
Hamilton
this has been quite the day the
quarterfinals delivered Gentlemen let's
remind everybody of what the scores were
when things were all said and done for
these matches you already knew going
into these last set of games that Hikaru
Nakamura and Wesley so moved on both
pretty dominant uh despite maybe some
some weird or bumpy moments overall they
got the job done they will face each
other in the semi-finals and then Anish
Geary defeats tame overjob in an
Armageddon game that had us on the edge
of our seats out there and nihal sarin
completes the comeback he started at the
beginning of the day uh by by winning
winning when it mattered most he you
know I want to go back to that I want to
go reverse order we talked about it
yesterday in that matchup where nihal
holds that game a game he should have
lost to Sam and Levy said it it was
almost prophetic and everyone had a
feeling like odd if that game got away
from Sam what will happen the next day
turned out he couldn't hold off the
comeback train that was nihil sarin no
he couldn't and he had a winning
position today as well so for Sam Sevin
he had those opportunities he shouldn't
even been here right like levonne Ronin
knocked him out he came back and he
still performed admirably but nihal
Saran was a man who was not going to be
stopped he may only be 18 but he plays
some great chess what do you tell your
boy Sam sevian right you got you gotta
be happy you were here we know he wasn't
just happy to be here but you got to be
happy you were here it was a great match
what's your coaching I mean at the same
time okay we got to keep our head high
right we going home with it with a big
check right said thanks to chess.com
we're getting some cake some big cake
and uh you know drinks for everybody
back home okay right so lots of money
his Smiles there but also at the same
time you play nihal sorrow he did take
out ding Loren okay so ding is actually
like playing for the world championship
so I mean of course we lost it happens
so now we just got to get better that's
all it's about I'm on your thoughts on
these final moments here we just saw
yeah I mean I I think that Sam Sevin can
definitely be proud of the the match
that he put forth he missed some
opportunities it it did look if I can
make an observation that he's a little
bit nervous just in the in these games
you know he was here in Toronto he felt
that pressure and it did feel like nihal
got locked in on day two today yeah so
you know he he definitely put a good
match for Danny I don't think he can be
too upset with a match that close well
and we talked about obviously we
highlighted the black the lack of
getting the win in that last game
yesterday the fact that Soren wasn't the
most accurate player yesterday you kind
of had a feeling that the real nihal
hadn't stood up yet right but he did of
course a great event for Sam Sevin uh
but ultimately sorry moved on but there
was another match that just came to a
close as well as we said Anish giri
defeated Tamor rajabov in Armageddon and
he is standing by live with Nemo right
now
thank you Danny I'm here with Anish
congratulations on your win
um so I wanted to ask you bid
13.1 seconds for your Armageddon game do
you have a strategy going to the bidding
process what colors do you prefer for
Armageddon
yeah I think there is probably like a
time
um which is balanced like in a default
case and in Norway chance you play this
10 versus 7 in that tournament so they
really thought about it so I think that
it's like something proportionate to
that is the sort of the neutral kind of
balance but in a particular match you
have particular openings that you play
particular issues you face with white or
black the way the games go so I think
given our bits by both of us it seems
we're both kind of okay with getting
whites
um I think he got a lot of Chances with
white pieces I also got a lot of chances
even though let's say I lost my last
white game if it wasn't a must twin
situation I would be very happy with the
outcome of the middle game in the
opening and so and the same for him he
didn't win all the white games but many
he got some chances so I I wasn't
surprised that a bid would be quite High
I think 30. 1301 I basically was
thinking if he beats 13 uh I'm gonna
take well that's fine
um but if he beats 392 then okay I'll
I'll take the black I love the reasoning
for that and yeah absolutely your
matches were super intense already and
the last Armageddon game was extremely
hard fought you played a really strong
opponent how do you feel about that
Armageddon game yeah really happy
because at some point the match was
slipping away from me I was in a
commanding position after the first game
today it was a good game too so there
were no worrying signs but then I um I
collapsed but in a strange way so I was
collapsing and in the middle game and
but then in the end I would get chances
in both of these games and I was on down
on seconds and the last one especially
like that I had this exchange down uh
position like everything was already
ready and I just plundered this thing so
I was kind of collapsing but then first
of all Danny Daniel wrench gave me a hug
another hug today and hugs they really
work
um especially if they're from Denny and
also I was really happy my I heard from
my wife my family is my kids were
watching you know so I thought okay I
should show them good example but now
it's free time to sleep because it's
already almost nine and I really hope if
they're watching they should really go
to sleep because it is really late
yeah it's always good to have hugs and
I'm really glad to hear that your kids
are watching so you are moving on to the
semi-finals how do you feel about
playing against Niels are in tomorrow
I must say
um I was kind of I keep getting in a
certain in a way lucky with the pairing
I mean nihal is a great player uh don't
get me wrong but um given the lineup up
front
um getting him in the semi-final is uh
well it's an opportunity for me um
and I'm really eager to play because he
destroys me in a quicker time controls
he's a total beast and it's impossible
to handle him in a bullet match for me
but I think that this time control is
maybe I I don't know of course him well
enough but I think this is the time
control where we probably match our
strengths I I hope so at least I think
probably in a classical I would think
I'm still stronger in a bliss he is
stronger already but maybe this rapid
format is where we are evenly matched
but maybe I'm wrong and I'll get uh
smokes you know we'll see but I I do
think that I should have a good shot
well thank you very much Anish it looks
like hugs do help and I'll throw it back
to you Danny
thank you Nemo and Denise that was that
was a great interview there's a lot to
unpack there uh real quick real quick on
the hug I got I got you and you so what
happened was yesterday he hadn't won yet
and he walked by me in the hall and I'm
like hey man you need a hug I'm like
I'll give you a hug and it became an
inside thing and then so you know by the
way we're hugging each other in the dark
there for those um that's that's another
uh I wish the lights were on never mind
okay
[Laughter]
okay okay but there's a lot of great
chest to unpack there the comments he
just made about knee hill summer and
Robert I want you to react first really
interesting the way he gives someone in
the nod and Blitz says maybe he's still
stronger in classical feels like this
rapid matchup should be big but also
likes his chances well first and
foremost he talked about the lineup of
opponents his face right you got to play
Pavel pancrata of the upset specialist
and when you look at the round of 16 you
don't expect Punk roster to be there
considering who he knocked off in
norback Abdus Atara and vishwanath and
Anand so anisha's saying wait hey Karen
Wesley I'm getting niho that has to be
the best matchup on paper but not so
fast nihal may only be 18 years old he
did very well in the Olympia he's
growing as a classical player and I said
the rapid might be the perfect matchup
for them because Neil is better in Blitz
a niche Better In classical Here Comes
rapid Canty you're Sauron you watched
that interview you see that Anish said
he feels like he's gotten kind of Lucky
with the pairings he'd rather be playing
nihal than either I either American left
what do you do if you're selling
anything this person you know sorry got
the face he's like hmm
with the eyebrows and then he'll do that
and then focus and then I'm like man I
feel disrespected if you said that to me
really okay why I'm the easy pairing huh
yeah so I'm just gonna come in here
tomorrow with a little smile and be all
nice and then crush him that's my goal
Iman your quick thoughts on that
interview too in the comments about
sorry I think chess needs more you know
direct comments like that yeah hey Yuri
has got to be the on paper favorite and
it just doesn't get set out loud enough
so yeah I'm glad he said it I think it's
probably true objectively and uh you
know he's either gonna eat his words
right or he's gonna have that uh you
know Trash Talk backed up and move it on
to the next yeah you put it out there
too right about like well I might but if
I get smoked if he does destroy me yeah
yeah I did say that he caught himself
yeah he has the contingency plan I got a
hug from Digger
my kids were up too late I had a call
back home
last thing though like how do you feel
like these guys match up we talked about
the uh you know the the trash talk or
the emotions how do you feel Geary and
Sauron match up stylistically on paper
it's a great question I think that for
nihal songs to be a very tough pairing
because Anish is very solid in the
opening extremely well prepared and we
saw in the match against seven Niha made
some huge mistakes now Anish made
perhaps the biggest blunder with
allowing this bishop to be captured and
when he had a draw in the bag so it's
not like there are no mistakes coming
from these giri but those mistakes tend
to happen later in the scrambles which
nihal thrives in but earlier stages when
they have a few minutes left on the
clock the more time the better it is for
a niche that was his ultimate point I
agree with that I don't think that means
he's going to just win the match but I
do think that means he's the favorite
yeah it's interesting because you could
argue that both players are very battle
tested nihal Sauron had to make a
comeback he was trailing Anish never
trailed in this match even though he did
lose and win an Armageddon right so you
have those questions who's going to be
more battle tested the guy who had to
win an Armageddon to get here the guy
who had to complete a comeback it's
going to be an interesting match of
course and uh there's a there's another
interesting matchup as well we we want
to talk about Wesley so and his battle
with Hikaru Nakamura but before we do
that uh we're gonna throw things back
over to Donya and Levy because they are
waiting with the brave move of the day
we are indeed thank you Danny that was
fantastic coverage and discussion and we
are indeed here for the brave move of
the day in which we highlight a key move
or set of moves that decided the outcome
of one of our mattress today and we're
going to dig into a crucial game in the
match between nihal Serene and Samuel
sevyan a moment that turned this match
around a moment that secured victory for
any Hall the moment comes in the
position in front of you Levy seems like
nihal is worse seems like Savion is the
one turning the match around about to
tie it and then lo and behold yeah
things are looking dark here for sarin
they look dark a couple of times in this
match and the only move on the board for
him that doesn't lose on the spot is the
move C4 and he what he does with this
move is he poses several problems to the
black position are you going to bring a
rook here you're going to take with the
pawn and give up the control of the D5
square and black has multiple choices
but time is ticking and as a couple of
Trades come in I almost want to give
this a second bravery let's give it two
Brave moves tonight reroutes to a home
square and goes back into the center of
the board and starts posing problems
making Savion play defensively and to
find these ideas with seconds taking
down on the clock just incredible yeah
this was amazing and even the way he
followed up if we want a third move
great move the day Rook C1 and Rook fd1
look how generous he is one Rook steps
away making space for the other Rook
with this move nihal completes the
rearranging of his pieces the landscape
of the position changes completely
savions queenside is now riddled with
weaknesses and although the position
remained relatively unbalanced and
topsy-turvy nihal kept his composure and
eventually with more brilliant night
Maneuvers dropping his Knight back to D1
eliminating Sam sebian's remaining
active piece C5 was another mistake and
ultimately was nihal Stern keeping the
nerves alive and winning the match with
just a brilliant brilliant sequence he
is such such a just a phenomenal player
especially in time pressure Knight B1 C4
those were our brave moves of the day
remember it's time to make your move
from chrome to Brave try it now at
brave.com chess and now we will send it
back without further Ado to our hosts in
the playing Hall Danny take it away
thank you Don your great break down
there what a turnaround nihal sarin we
were calling him mini Hikaru out there
with his ability to resourcefully hold
those weird positions so again amazing
stuff all right well let's talk about
what that means for the bracket we've
already mentioned a few times the two
guys who won earlier Hikaru Nakamura and
Wesley so will be playing in that first
semi-final matchup you see at the top
and then of course Anish Geary will be
playing here from Toronto against the
only man still standing in Serbia that
is Nihao sorry and he he will continue
to join us from Belgrade and so much so
much to break down here so guys let's
talk about tomorrow's schedule real
quick uh this is the the matchups that
will kick off first once again you have
Hikaru Nakamura versus Wesley so Anish
giri and Nihao Sauron will start not
very far after that with the slight
staggers we have that allow our
commentators to focus on the moments
that they want to uh now now let's talk
about these matchups guys so we've
talked a whole bunch about Geary and
Soren given the great interview that
Gary gave us let's go back to the
matchup on paper between the two
Americans guys that have played each
other many times in their career
certainly Rivals there's no denying that
Amman will go and reverse her here
kickoff to you who do you who do you I'm
actually I'm not gonna actually make
your pick production wouldn't like that
but what are your thoughts about that
match going in between those two well
Danny the first thing that stands out to
me is that Hikaru Nakamura is in an
interesting position he's one of the
only guys that has face-to-face matches
back to back and it could even be the
case if he wins this match and yeah it
goes that way he might just have a very
normal tournament from his perspective
where not everyone is getting that
experience some people are playing guys
as you said in Serbia and so I think
that might be making Nakamura feel more
comfortable and I think it's kind of
showing in his play so that's one
observation that I had that I think the
Nakamura is just comfortable with the
format he can look across see his
opponent there and that's always been
you know where he plays his best chest
so I like him in this match what about
the argument though that's so after that
missed Gaff of Maiden 2 and in game one
against ondraken has just gotten better
and better he's got to be feeling pretty
pretty good going up against the car oh
absolutely of course he's gotten better
with it but it's just Hikaru we know
he's dominant I mean every Tuesday what
he does the man is dominating everything
Mr world champion say it twice you know
what I mean like that's that's him right
so I think he has obviously he's going
to be in her comfortable I think he's in
his element like uh Iman said too
sitting right across from you we've done
this before it's just another day in the
office right well except I think Wesley
might want his title back who was the
Fisher random world champion before hit
Cairo that was Wesley so if Carl just
got one now Wesley saying you know I go
head to head with this guy in the speed
chess championships he's playing all
throughout the rapid Chess Championship
season so I feel like these two are
actually pretty tight they were actually
working together uh in Reykjavik on
those positions when they were revealed
they were collaborating just like what's
the best plan so they become friends
more so but now they're foes and the
momentum has to be in Wesley's favor
Hikaru couldn't have started better four
out of four today he actually lost more
games than he won Wesley was like well
on draken he's got a shot people say he
can come back down three to one that end
game Exquisite technique and great time
management so I feel like Wesley should
be feeling pretty good about himself
Wesley won the first ever Fisher random
World Chess Championship this is the
first ever Global Chess Championship if
history repeats itself maybe Wesley's
thinking in his head I've been here
winning these events the first time
their inaugural kick off I'm on you
think maybe he thinks that yeah I think
it's a guarantee Danny yeah he win the
first time of every event you play it
but uh no he's he's got to be feeling
good and you know Wesley is definitely
playing right now in a comfortable way
Hikaru is a little bit shaken up after
those those losses but I think as Robert
said Wesley's feeling comfortable and uh
you know I think I like his his chances
but he's up against Hikaru Danny and uh
he carves not easy for anybody everyone
keeps saying you think he can hear us
here like every everybody's saying hey
you know you're up against a car I know
this I know I know well several people
will be up against Hikaru in the SEC
coming up remember we announced earlier
so let's remind everybody that the SCC
is back with these 14 confirmed players
the main event begins Monday November
21st with the participants including
world champion Magnus Carlson Arjun
irigaisi Hikaru Nakamura Yana Palm Nashi
and two more qualifiers of course will
earn their way into the tournament
there's a hundred thousand dollars on
the line you don't want to miss the most
exciting the most exciting event in
chess I would say besides sudden death
dodgeball that's another story the most
exciting speech has Championship type
SCC in the chat for more all right
everybody that completes our coverage of
the cgc quarterfinals from Toronto
thanks for joining us once again also
big thanks to Robert Canty Amman and all
of our commentators this has been
another great day of live chess we have
our four players set for the cgc
semifinals so we're not done yet this
week okay remember that make sure to
join us tomorrow on Twitch and YouTube
as we begin day one of the semi-finals
the chess starts at noon Eastern Time
that's 9 A.M Pacific for now I'm Danny
wrench that was hikara Nakamura right
there leaning in that was Anish Geary
doing his thing uh and uh Sam's heavy on
behind him this has been this has been
awesome thank you for being with us once
again I'm Danny wrench have a great day
have a good night and we'll see you
tomorrow from Toronto
foreign
[Music]
come on
side
[Music]
foreign